hey this is Andrew Brown over here on
free cocam bringing you another free
Cloud certification and this time it's
the hashicorp terraform associate
version three and the way we're going to
achieve certification is through lecture
content Hands-On labs and as always I
provide you a free practice exam and so
at the end of the day you're going to
get that certification and you could put
it on your resume on your LinkedIn to
demonstrate that devops skills and try
to go get that cloud or devops role
you've been looking for or trying to
upgrade to so if you like the materials
here a great way to support more content
like this is to look at the paid
additional materials it will also help
you increase the odds on your exam and
it also really does help out and support
the production of more of this kind of
content and if you are not familiar with
me I produce a lot of different kinds of
cloud certification courses like AWS
Azure kubernetes you name it I've taught
it and so you're in really good hands
and we'll see you in class soon ciao
foreign
[Music]
everybody it's Andrew Brown and welcome
to the start of our journey and we're
asking the most important question first
which is what is terraform and I just
want to tell you that I'm on screen now
but I'm going to vanish here shortly and
stay out of the way so that you can see
the full content but I just wanted to
know you to know that I'm here with you
the entire way okay so the terraform
associate certification is a specialty
certification in terraform terraform is
a technology produced by hashicorp and
it's specifically for infrastructures of
code and it's a declarative
infrastructure as a code and it's a
cloud agnostic infrastructure as a code
we will dive into all of this in great
detail in the introduction section and
just notice that I put an asterisk there
on declarative because there is
something special about terraform that
we will discover if you are considering
the terraform associate then you most
likely are looking for a devops role you
want to automate infrastructure or
writing scripts you want to work with
multiple Cloud providers or you know you
enjoy designing iterating on end-to-end
infrastructure life cycle so if this
sounds like anything that you are
interested in then you would probably
want to take this certification I want
to tell you that terraform is one of the
most in-demand skills for devops rules
today and it's becoming quickly the
industry standard just because it is so
flexible and works with all providers
and goes beyond a lot of these other
tools and the terraform associate exam
itself isn't that difficult
uh but I would say that the concept of
learning terraform is a bit tricky
because uh you know it's not something
that you can just go do the lecture
content uh and and do the lab content I
had to do a mix of it uh so in this
course you'll see me do lecture lab
lecture lab because I'm trying to
solidify the knowledge as soon as we do
that this is not the format that I use
for my other courses it's just because
with terraform it requires patience it
is a silical learning process to
understand so just uh stick with it and
by the end of it you will be really good
with terraform uh you know and so that's
that there so let's talk about our
multi-cloud roadmap I'm going to get out
of the way so we have a little bit more
room
um and so you know what I would
recommend uh is that you start with an
Associate certification so just getting
my pen tool out here uh if I can get it
here here we have the Google's Ace
um the cloud engineer or maybe some
level of AWS uh associate certification
I personally think the sysops is the
best pairing for terraform or the Azure
administrator if you're going for Azure
and quite possibly learning more than
two would be very beneficial but of
course whatever your primary provider
you're using is where you're going to
benefit with uh terraform and you really
should learn this stuff before you do
terraform it is super hard to learn both
cloud and terraform at the same time you
should have that Foundation before you
tackle onto terraform and so there's a
lot of different paths for multi-cloud
and just to kind of give you an idea of
all the different ways you can go you
know you can go from associate to either
Vault and to the Vault professional if
you're looking at a security background
but it's very common for people to get
the terraform and then go for
uh Vault afterwards but you know it's up
to you to which path you want to take
how long do you have to study to pass
this exam well uh it's a spectrum based
on where your background is so let's
take a look at beginners first so a
beginner to me would be someone that's
never written IC uh they have not
previously focused on automating
infrastructure they might may not hold
an associate level certification so
you're adding those additional hours or
trying to make up the difference you
could be looking at 30 hours or more if
you're already experienced with writing
IAC but maybe just not terraform maybe
you know Azure bicep or cloud formation
you already work in devops you're
already comfortable writing scripts and
you hold associate level certification
knowledge of you know a major cloud
provider then you're looking at
something like 12 hours but you know if
you're looking for a general study guide
somewhere in between I would recommend
between one to two hours a day for 14
days and you'll be in a really good
place by then you know what does it take
to pass this exam well there is a
lecture content and I have a lot of it
um you know the thing is that
the exam itself is very practical it's
not like AWS aws's exams where it's very
um uh Theory based at a conceptual level
this one is very much how do we use this
technology and so the lecture content is
there to really support the lab content
and you really really need to do the lab
content uh because that's the nature of
this exam
um and to make this a lot easier I do
recommend taking some practice exams we
have a free practice exam and we also
have uh many more practice exams if you
take all these Pax exams and you've done
the labs prior to that you're going to
be in really good shape to pass in terms
of the content outline
um I can't remember how many domains
we'll see how many there are but we have
one so understand infrastructure as code
so I see Concepts understand the purpose
of terraform
understand terraform Basics the use of
terraform outside core workflows
interact with terraform modules
use the core terraform workflow
Implement and maintain State regenerate
and modify configuration
and understand terraform Cloud
capabilities so yeah nine domains uh
something that's different about uh the
hashicorp certifications is they do not
provide distribution of domains what do
I mean by that well they're not weighted
right so it's not like uh we know that
uh like eight is I'm going to have a
particular weighting that's higher but
we can look at the exam guide outline to
see generally how many questions we
probably would so we could kind of infer
our own waiting but they do not provide
it so I would just say it's not known
but we'll take our best guess when we
look at the full exam guide outline
where do you take this exam well you can
take it in an in-person test center or
online from the convenience of your own
home I do believe that the test center
that hashicorp is using is PSI or PSI
online and understand that this is a
proctored exam so someone is supervising
you watching you monitoring you as you
take the exam so that you uh that
there's no funny business happening
there's no cheating and to ensure that
uh you know that you gain gain that
knowledge in a reputable way so just
understand that in terms of the grading
you need to get about 70 percent to pass
or round that it uses scaled scoring uh
is it possible for you to fail if you've
got exactly 70 percent it might be so
always aim to get higher than 70 percent
um and so I always say aim for a target
of you know 10 to 15 above what the
score is if you're getting that on your
prax exams then you're going to be in
good shape in terms of the response
types they don't tell you exactly how
many questions there are but I've always
observed there's 57 questions and so you
know based on that calculation I feel
that you have 70 17 questions you can
get wrong there are no penalties for
wrong questions so always answer your
questions do not leave any blank the
format of the questions is multiple
choice and multiple answer and then
sometimes you get a fill in the blank so
type a one word answer most likely it's
going to be a command right so or a flag
for a command so you definitely have to
know the technical components of
terraform okay the duration of the exam
is one hour so that means you get about
a minute to answer per questions the
questions are very short format so it's
not like you have to read a ton of text
to figure out what's going on the exam
time is 60 Minutes the seat time is
actually 90 minutes so when we say C
time referring to the amount of time you
should allocate for the exam so that
means that would include things like
time to review the instructions show uh
show the online proctored your workspace
to make sure there's nothing going funny
on with your environment read and accept
the NDA complete the exam provide
feedback at the end and I'm going to
tell you you really do want to get for
your exam much sooner than you think
because it is a very stressful process
and things tend to always go wrong when
when you uh when you don't show up early
enough okay so just make sure you do
that if you do pass this exam it's going
to be valid for 24 months so that's two
years before recertification and the
last thing I just want to talk about is
um well maybe not the last thing I got
two more slides here for you but this
course is going to be designed around
the
1.1.6.0 specification of terraform
and even when I'm making this course as
of today 1.60 is an alpha this will be
in the future so 1.60 will be out but I
like to try to give you more knowledge
in the future even if it's not an exam
just so that you are prepared and this
course does not go stale sooner
terraform is always incrementing
inversion so you know when you study you
always want to go back three minor
versions since I'm showing 1.60 it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense but if
you're let's say you're on 1.54 you'd
want to do one you want to make sure you
know terraform for a range of versions
going a few versions back and so so you
know I will be showing you things that
may be deprecated but are still uh but
might still be in use based on the
version that people are using so just
understand that
um and again you know these these
certifications are or the terraform
certification is heavily dependent on
your practical knowledge so if you are
taking the time to apply the knowledge
uh this version difference differencing
is not going to make a big difference
okay
um so just make sure you know you put
the time in with the labs
um now this is the third version of the
certification and so I just kind of want
to tell you that not a whole lot has
changed between version zero zero two
and zero zero three uh the one of the
big differences is they change the badge
design why I don't know uh is it better
who cares
um but uh it is a different looking
badge
um one thing is that there were
superficial name changes to the outlines
of the domain so basically all the
domains are the same they just kind of
did some tweaks there they did kind of
cut some content out in the uh the like
first uh first first two domains because
those ones were just more General
concept of knowledge and so they slim
those down I'm leaving that content in
this course because I think it's very
valuable to know more rounded knowledge
there so you're going to be over
prepared for those first two domains
there used to be this thing called
provisioners it's still in terraform but
the thing is that it's just no longer
needed to know in the exam so this is
about doing remote execution annoying
all the provisioners and so I mean local
execute and remote execute are things
you need to learn and definitely
something that you will use on the job
but knowing how to provision and use a
lot of Provisions is no longer a focus
there
there's this thing called null resource
that we learn about and now they have a
new thing called terraform data so that
is a evolution of terraform data so
we'll still learn about null resource
but we'll also learn terraform data
where it makes more sense to use
uh you know terraform Tate had taint has
been replaced with uh just a flag uh
called hyphen hyphen uh uh replace uh on
the terraform plan and we have a few
more others like that so refresh has a
flag
um and uh the thing was is that when I
made this exam the first time they were
already talking about doing this so This
exam is already
um my previous one is up to date with
the current version of zero zero three
if that if that's surprising here uh
terraform workspace is no longer part of
the exam
um I would still cover terraform
workspace uh you know if we come across
it because I still think again it's
practical knowledge that you should know
um connecting to terraform Cloud now
uses its own cloud block instead of
remote block
um I believe that we can still use
remote block here and I will definitely
test that in the in the
um in the uh the labs in this course so
you know it's good to know both of them
but the focus will be using uh Cloud
block
um we have the lock file so the lock.hcl
files are new
um I mean they weren't new when I made
the previous exam so they were already
in there so again I already had this
content here
um but I'm just pointing out that that's
something that they're focusing on uh
within the certification here
um you need to know how to Mark data as
being sensitive again that's something I
had in the older exam but one major
thing is terraform cloud has a new UI
and it looks like there's a lot more
functionality so in terms of the old
exam or a course that I produce and this
one I'm definitely going to have to
reshoot all of terraform cloud and go
deeper into it there's obviously a few
different functionalities that have been
added like the terraform Cloud block the
terraform data block
um but you know for the most part
there's not a whole lot that has changed
so the majority of this will be very
similar to the last one but I'm just
touching up and improving lab content
where we can and hopefully adding a lot
more additional content to expand the
terraform knowledge that I wasn't able
to do the first time around so hopefully
that gives you a good idea of what
you're getting yourself into uh but yeah
we will proceed forward to looking at
the exam guide
foreign
Brown and welcome back as we are taking
a look at the exam guide uh for the
hashicorp terraform associate
certification I want to tell you uh
throughout this course I'm going to show
you where I get things so I will be
going to Google I will be typing in
where things are it's not because I
don't know where things are I'm doing
that for your benefits so that you build
up the skill to know how to find things
just the way that I would go find things
and I'll be very transparent about that
so for this one all I did was go into
Google and type in terraform exam guide
and so I found it here this is also the
place where you can register for the
exam so if you click this it should load
up certain metrics I'll make a pop-up
you have to authenticate it I'm not
showing that here right now but when you
are ready to register for the exam you
can go ahead and do that you'll notice
they also have this button here called
prepare for the exam they have their own
study guide here it's very text based
heavy I do believe that somewhere in
here there is a way to launch tutorials
and this will launch sandbox
environments I think through instruct at
least the last time I checked those are
great if you don't have an environment
set up what I want to do with you is I
want I want you to set everything up in
your own environment because I want you
to have those Real World skills so you
can use this stuff adjacent to this
course I've gone through all this
material here I'm trying to cover things
that aren't in here and try to make sure
that we are doing things without guard
rails without the bowling bumpers
because I want you get that Real World
Experience okay but I do want to point
out that this is here and you can use it
um and it's okay so let's scroll down
and take a look at our exam guide here
and so here they say we have some
prerequisites so they say basic terminal
skills that makes sense we're going to
be doing a lot of stuff uh in terminal
basic understanding of on-premise and
Cloud architecture uh I think what they
really mean is do you know how to use
AWS you know how to use Azure gcp what
is your major uh cloud provider or or
stuff like that um now I keep talking or
focusing on AWS Azure gcp but understand
that terraform can be used for anything
as long as there is a provider for it it
can provision on almost anything okay
and that's why they're being very
generic in their description this says
the product version tested is terraform
1.00 and higher so it shows you that
this is still even though it's the zero
zero three it's still really the zero
zero two exam with some minor tweaks but
just understand in this course we're
going to go well beyond this because I'm
just future proofing you and making sure
you have Real World skills let's scroll
on down here
and let's just it's about renewing your
certification so if you hold an
unexpired terraform associate 002
certification
uh you can take the new one starting 18
months after your previous exam if you
hold an unexpired one you can take the
new exam starting 18 months after your
previous exam uh if you hold an expired
one you're eligible to recertify at any
time I really like this because what
happens for me with certifications not a
problem for you but problem for me is
that I will sit a certification and then
nine months later the new one comes out
and I can't sit the new one and tell you
about it so it looks like we've gotten a
bit of flexibility there and again I'm
on video here I will get out of the way
um it's just that we're in the uh these
earlier videos and I want to just hang
out here with you okay going down below
we can confirm it's the one hour
duration this is seventy dollars it
might vary based on your location and
other stuff you I just don't want to
tell you that 70 I want you to go
through the process and find out
yourself but that's probably what it's
going to cost you
um there is no free retake included
um some certifications like CompTIA you
are basically or uh the kubernetes ones
from looks Foundation you basically get
a retake so you're basically paying a
love for two and they call it a free
retake which it really isn't free but uh
I think this is okay
um I think it's fine there's no retake
it's in English expires in two years we
covered that before let's take a look at
the exam objectives so the first one is
understand infrastructure as a code and
Concepts they used to have a bunch of
junk in here
um and honestly I didn't even know what
they were talking about when they said
that I remember I had to comb through uh
the study guide and try to watch uh
articles and stuff like that but I think
they realized
that it was junk uh that they were
trying to uh impart too much conceptual
stuff and they cut back this one here
same thing with two
it doesn't show us the comparison of the
old one at some point on this website
they showed the comparative between zero
zero two and zero zero three
but all I'm saying is that they cut back
here I have a bit more content on this
in the course it's not going to hurt you
to watch it it's just going to help you
understand it but you're not going to be
tested 100 on this stuff the other thing
I want to note is that for each point
that is here each subdomain or or Point
whatever you want to call it they're
going to ask you a question on this is
very different uh way of Designing uh an
exam uh other exams like AWS they will
they will list a bunch of stuff but they
say it might not be on the exam or it
might have stuff that are that's outside
of it so you just have to broadly study
and uh you'll over over study for the
content because you just don't know what
you're going to get uh get on the exam
for hashicorp exams they're very fair if
you know each of these points you can
expect to see them generally on the exam
and that's how you're going to know that
you are ready if you if you know all
these things in this course we're going
to go beyond that because again I want
you to have those Real World skills but
just feel confidence in knowing every
single point Point here going down here
understand terraform Basics install and
version terraform providers so that is
what we will be doing a lot of in this
because we're going to at least touch
more than one provider in this course
I'm not going to go in great detail on
uh the cloud infrastructure part of it
because you're already supposed to know
it
um and I'm going to leave that for other
things doing future projects for
specific uh for for specific Cloud
providers we're focused here on
terraform in this course not the
underlying providers but we do use
multiple ones here describe plug-in
based architecture write terraform
configuration using multiple providers
describe how terraform finds and fetches
providers so you can see there is a a
lot of stuff about providers not to be
confused with provisioners I said
earlier that provisioners is no longer
covered in this certification course but
again the materials here so you can
learn it for real world practice use
terraform outside of core of core
workflows I think this used to be like
you use terraform CLI outside of core
workflows so they made a small tweak
there so it says destroy describe when
to use terraform import to import
existing infrastructure into your
terraform State terraform import is
super super powerful going over to other
providers uh you know for a long time
AWS did not have an import option and so
the idea is that by having this import
we can bring an infrastructure that was
not necessarily there before we have
terraform state to view our terraform
State something that you're going to
find unique to terraform is State
Management it's something that's super
important and it's probably the hardest
Concept in terraform because when you
use something like cloud formation or
Azure bicep the state is managed by
services on those providers
there isn't a managed service
managed service on those providers and
so you have to decide where you want to
put your State uh and one example would
be terraform cloud and that's one that
we do use in this in this course here
describe one to enable verbose logging
and what the outcome is so you have to
know how to debug things here which is
great interact with terraform module so
contrast and use different module Source
options including public terraform
module registry interact with modules
inputs and outputs describe variable
scope and module child modules set
module versions modules is a way of
creating reusable code
uh we are going to use uh public
libraries as well as uh make our own
modules making modules is not as hard as
you would imagine but they can get very
complex uh so you know we're not going
to go super Advanced into modules but we
are going to make sure we can write our
own and and use public ones use the
terraform uh use the terraform workflow
so this is something we're going to have
to know a lot about which is just the
general life cycle workflow of working
with infrastructure as code so we have a
knit validate plan apply destroy format
plan it apply are the ones we're going
to be using a lot of there is a lot of
trickery with the init so that's
something else that we'll do there as
well Implement and maintain state so
maintaining State working with State
super super important so we'll look at
how it works with local state state
locking handling back-end Cloud
Integrations authentication methods uh
you know they're talking about managed
providers like terraform Cloud
the different between remote State
back-end options manage resource drift
and terraform State terraform is super
good at drift and fixing drift it's so
good at remediation compared to other
IEC tools and that's why it is such a
popular tool to use describe back-end
block and Cloud integration
configuration understand secret
management and state files then we have
regenerate modify configuration so
demonstrate the use of variable
variables and outputs describe secure
secret injection best practices
understand the use of collection and
structural types create and
differentiate resource and data
configuration use resource addressing
and resource parameters to connect
resources together
use HCL and terraform functions to write
configuration describe built-in
dependency management
and the last one here is understand
terraform Cloud capabilities so explain
how terraform clouds helps to manage
infrastructure describe how terraform
Cloud enables collaboration government
governance I'm going to tell you right
now we're going to probably do more
terraform Cloud than we we need to it's
just because when I made this course the
first time I I just lightly did
terraform Cloud just enough to pass the
exam I have the time to do a little bit
more there I would like to do that for
your own benefit and so we will expand
on that a bit more but you can see this
is mostly about terraform the technology
not necessarily terraform Cloud the uh
the service if you're confused about
terraform and terraform Cloud uh again
we'll explain that in this course and
make sure it's very clear what the
difference is one other thing I wanted
to notice that you do have some sample
questions here so you can go through
here and you can just see that the
questions are very straightforward and
they're just like this they're very
simple uh but you know you do have to
know
you do have to know what you're looking
at and see like here they're showing
code so you can see you have to choose
code and you might get a code block so
it is very focused on the Practical
component of it it's less about the
conceptual okay but yeah hopefully that
gives you an idea of what we're getting
into and we'll see in the next one okay
ciao foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and what I want to do is walk you
through a few of our practices and
questions just to give you an idea of
what it will be like on the real exam
and where we might have had to make some
adjustments to help your study so what
you'd have to do to access this prax
exam is you'd have to be signed up and
logged in to the exam Pro platform make
a way over to the hashicorp terraform
course except the free tier or pay for
full access but once you go there you'll
scroll all the way down to the bottom
and you should see three or four
products exams at the time of writing
this we're still writing the questions
so that's why they're not shown in the
video here but what I want you to do is
to go to the first practice exam and
notice that there are 57 questions you
get an hour on on the exam here and we
have a breakdown based on domain now the
percentage is not something that uh
terraform or hashicorp provides so we
just had to break it down based on the
coverage of questions that we saw in the
exam guide outline and so that should be
accurate enough and that's kind of what
it felt like on the exam so I don't
think that's going to be a problem if we
click into here we're just going to look
at some of the questions I'll talk
around them so the first one here is we
have how do you create a workspace and
it's showing us a bunch of CLI commands
and so on the exam you do need to know
um uh you know CLI commands and the
difference of them and the questions can
be as simple as this where you're just
choosing the option and some are obvious
distractors like there isn't there is no
one called terraform workspace Branch
okay so just understand that you not
just need to know the conceptual ideas
behind terraform but also it in practice
okay
another one here would be the terraform
registry can search based on the
following Search terms we have an option
to choose multiple questions and so this
is something that you will see on the
exam where you're choosing multiples of
something I didn't get a lot on my exam
but I cannot say for certain like how
many questions would show up like this
um but you know they're not really that
hard to figure out okay and this
question is about
um a tool or sorry uh the public
terraform registry website and that is
just a uh a public-facing website if we
go to
registry.terraform.io here it's this
website here so it's not just the
tooling of terraform itself but it's the
ecosystem around it so terraform Cloud
the terraform registry things like that
another type of question you will see
and I think it's over here is what they
will do is they'll ask you to fill in
the blank now we don't have that support
in our platform just as of yet but the
idea is they'll say like okay uh we'll
ask you a question or we'll even give
you
um maybe they'll have like underscores
they'll say fill in this thing and
you'll literally have to type type the
answer in but the answer is going to be
like a one word answer so on the exam I
literally had a question which was like
where is the API stored and it was
actually terraformed at TF state but I
did not know I could not recall the name
of it which is kind of embarrassing but
uh you know that is the level of
fill-ins that you'll have to do and
you're very likely to see some code on
the on the exam two so if I just click
through here really quickly you may see
a code block okay and you might have to
decipher it so that's the difficulty
exam I would not say this is a heart
exam but you just have to understand the
scope of those kind of questions and
make sure that you have well-rounded
study in both practical and conceptual
concepts of terraform so hopefully that
helps you out okay
[Music]
everybody there it's Andrew Brown and I
just wanted to tell you about the
content that you're going through
because honestly between the zero zero
two and zero zero three there was not
much to update
um and so you know the key differences
is the versions of terraform and the
versions of the providers that you are
using
um and for the most part everything
worked out perfectly fine I thought that
I'd have to reshoot all of the lab
content but it turns out nope barely
nothing has changed what has changed and
I want to point this out early on is
that when you are specifying a version
for the provider just go use at least
version five zero you can use an older
version if you want to follow along but
uh you know I think it's better to be
more um up to date if you can the
version that we were using prior in the
follow alongs was version three again
there are no major changes that will
break anything
um so at least there shouldn't be but I
ran through these Labs my cloud support
engineer ran through these Labs so we're
pretty confident you're going to be in
good shape otherwise if they weren't I
would go re-record them but I just
wanted to point out those two things uh
there so hopefully you know that makes
sense and you're going to be in good
shape okay now I did say that we're
scoping things around terraform 1.6.0
and again there's not much to call out
for that the biggest thing that I think
that 1.6.0 might bring would be testing
and even if I looked into it and it just
wasn't where I thought it was going to
be so I did not include it at least at
this time in uh this uh this this course
and again this is me going uh above and
beyond because I'm trying to just future
proof the contents of this course and
future proof uh stuff that I believe
that is coming to terraform form but
yeah you should be in good shape and you
know if there are any changes on exam
Pro we're very proactive of having those
differences there so if you do run into
anything that's giving you any kind of
issue they're going to be on the the
main learning platform there okay if if
for whatever reason there's minor
updates or things that are found out but
yeah you'll be in good shape and have
fun on your journey learning terraform
ciao
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at what is
infrastructure as code and before we
talk about that we need to talk about
the problem with manual configuration so
manually configuring your Cloud
infrastructure allows you to easily
start using new cloud service offerings
to quickly prototype architectures
however it comes with a few downsides so
it's easy to misconfigure a service
through human error it's hard to manage
the expected state of the configuration
for compliance it's hard to transfer
configuration knowledge to other team
members and so this is why
infrastructure code is going to really
help us out so infrastructure is code
commonly abbreviated to IAC and you'll
see that a lot in this course allows you
to write a configuration script to
automate creating updating or destroying
Cloud infrastructure notice I gave great
emphasis on automate or automation
because that is really key to
infrastructure as code IEC could also be
thought of as a blueprint of your
infrastructure IEC allows you to easily
share version or inventory your Cloud
infrastructure and just to kind of get
your visualization imagine you write a
script and that's going to provision and
launch a bunch of cloud services that
are all interconnected okay
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look at
popular IAC tools and so of course this
course is about terraform but by
understanding um all the options out
there if you understand why we're using
terraform uh and one thing that is very
important to understand is the
difference between declarative and
imperative IAC tools those are the broad
categories that we see for IAC so let's
start with declarative so the idea here
is what you see is what you get
everything's explicit it's more verbose
but there's zero chance of
misconfiguration and this all relies on
the fact that they use a scripting
language such as Json yaml XML in the
case of terraform they have their own
language called HCL but the way these
languages are structured is that they're
very verbose and there's not a lot of
programming logic involved so for Azure
we have arm templates and Azure
blueprints for AWS we have cloud
formation for Google we have Cloud
deployment manager and there there is of
course terraform which has many cloud
service providers such as AWS Azure gcp
kubernetes and a lot more
but these are all in the declarative
category
on the right hand side we have
imperative so you say what you want and
the rest is filled in everything here is
implicit it's less verbose but you could
end up with misconfiguration and when I
say that it's that like if you were to
find
um let's say a virtual machine you might
not have to provide every single uh
option that you would normally do and it
would fill in the rest but if you
weren't aware of what it was doing
that's where you could end up with
misconfiguration uh though I would say
that imperative tools generally try to
always uh have their defaults as best
practices so you're not usually in a bad
position uh but you know you might end
up with something you don't expect
imperative can do more than declarative
so there's just some very hard
limitations with declarative languages
so there's just cases where you want to
do imperative and the idea here is
imperative languages use programming
language you know like python Ruby
JavaScript golang you know whatever it
is uh there's likely an SDK for it and
so it's just a lot more programmer
friendly a lot of developers like
imperative tools so AWS has their own
called Cloud development kit cdk and it
technically only supports AWS I say
technically because hashicorp has a very
cool library that allows you to generate
out terraform HCL files which allows you
to work with anything but when we're
just talking about cdk on its own it's
just for AWS then you have plumy it
supports AWS Azure gcp and kubernetes so
it can do a lot so why would you choose
with your team to use declarative over
imperative well it just really depends
on your your team right so like if
they're all used to if they're all
administrators and they're used to using
Json yaml and they're not good with
programming languages that is one reason
why you might want to use declarative
over imperative the other thing is just
you know you prefer to know exactly
every single thing that was defined
right you don't want anything left up to
a chance and so that is another reason
why you might want to use declarative
but both are great options it's just
really depends depends on your team's
knowledge and what your goals are okay
[Music]
so we just looked at imperative and
declarative but I just want to clarify
that terraform even though it's a
declarative language it has
imperative-like features so I've coined
the phrase declarative plus and so
terraform kind of gives you the best of
both worlds so you have declarative and
imperative and then the three types so
our yaml Json XML we have terraform
language which actually utilizes HCL
underneath and then you have programming
languages on the right hand side like
Ruby python JavaScript what it have you
right so when we're looking at yaml or
Json these are very limited languages or
scripting languages where uh you know
you don't really have any kind of
complex data types you probably don't
have a whole lot of robust functions but
in some cases you can extend That Base
Behavior so in the case of cloud
formation which uses yaml or Json files
they have a concept called macros so you
can extend it a bit but again it's very
inflexible and so a lot of people are
led to go and use cdk so terraform is
great because it kind of has a lot of
stuff you'd see in programming languages
like for Loops Dynamic blocks locals it
also has complex data structures and a
lot of functions around using those data
structures and so it allows you to stay
in that declarative world but having the
stuff that you generally need when
you're in the parative world when you're
in the imperative side the idea is that
the language is what you're utilizing so
you can do anything that the program
language allows you to do but I just
wanted to kind of show you that
terraform sits in the middle okay
[Music]
hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we are looking at infrastructure life
cycle so what is infrastructure
lifecycle it's the idea of having
clearly defined and distinct work phases
which are used by devops Engineers to
plan design build test deliver maintain
and retire Cloud infrastructure where
we're talking about like sdlc so
software development life cycle there's
usually a really great visual that I can
show for you but for infrastructure
lifecycle especially Cloud
infrastructure lifecycle there isn't
something that is well defined which is
weird by the definition but I think that
there's just nobody's agreed up on one
yet or nobody's made the graphic yet so
I just don't have anything to show you
for that but I just want you to get
familiar with the term infrastructure
life cycle because you're likely to hear
it again but one particular
infrastructure life cycle that is pretty
common is ones that talk about day zero
day one and day two so the idea here is
this is a simplified way to describe
phases of infrastructure life cycle so
when we say we are on day Zero we are
planning and designing our
infrastructure on day one we are
developing and iterating it so we might
be uh you know deploying or provisioning
it and actually testing it uh in the
cloud and then day two is actually when
we go live with real production users
and maintain it and the idea of
mentioning day zero one and two is to
say Well when does IAC start and the
idea is it starts on Day Zero okay the
days do not literally mean a 24 hour day
it's just a broad way of defining where
in the infrastructure project we would
be okay
[Music]
so after defining what infrastructure
life cycle is what advantage or what an
advancement are we going to have when we
add IAC to our infrastructure lifecycle
well the first thing we're going to get
is reliability so IC makes changes
impotent consistent repeatable and
predictable I'm going to give extra
attention here to impotent because it is
a very strange English word but no
matter how many times you run your IC
you will always end up with the same
state that is expected that is a very
important concept of IEC whereas if you
use configuration management there's no
guarantee of that that's why you use
terraform over something like ansible
okay you have manageability so enable
mutation via code revise with minimal
changes and then you have sensibility so
avoid financial and reputational losses
to even loss of life when considering
government and Military dependencies on
infrastructure so there you go
[Music]
okay so it impotent is a very important
concept to infrastructure as code and so
we're going to give it a little bit more
attention I wouldn't stress out about
the pronunciation uh there's more than
one way to pronounce it in English and
I've probably even said it wrong uh in
the previous slide so uh just be uh
forgiving on that part okay but the idea
is that let's stage a scenario between a
non-itipotent example and an independent
example so when I deploy my IAC config
file it will provision and launch two
virtual machines that is what I'm
expecting okay and that is what I get
but what happens when I go and I update
this infrastructure code file saying
maybe I want to increase the size of the
VMS or some of the configuration I
deploy that again when it's
non-edepotent what will end up happening
is I will end up with two additional
virtual machines with the new
configuration and the old ones will be
there and so this is something you might
not want because you just want to have a
file that says exactly the state that
you expect okay
so when we have something that is Idi
potent the idea is we will go and we
will Define our two virtual machines and
we will get our two virtual machines but
we go and we update that file and we
deploy again and what happens this time
is it just ends up modifying the
original virtual machines or if it
really can't and it has to it might
delete them and recreate them but the
idea is that we end up in a state of
exactly what we want so in the first
case we expect it to but we ended up
with four but with the independent uh
case we expected to and we always end up
with two so hopefully that makes that
very clear okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and what I want to do here is concretely
Define the difference between
provisioning deployment and
orchestration now in practice sometimes
these have overlapping responsibility so
you might say provisioning when you
really mean deployment or vice versa
it's not a big deal uh we all get kind
of mixed up about it but I did want to
just take the time to make sure that we
understand what these things are
supposed to mean okay so the First on
our list here is provisioning so to
prepare a server with systems data and
software and then make it ready for
Network operation if you're using a
configuration management tool you are
most likely provisioning because that's
what these tools do so puppet ansible
Chef bash scripts Powershell or cloudnit
so you can provision a server when you
launch a cloud service and configure it
you are provisioning it okay then you
have deployments the deployment is the
act of delivering a version of your
application to run a provision server
deployment could be performed via AWS
code pipeline harness which is a
third-party deployment tool Jenkins
GitHub action Circle CI there's a lot
more other providers out there then you
have orchestration so orchestration is
the active coordinating multiple systems
or Services orchestration is a common
term when working with microservices
containers and kubernetes so
orchestration could be done with
kubernetes salt or fabric so if you're
working with containers generally like
you use the word orchestration
especially with kubernetes because
you're working with thousands of
microservices okay so you know hopefully
that helps you know the difference
between the three again it's not a big
deal if you don't perfectly know them
but there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at
configuration drift so this is when
provision infrastructure has an
unexpected configuration change due to
team members manually adjusting
configuration options malicious actors
so maybe they're trying to cause
downtime or breach data or side effects
from apis sdks or CLI so you've written
some code that uses a CLI and a bash
script and it does something you did not
expect to happen so here an example
could be imagine you have a server like
a database and a junior developer turns
off delete on termination for your
production database this could be a
problem where let's say there's an
accidental deletion of the database this
feature would protect the database from
deletion but if it's turned off you
don't have that right so configuration
drift going unnoticed could be a loss or
breach of cloud services and residing
data will result in Interruption of
services or unexpected downtime so
there's a lot of
downsides to to neglecting or not
noticing configuration drift so what can
we do about this so how to detect so
there's three things detect
um we can fix it and then prevent it
okay so to detect configuration drift if
you have a compliance Tool uh it can
detect misconfiguration so it was config
can do that as your policies can do that
gcp security health analytics can do
that some of these are constrained to
security things not just configuration
in general but there are tools there for
all the cloud service providers there is
built-in support for drift detection for
it was cloud formation it's called cloud
formation drift detection other
providers don't necessarily have that if
you're using terraform which is this
which is all this course is about you
have the terraform State files which
says what the state of things should be
so that's how you could detect
configuration drift how to correct
configuration drift well compliance
tools can remediate so again it is
config you can create a custom Lambda to
say hey when this happens then do this
so set the configuration back into place
with terraform you can use the refresh
and plan command which we'll look at in
detail in this course or you can
manually correct it so if the option was
changed you could do that not
recommended to do that
another thing would be tearing down and
setting up the infrastructure again
because that would bring it back into
its original state that could be a risky
thing to do depending on how you have
things set up or could be it could be
fine right then there's prevention so
um this is a the important thing and
kind of why we're talking about
configuration drift which is all about
immutable infrastructure so always
create and just destroy never reuse so
that might be blue green deployment
strategies servers are never modified
they are all they're just always
deployed with a new version the way you
would do that would be baking Ami images
or containers via AWS image Builder or
hashicor Packer or a build server like
gcp Cloud run or code build like AWS but
the idea is that you're not modifying
after they're deployed you'd have that
image already ready to go another thing
you could use is git Ops so you would
Version Control your IAC like within
GitHub or something like that and you
would peer review every single uh change
the a pull request to the infrastructure
so hopefully that gives you an idea of
things we can do to tackle configuration
drift okay
[Music]
we were just talking about immutable
infrastructure but I just want to give
it a bit more attention here so the idea
is
um we are going to first develop our
infrastructure as a code file terraform
cloudformation what have you and then
we're going to go ahead and deploy that
so we'll end up with our own virtual
machine and that virtual machine needs
to be configured so you need to install
packages and things like that that's
where Cloud init would come into play
ansible puppet Chef salt whatever
configuration management tool you want
to use the problem here is that there's
no guarantee that that configuration is
going to stay in place so that's where
immutable infrastructure comes into play
so we develop our infrastructure as a
code file terraform cloud formation and
then we're going to go ahead and do our
configuration by building a virtual
machine or building a container so we
can use something like Packer and then
the idea is once we are happy with our
configuration what we're going to do is
bake that image and put it in an image
repository and then that image is going
to be referenced when we do our deploy
and so that's going to make sure that
our infrastructure is always immutable
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at the concept
or methodology of git Ops so this is
when you take infrastructure as code and
you use a git repository to introduce a
formal process to review and accept
changes to infrastructure code and once
that code is accepted it automatically
triggers a deploy and changes that
infrastructure so here's my illustration
through it so the idea is you would have
a terraform file and you would place
that in something like GitHub you would
apply your commits and when you're ready
you'd make a pull request you would
merge that pull request into the main
branch or whichever branch is set up for
production and that could trigger
something like GitHub actions and GitHub
actions would then trigger a terraform
plan and and accept it or maybe you have
to manually intervene to say Okay I
accept these changes but then it would
roll out those changes now terraform
does have their own and it's pretty darn
similar but I thought mine was a bit
easier to read but the idea is you have
your git repository you have your pull
request this is pulling from terraform
Cloud because you can have files and
state managed there so that is another
means to do it but that's generally how
it works okay
foreign
[Music]
so we were just looking at immutable
infrastructure but what I want to do is
just kind of cement in your head things
that you should be asking yourself as a
devops engineer so that you kind of lean
towards that immutable uh kind of way of
thinking and so this is mostly going to
be applicable for virtual machines but
let's just ask some questions of things
we should be thinking about so what's
going to happen if we deploy our virtual
machine and there is a physical failure
of the hardware by the provider so this
can sometimes happen on AWS where they
have two status checks that have to
complete before a virtual machine is
ready sometimes they fail and so you
know your infrastructure is not ready to
graded or damaged right then you have
application failure so you have this
post installation script maybe to
install your application and there's
either a bug so introduced by developer
or maybe there's just a dependency and
it's changed and so it's breaking your
app what happens when you need to deploy
in a hurry what have happens in worst
case scenarios where you have accidental
deletion compromised by malicious actor
need to change regions maybe there's a
region outage and so the thing is is
that when you look at these things what
happens when multiples of these happen
at the same time because that's the
problem where you know it's like okay I
have something wrong with my application
code but I also have uh you know now we
also have a region down and so you don't
want to be dealing with more than one
problem at the same time and so that's
we're going to have an issue of agility
in terms of deployment another thing
that is overlooked is there's no
guarantee of one to one if you are
configuring your code after deployment
because if you were to deploy a virtual
machine
and installed all the dependencies and
then you to were to deploy a virtual
machine literally a minute later one of
those dependencies could have a minor
revision and so that would be deployed
with that one minor revision so they
would look very similar but they aren't
one to one so by introducing golden
images which is an immutable
infrastructure idea you get a guarantee
of one one to one with your Fleet you
have increased Assurance of consistency
security you have you can speed up your
deployments the reason why you have an
improvement of security is because at
that stage you could
um you could perform kind of Security
checks and things like that there on
that image before you roll it out so I
don't know um I would just say that I
would recommend that you go with the
immutable infrastructure or baking your
images when you can if you're using VMS
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're going to take a look here at
what is hashicorp so hashicorp is who
creates terraform and they are a company
specializing in managed open source
tools used to support the deployment and
development of large-scale service
oriented software installations and they
have their own cloud platform called the
hashicorp cloud platform hcp and it's a
unified platform to access hashicorp
various products so uh the main thing is
that it's Cloud agnostic so hashicorp
makes it really easy to build across
cloud and they have support for all the
three main providers so AWS gcp Azure
I'm sure they have more support like
kubernetes and things like that they're
highly suited for multi-cloud workloads
or cross-cloud workloads and they have a
lot of products that will help you out
there so let's go through them quickly
so first we have boundary this is secure
remote access to systems based on
trusted identity this is console this is
a full featured service mesh for secure
service segmentation across any cloud or
runtime environment you have Nomad this
is scheduling and deployment of tasks
across worker nodes in a cluster you
have Packer which is a tool for building
virtual machine images that will be
later deployed or they will place them
in a image repository then you have
terraform which is infrastructure as
code software which enables provisioning
and adapting virtual infrastructure
across all major providers then you have
terraform cloud and this is just a place
to store and manage your IAC State files
and things like that with a team or just
in the cloud by yourself we have vagrant
so building and building and maintenance
of reproducible software development
environments via virtualization
technology we have Vault so secret
management identity based access
encrypting application data auditing of
Secrets for application systems and
users and lastly we have Waypoint a
modern workflow to build deploy and
release across multiple platforms so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at what is terraform
so terraform is an open source and Cloud
agnostic infrastructure as a code tool
and terraform uses declarative
configuration files and the
configuration files are written in the
hashicorp configuration language HCL and
so that's what you can see on the right
hand side we'll generally call it the
terraform language which we'll talk
about later but notable features of
terraform are installable modules plan
and predict changes dependency graphing
State Management and provisioning
infrastructure in familiar languages
that's something you could do via AWS
cdk so I wouldn't say it's core to
terraform but that's what they listed on
their websites that's why I put in there
and terraform registry which has over 1
000 plus providers okay so there we go
[Music]
so we were just looking at terraform but
what is terraform Cloud well it's a
software as a service offering for
remote State Storage Version Control
Integrations flexible workflows and
allows you to collaborate on
infrastructure changes within a single
unified web portal and this is all
accessible via terraform.io and the
first thing you'll have to do is create
yourself an account on terraform i o but
it's free to start with and they
actually have a very generous free tier
that allows for team collaboration for
the first five users of your
organization that's not part of the
team's plan that's part of the free plan
and in the majority of cases you really
should be using terraform Cloud as your
remote backend even if you are an
individual just because you know it
makes experience so much better the only
case that you might not want to use
terraform cloud is if you have a very
large company that's trying to meet
particular regulatory requirements and
it's not that terraform Cloud does not
meet them but sometimes there's just a
long procurement process so in the
meantime you would have to use something
like standard remote back end or
Atlantis or maybe you need to
investigate terraform Enterprise I do
want to note that terraform cloud and
terraform Enterprise is the underlying
software known as terraform platform
it's not something you're going to ever
have direct access to but just to
clarify that terminology okay
[Music]
so what I want to do is just set you up
with understanding the terraform life
cycle this is not necessarily uh
described in the documentation anywhere
but it's something that is inherently
known when you're working with terraform
uh and it's definitely not uh inclusive
with every single command that can be
ran but the ones that you're going to
counter most often so at the start
you're going to be writing or updating
your terraform configuration file okay
and from there the first thing you'll
want to do is initialize your projects
and or if you need to pull the latest
providers and modules you're going to
use terraform indit to do that as well
from there you're going to use plan so
plan allows you to speculate what will
change or generate a saved execution
plan that you could use later on when
you run plan validate happens
automatically but you could also run
this separately and ensures types and
values are valid ensures the required
attributes are present within your
configuration file from there if
everything is good you're going to
execute your execution plan by running
terraform apply you can also from this
point use terraform apply to destroy
infrastructure so if you have things set
up there's actually a flag for it or you
can use the Alias the terraform destroy
command and then you know as you work
you're just going to keep updating your
code and that is the terraform life
cycle so you know hopefully this gives
you kind of a a snapshot of what the
workflow will be and I mean we'll be
covering it tons and tons of times over
in this course okay foreign
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at change
automation but to understand that we
need to first talk about change
management so this is a standard
approach to apply change and resolving
conflicts brought about by change in the
context of IAC change management is the
procedure that will be followed when
resources are modified and applied via
configuration scripts so what is change
automation then it is a way of
automatically creating a consistent
systematic and predictable way of
managing change requests via control and
policies notice and I should have
probably emphasized this is change
requests saying I'm going to change
these resources terraform uses change
Automation in the form of execution
plans and resource graphs which will
look at detail those two things in
upcoming slides and apply review complex
change sets so a change set is a
collection of commits that represents
changes made to a versioning repository
and for IEC uses change sets so you can
see what has changed by who over time so
when I say versioning repository that
doesn't necessarily mean get and if
you're using get Ops I suppose you could
consider your chain sets being committed
to that but something like cloud
formation when you apply a change you
actually have to accept a change Set uh
and so the version repository is part of
AWS and so um it will terraform you just
kind of accept it in place it's not
necessarily on your local machine but I
guess reflecting your state file okay so
change automation allows you to know
exactly what terraform will change and
in what order avoiding many possible
human errors a change automation is
essential to any IAC tool they all have
it okay so there we go
[Music]
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we are taking a look at execution plans
so this is a manual review of what will
add change or destroy before you apply
changes and so let's say you type in
terraform apply it's not just going to
go ahead and do that it's going to have
you uh type in yes or accept the value
but what you can do is see the resources
or configuration settings that will be
added changed or destroyed and it will
summarize them at the bottom and then
you'll have to type something like yes
in order to accept the changes okay
[Music]
something else I want to show you is
that you can actually visualize your
execution Plans by using the terraform
graph command and terraform will output
a graph of his file you'll have to have
graph Vis installed but Graphics is an
open source tool for drawing graphs
specified in the dot language scripts
having the file name extension of GV so
I believe this is cross-platform it's
open source but once it's installed in
your machine you can run terraform graph
and here this is Linux so we're using a
pipe to say okay pass it over to graphis
which is Dot and that is going to then
create an SVG file you can just open
that in your browser and the idea is
you're going to get this graph which
kind of shows you the relationship of
the resources here but we'll talk about
the these relationships in the next
slide here which is a resource graph
okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at the resource
graph so terraform builds a dependency
graph from the terraform configurations
and walks this graph to generate plans
refresh rate and more when you use
terraform graph this is a visual
representation or presentation of the
dependency graph if you're wondering
what a dependency graph is in
mathematics it's a directed graph
representing dependencies of several
objects towards each other so it's
pretty much like nodes with
relationships between other nodes so
that is one that I generate out from
terraform and so there's a few different
types here we have a resource node that
represents a single resource a resource
meta node represents a group of
resources but does not represent any
action on its own and provider
configuration nodes that represents the
time to fully configure a provider will
you need to know this for the exam
probably not do you need to know this in
great detail probably not because
there's a lot to the resource graph but
the idea here is just kind of like
terraform saying just so you know we're
using a graph database and graph
databases are very well suited for this
kind of stuff and that's why terraform
is very good at figuring out conflicts
and things like that okay
foreign
[Music]
from exam Pro and we are taking a look
at terraform use cases and the idea here
is not necessarily because it's going to
show up in the exam but the idea is to
give you a business use case or to
highlight the features as to why you'd
want to be using terraform and the first
one here is that it has exotic providers
so terraform supports a variety of
providers outside of gcp AWS and Azure
and sometimes is the only provider
terraform is open source and extendable
so any API could be used to create IC
tooling of any kind of cloud platform or
technology so you can make your own
provider there's some interesting ones
that they have like Heroku or even
Spotify playlists I have my own platform
called teacher seat and I want to have
IAC for my platform and so this is what
I'm going to be using terraform for for
multi-tier applications terraform by
default makes it easy to divide large
and complex applications into isolate
configuration script modules you'll
notice in this course that when you have
a bunch of terraform files they're all
treated as one so that makes it really
easy to split up your uh your projects
or your your infrastructure so so it has
a complexity advantage over Cloud native
IC tools for its flexibility while
retaining Simplicity over imperative
tools then we have disposable
environments this is not unique to
terraform it's any kind of ISE tool but
easily stand up an environment for a
software demo or a temporary developer
environment resource schedulers so
terraform is not just defined to
infrastructure of cloud resources but
can be used to set Dynamic schedules for
Docker containers Hadoop spark and other
software tools you can provision your
own scheduling grid and the last one
here is multi-cloud deployment terraform
is cloud agnostic and allows a single
configuration to be used to manage
multiple writers and to even handle
cross-cloud dependencies and that is a
big deal and is a very unique offering
to terraform okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at terraform core
and terraform plugins so terraform is
logically split into two main parts
terraform core which uses remote
procedure calls RPC to communicate with
terraform plugins and terraform plugins
so expose an implementation for a
specific service or provisioner
something that's interesting to know is
just terraform core is written in go
um you know you probably will never
encounter it but it's just a fact okay
and so here's the graphic that terraform
uses to kind of like explain terraform
core versus terraform plugins and how
they all relate so here's the terraform
core and here are the plugins notice we
have providers here which will cover
provisioners uh and there's just this is
the group for plugins overall
um but yeah that's about it we'll show
up an exam probably not but it's good to
understand from a top level view the
split between these two things okay
[Music]
if you are new to terraform I just
wanted you to be aware of an additional
resource that you can use Beyond this
course which is called terraform up and
running so it's a a book and it has a
deep dive into the internal workings of
terraform and this is really great if
you want to go beyond this course Beyond
certification beyond the basics because
what it will do is teach you about
testing with terraform Cloud zero
downtime deployment common terraform
gotchas and compositions of production
grade terraform code there's a lot more
to it and this book in particular is
written by Jim who's the co-founder of
grunt work and we do have a whole
section just on grunt work and the thing
is I just want you to know about this
resource you definitely don't need it to
pass a certification or to have a good
understanding or working of terraform
but you know at some point you if you
want more I just want to point you to
that resource okay
[Music]
there's one other resource I want you to
check out for terraform and this one is
free and just online and it's the
terraform best practices so it's an open
book it's a get book so it's essentially
a Wiki and it basically covers the best
practices that are being used in the
industry and so this is stuff that is
separate from the terraform
documentation it's just good practices
you know if you're going to be using
terraform professionally within the
industry so I just wanted to make you
aware of this resource and to go check
it out okay
foreign
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at terraform
provisioners so provisioners install
software edit files and provision
machines created with terraform and
terraform allows you to work with two
different provisioners we have Cloud net
and Packer so Cloud init is an industry
standard for cross-platform cloud
instance initialization when you launch
a VM on a cloud service provider you'll
provide either a yaml or Bass script and
so for the case of AWS what you'll have
is this box called user data and so you
can either put your yaml or Bass script
in there it's the same if you're using
Google or Azure they both have this box
it might just not be called user data
but that is using Cloud init underneath
then you have Packer this is an
automated image Builder service you
provide a configuration file to create
and provision the machine image and the
image is then delivered to repository
for use if you've ever heard of ec2
image Builder it's a very similar
service except that one's just for AWS I
suppose for Google you can use Google
Cloud run and even on AWS you could use
um
code build but uh Packer is great
because it's Cloud agnostic so you're
going to just build the image and then
you can deliver it
to any provider provisioners should be
used as a last resort for the for more
common situations there are better
Alternatives this is a warning that
hashnode puts out in their terraform
provisioner section and so I wasn't
really sure why they were saying this so
I reached out to Anton and Anton uh if
you don't know him he's an as Community
hero just like myself and so he
specializes in terraform like he wrote
so many modules for the terraform AWS so
he knows it pretty well and he says here
the main reason is that provisioners
will do something that won't be
reflected in the terraform State and the
better alternative for that one is to
use cloud provider features like Cloud
init scripts I think this comes back to
immutability when we're looking at the
fact that we want to
lean towards doing an approach with
Packer right we want to
um uh bake our Baker machines or virtual
machines and then deploy because that's
going to be probably the better
alternative so if we wanted to use cloud
init the idea is we'd have to provide a
cloudinet yaml file which is a a very
particular format you can find them on
the cloudinet website and the idea here
is we have these run commands so this
just like bash commands here to start
and stop Apache we can install our
packages here do an update do an upgrade
we'll have to pass along our SSH key
here that's a very important component
to that once we have that file
configured we can reference it as a
template file over here call it user
data and then we're going to pass it on
to this section here for user data so
that when we launch up this VM and this
one in particular is for AWS that's
going to pass it to that user data okay
now you might be asking well where's all
these other provisioners because there's
a lot of other tools out there so
terraform used to directly support
third-party provisioning tools in the
terraform language but they were
deprecated because it was considered to
be poor practice suggesting better
Alternatives as we were just talking
about so you might be asking where is
Chef where is puppet where is salt and
the thing is is that you can technically
still use chef and puppet through Cloud
init because cloudinit actually supports
some dsls in there I've never used this
before myself but it doesn't look too
complicated but the idea is that there's
just not direct support so you're not
going to use it directly in the language
you can use it through cloud in it if
you really need it one thing I didn't
see mentioned anywhere was ansible and
this one's a little bit confusing
because there's a lot a lot of videos
online about terraform and ansible
working very well together and they're
complementary Technologies so ansible is
a little bit different than these other
ones because it does more than just
configuration management so maybe that's
the reason there
um but anyway the point is is that
there's no direct support for these
anymore you got to use cloud in it and
generally if you can use Packer instead
when you're working with virtual
machines okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at local exec
which allows you to execute local
commands after a resource is provisioned
so the machine that is executing
terraform so what's doing the terraform
apply is where the command will execute
and a local environment could be your
local machine so your laptop or
workstation a build server like gcp
Cloud build a business code Builder
Jenkins or terraform Cloud run
environment so that is a single use
Linux virtual machine so just an example
and there's a lot of cases where you
might want to automate but the idea here
is after your provision a VM you need to
supply the public IP to a third-party
security service to add the VM IP
address and you can accomplish this by
using locally installed third-party
cli's on your build server and so there
is a bit of an overlapping
responsibility between terraform outputs
versus local exec because the idea is
that by getting by getting data out
after something is provisioned or
something like that you can do something
pragmatic but the idea here is terraform
outputs allow you to Output results
after running terraform apply local exec
allows you to run any arbitrary commands
on your local machine commonly used to
trigger configuration management like
ansible Chef or puppet okay
[Music]
let's take a look at some example code
for a local exec so here we have a bunch
of examples on the right hand side and
so I just kind of want to walk through
some of the commands that we can use but
before we do that just let's take a
quicker look here at the code so notice
we have a resource like Ava's instance
in web and then we are specifying a
provisioner being a local exec and then
we have a command that is being executed
under there okay so hopefully that makes
it pretty clear but let's just kind of
work through the options we have
available to us so the first is we have
a command and this is required and this
is the command you want to execute so
notice that we are doing an echo there
so it's whatever is possible uh there
and I think by default it's using bash
okay so if you're using Linux that's
what it would be using we could also set
a working directory we don't see an
example there on the right hand side but
if you wanted to say where the command
will be executed that's something you
could do so maybe you want it over here
another thing is The Interpreter so this
is the entry point for the command I
think by default again it would probably
use bash if you're on Linux machine but
you could say use bash Ruby it was CLI
Powershell whatever you want okay
if you needed to pass environment
variables in maybe you need a key and
secret so the example here is you know
we are printing out those keys and then
putting them into a credentials XML file
so that could be an example there okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at remote exec
so this allows you to execute commands
on a Target resource after a resources
provision so the idea is you have a
local machine executing terraform and so
the idea is that when remote exact
happens it has a script and it's sending
that off to the Target so this case it
could be a provision virtual machine and
this is where the command is going to
run so a remote execute is useful for
provisioning a virtual machine with a
simple set of commands for more complex
tasks it's recommended to use cloud init
and strongly recommended in all cases to
bake golden images via Packer or uc2
image Builder if you want to use
something more complex like ansible or
something
[Music]
let's take a look at an example of a
remote exec script so here we have a
couple and just to quickly go through it
the idea is you define your resource so
here it's just a virtual machine on AWS
and we are provisioning our provisioner
is going to be remote exact and so we're
able to put these inline commands and
say okay let's run puppet apply and then
we'll use console join which is the CLI
for hashicorp console so there are three
different modes for a remote exec the
first is inline list of command strings
which is what we are seeing over here
and then the other option is we can
provide a script or scripts so the idea
is that you would
um well you just specify those locations
and it would run it what's interesting
here is that it doesn't say
um like because we saw with local exec
that we could use an interpreter and so
it's my assumption that it's just going
to use bash or it's going to use a
script that is executable right where
you have a shebang in the top there and
so that's something you know I might
test out it's not something that's going
to be on the exam but maybe we'll just
test out that theory because it's not in
the documentation as of the time I'm
recording this
[Music]
let's take a look at the file
provisioner and this is used to copy
files or directories from our local
machine to the newly created resource so
here we have some on the right as an
example so again we have a virtual
machine that we're deploying to AWS
we've set the provisioner as file and we
are specifying a source file and a
destination so source is going to be the
file that's on your local machine or
whoever is the considered the local you
might also want to provide content
directly so in this example here you see
that we're literally just giving it a
string and then there's the destination
where you want that file to be I don't
have it shown in the code example here
but there's a high chance that you would
have to provide a connection block so
that you could say okay I need to use
SSH or
winrm to gain access to that machine
okay
[Music]
so we just mentioned that there's a
connection block so it tells the
provisioner or resource how to establish
a connection so here is a big example on
the right hand side so this is using the
example for a provisioner file and here
we are specifying our connection block
and this one in particular is for SSH as
you can see and there's a bunch of
different parameters like the user the
password the host you could also use a
Bastion host I don't I'm not showing it
here but if you're using SSH you could
specify a bunch of keys in order to do
that because maybe you need to go
through a Bastion first
for Windows Remote Management you also
have that option down below okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at null
resources so this is a placeholder for
resources that have no specific
Association to a provider it's a bit
confusing but it makes sense once you
run into some use cases for it so here
is a big example where we have an AWS
instance and we're defining a cluster
and so we need a null resource here
because we want to run this trigger and
that's generally why you're going to be
using null resources is to trigger a
resource so triggers is a map of values
which should cause this set of
Provisions to re-run so values are meant
to be interpolated references to
variables or attributes of other
resources and triggers are interesting
because I think we also see them in
terraform Cloud I'm not sure if this is
the same kind of functionality but yeah
that's in all resources okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at terraform
data so this is very very similar to
null resource but the key difference
here is that it does not require or the
configuration of Provider because when
you install null resource it actually
installs a provider called null and so
now it's just with this dare terraform
data you can do something very similar
like this with null resource and
literally replace it with terraform data
and for more or less it will do the same
thing now it's not one to one because uh
some of those parameters are a little
bit different so instead of triggers we
have triggers replace but more or less
you know you can almost replace it and
get the exact same result and you know I
would recommend it over using null I was
trying to figure out if there was a case
where you'd want to use an all resource
but I really could not determine that it
did not seem like there was anything
additional so yeah there you go it's as
simple as that
[Music]
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at terraform
providers so providers are terraform
plugins that allow you to interact with
cloud service providers like AWS Azure
gcp software as a service provider so
GitHub and Golia stripe or other apis
such as kubernetes or postgres servers
there's a lot there there's like over a
thousand providers so providers are
required for your terraform
configuration file to work so you have
to have at least one provider and
providers can come in three different
tiers we have the official one so
published by the company that owns the
provider technology or service verified
so actively maintained up to date and
compatible with both terraform provider
communities so published by Community
member but no guarantee of Maintenance
up to date or compatibility providers
are distributed separately from
terraform and the plugin must be
downloaded before use so if we do
terraforming knit this will download the
necessary plugin provided plugins listed
in the terraform configuration file so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at the
terraform registry so this is a website
portal to browse download or publish
available providers and modules and just
remember providers and modules are
plugins within terraform both of them
okay so to get to this website we go to
registry.terraform.io and everything
published to the terraform registry is
public facing so let's just distinguish
between providers and modules and I feel
that I should have given providers a
little bit more attention in the uh in
its own slide but I'll give it a clear
distinction between providers and
modules here so a provider is a plug-in
that is a mapping to a cloud service
provider's API so if you wanted to call
individual API actions that is what the
provider is providing to you when we're
talking about modules a module actually
relies on a provider plugin but a module
is a group of configuration files that
provide common configuration
functionality this is going to help you
enforce best practices reduce amount of
code code reduced time to develop
scripts so the way to think about it is
imagine that you have to do something in
your CSP like AWS and there's just
common things that would go along with
it so let's say you're launching a load
bouncer Auto scaling group with ec2
instances that's a bunch of services
that you are just very common you'd have
to configure it together so there could
be a module that allows you to do all
that with writing very little amount of
code it will choose best practices when
doing that okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at providers and
modules within terraform registry really
quickly so um here is the AWS one here
and so I just want to point out that
this official one is by hashicorp it's
not by AWS but it does mean that it has
uh proper support so you know it's going
to have pretty much one-to-one mapping
to the AWS API
um and so it has really really good
documentation now I complain about
terraform not having great documentation
for learning like their language but for
the actual documentation of doing things
practically they're really really good
and here's just an example where we see
app mesh and they just give you full
examples for basically everything it's
really great and if you need a code
sample to get going like to actually
install it within your configuration
file it's right there over here so you
can just go ahead and grab that for
terraform modules it looks pretty
similar so the idea is you get your
module code on the right hand side here
you want to check out the examples it's
going to be dependent on who is
developing these modules this one is
made by Anton so he has lots and lots of
really great examples and then you can
see a list of dependent modules here
under sub modules so it's not too
complicated so there you go
[Music]
so we're taking a look at terraform
registry which is a public registry but
let's talk about private registry how
would we do that well that's where we
use terraform Cloud it allows you to
publish private modules for your
organization within the terraform Cloud
private registry when creating a module
you need to connect to a Version Control
System of VCS and choose a repository so
here you can see
we can be using something like GitHub
gitlab betbucket or azure devops
and of course we're going to cover
terraform Cloud a lot more further on in
the course and it does definitely does
more than just act as a private registry
but I figured this is the best place to
put it against the terraform registry
okay
[Music]
let's take a look at how we would get a
list of the current providers you are
using so all you'd have to do is type in
terraform providers and you'd get a full
list this command is useful if you have
a very complex
architecture where you're using a lot of
files and modules within terraform I
wanted to just show this command just
because I saw it on the exam and so it's
just an easy point if you happen to get
that question okay
[Music]
so we know we can set multiple providers
of in our terraform configuration file
but there are some variations here that
you should know so one thing is is that
if you need to have an alternate
provider you can use this thing called
Alias so if you just notice here there's
the Alias this is useful if let's say
you want to have resources within
different regions of AWS is a very
common use case when you want to
reference uh what resource should use
with provider you're going to have that
little provider attribute and then
you're just going to do what the name is
of the provider followed by the Alias
you can also set an alias provider for a
parent module so notice here in the
required providers we have this
attribute here and we're using this
configuration Alias and then if you need
to set an alias provider for a child
module but more or less you just need to
remember these two up here okay for
setting an alias
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're giving closer attention to
modules so a terraform module is a group
of configuration files that provide
common configuration functionality to
enforce best practices reduce the amount
of code and reduce the time to develop
scripts I definitely had a lot of
confusion understanding the difference
between a provider and a module
initially but the clear thing is that a
provider is just an API mappings to the
service okay so on the example here on
the left we have AWS as a provider and
the example is to show you if you had to
create a VPC you'd have to specify many
networking resources and just notice
that I have the three ellipses there to
suggest there is a lot more that you'd
have to configure but by using a module
and there's one called the AWS VPC
module it basically has this short
domain specific language
that allows you to quickly provision a
VPC so the easy way to remember modules
is Imagine clicking a wizard that
creates many Cloud resources like it
able to have the VPC wizard that's
basically the idea behind modules just
to kind of give a better contrast to the
value that modules have we'll look at
the Azure provider so imagine you had to
provision an Azure virtual machine this
is how much code you'd have to write so
it's going to vary based on providers so
AWS does not require this much work it's
very short gcp requires a little bit
more work and for some reason Azure
requires a lot so this is a case where
you'd want to use a module so there's a
module called compute and network module
and it reduces the code to amount of
this still a bit long but that's just
what it is okay
thank you
[Music]
all right let's talk about the fine line
and this is understanding the gray areas
of responsibility between terraform
infrastructure as code and third-party
configuration management tools like
ansible so there are cases where when
you get outside of AWS as your gcp you
might see providers like for postgres
database and you might say okay well
what part of terraform should be
automating it and so that's a little bit
more complicated question because
terraform does more than one thing so
terraform has providers modules and
provisioners and then on outside of that
if we're not even using terraform we
have third-party configuration
management tools that we can use like
ansible and the thing is is that you
could have ansible do everything but
that does not mean that you should have
it do everything and with terraform at
more or less most of these levels you
can have them do everything but that
doesn't mean that they should right so
the idea is to try to figure out what
should be where and how to define that
so let's talk about creating a database
so if we created a database that is like
setting up a new service so that is
going to be under the providers and so
you'd use the postgres terraform
provider to set up a database now you
have users and so users are an entity
they're not just like loose data so
there's something that you can add
remove add permissions to and we would
treat them as entities and so it
wouldn't necessarily be under the
providers but that's a great place to
put it under modules okay then you have
your data so where would the data go
well data is not necessarily an entity
it's just a bunch of data so I would say
that that is for provisioners that can
run random scripts and then when we want
to do things like backup tables to data
warehouses or truncate data daily tables
things that are repetitive tasks that is
what we're going to use ansible for or a
third-party configuration management
tool outside of terraform you wouldn't
have terraform to that stuff at all so
when you have a task done one time to
set up the database like seating data
it's going to go to provisioners what
you have repeatable tasks for ongoing
maintenance it's going to be out as a
third party provider and if you have
something that is like identified as an
identity like as a resource that you
want to manage like Asset Management
which are these things these are going
to be over here in providers and modules
I do want to point out that a
provisioner can be using ansible but we
would still want to use ansible or
third-party configuration management
tool isolate or separate to do these
kind of things you do not want terraform
running these okay
foreign
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Hashi Corp
configuration files also known as
terraform files that which contain the
configuration information about
providers and resources this is
basically core to terraform and that's
what we're doing so terraform files and
in the extension of dot TF or TF Json
and we'll talk about the Json case a
little bit later but terraform files are
written in the terraform language and so
here is kind of an abstract way of
looking at the language I know it's
confusing here but don't worry we're
going to reiterate on it to make more
sense but terraform language consists of
only a few basic elements you have
blocks and so these are containers for
other content and they represent an
object so I'll have a block type which
can have zero or more labels and a body
you have a block label it's a name of a
block you have arguments which is which
is what you assign a value to a name so
notice like we have assignments so we
have identifier to an expression okay
they will appear within block so here it
is within a block as you can see
um Expressions represent a value either
literally or by referencing and
combining other values they appear as
values for arguments or within other
Expressions you might come across
hashicorp configuration language so HCL
and this is the low level language for
both the terraform language and
alternative Json syntax I don't know if
we'll be getting into it in this course
um or if there's even an easy way to
distinguish it because it's basically
terraform language but just if you see
HCL just think terraform language it's
the easiest way to think about it okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at the alternate
Json syntax so terraform supports
alternate syntax that is Json compatible
terraform expects Json syntax files to
be named dot tf.json so we mentioned
that earlier and so this is generally
what it would look like okay the syntax
is useful when generating portions of a
configuration pragmatically since
existing Json libraries can be used to
prepare the generate configuration files
and that's pretty much it would you want
to work on this it's up to you
um but uh yeah so that's the reason for
this alternate syntax
[Music]
all right let's take a look at terraform
settings so the terraform configuration
block type terraform curly braces you'll
see this within your configuration file
is used to configure some behaviors of
terraform itself so here is what it
looks like and what's very common is
you're going to see those required
providers so there are different things
that we can put in here so we can put
the required version so this expects us
to match to a particular version of
terraform required providers this is the
providers that will be pulled during the
terraform init we can also do
experiments here so these are
experimental language features that the
community can try and provide feedback
on and then we have provider metadata so
this is module specific information for
providers okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at the
hashicorp configuration language also
known as HCL I'm going to tell you I was
really confused at the start working
with terraform because sometimes they
mention things like hashicorp
configuration files hashicorp
configuration language terraform
language and I could not discern you
know what the difference was but so this
is the idea here is to give you that
Clarity okay so HCL is an open source
toolkit for creating structured
configuration languages that are both
human and machine friendly for use of
command line tools and it's an open
source project so you can find it at
github.com
HCL so the idea is that they have this
Baseline language that you can extend
for your own use case so uh terraform is
using it and so it uses a good like it
uses the language itself but then it
goes ahead and extends it by adding
additional functionality for its
specific use case and this HCL based
language is not just for terraform it's
used for hacker templates Vault policies
boundary controllers and workers console
configuration Waypoint application
configuration Nomad job specification
and this one isn't a hash Accord product
but this is an open source project
called Shipyard and you can use it for
Shipyard blueprints surprisingly
Sentinel which is a Hachi Corp policy as
code server service does not use HCL but
it has its own HC ACL custom language
but the idea is that you know we're
looking at mostly the use case is for
hashicorp services but if you wanted to
extend this language for your own use
case you totally could and so I think
that's really cool but hopefully that
kind of distinguishes between HCL and
terraform language okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at input
variables so also known as terraform
variables or just variables are
parameters for terraform modules that is
the way we get data in to our
configuration scripts is via input
variables so you can declare variables
in either the root module or child
modules and the way you define them is
via this variables block there at the
top and just to kind of go over the
possible fields for that block we have
the default option so the default option
which is here is going to be the default
variable if you do not set it
for type this is an argument that
specifies the value types that are
accepted for the variable so this case
up here we can see string and this one
is a list
for description this specifies the input
variables documentation we don't see an
example there I believe that is optional
but it's always great to put a
description in when you can there is a
validation block so a block to Define
validation rules usually in addition
addition to type constraints so we don't
see that here on the right hand side but
the idea is that you know let's just
make sure that there's less of a human
error entering the wrong information you
can also have sensitive this limits
terraform UI output when the variable is
used in the configuration and we will
cover sensitive a lot more in this
course outside of just this one slide
okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at variable
definition files and these allow you to
set the values for multiple variables at
once so variable definition files are
named with the dot TF vars extension or
if you want to use the alternative
syntax it's the
tfbars.json file by default if you have
a file called
terraform.tfrs within your project
directory this will be automatically
loaded so it's pretty common to make
that file to create a definition file it
just uses the terraform language so you
would just assign
values here you wouldn't make variable
blocks but you just Define these um
identifiers and give them values okay
[Music]
another way of loading input variables
is via environment variables and this is
very common uh way of loading them if
you have your own CI CD process for
terraform so if you're using terraform
cloud or you're using some kind of build
server that's going to be the primary
way you're going to get variables into
those build servers probably won't be
doing this much locally but the way it
works is that terraform will watch for
any environment variable starting with
TF underscore VAR underscore followed by
the name this is very important to
remember because it definitely will show
up on the exam so let's say we want to
do set a variable for an image ID so we
do TF underscore VAR and then image ID
probably most cases when you follow the
name it's going to be a lowercase
underscore I don't think you'd probably
want to uppercase that stuff and you
just set the value okay
[Music]
so there's a lot of ways for us to load
input variables we just saw two so we
saw terraform tfrs and environment
variables but there's a lot more caveats
to this so let's just run through them
so we already covered uh terraform.tfrs
the idea here is that if you create this
file and it's in your project it will
automatically be loaded when running
terraform apply you can name other TFR
files uh so I just called them use
additional TFR files but they won't be
loaded by default you'll have to use a
command line to load them this is useful
if you have like a Dev and prod
environment and you want to swap those
out now if you want to have files that
auto load then you can just put the dot
Auto here and give it any name you want
this would be useful if let's say you
had a very large terraform tfrs file and
you wanted to break it up to make it
more human readable you could do that
then you have the hyphen VAR file flag
when you're doing terraform apply or or
plan and this is actually how you load
up these additional variable files if
you need to override a single value you
you can use hyphen VAR so here I'm
overriding the ec2 type to be T2 medium
and then lastly here we have environment
variables we covered this this is where
it starts with TF underscore VAR
underscore followed by the name and this
is going to be very common when you are
using Code build servers or runtimes to
run this in a CI CD automated way now
there's a precedence to which these get
loaded meaning that that certain
configurations of or input of variables
will override other ones so as we go
down this list these ones will override
the previous one so at the top you have
environment variables if you have a
terraform tfrs file that will override
the environment variables if you have
the Json one that will override that one
if you have auto files that will
override the default tfrs file and then
on the last list you have hyphen VAR and
hyphen VAR file will override the rest
so there you go in terms of the exam
they're not going to ask you the
president's here but you're going to
need to know what VAR VAR file are
environment variables are in this
default line okay
thank you foreign
[Music]
let's take a look here at output values
which are computed values after a
terraform apply is performed output
values allow you to obtain information
after resource provisioning such as a
public IP address I'll put a file of
values for chromatic integration
cross-reference Stacks via outputs in a
state file via terraform remote State
and so here's an example of an outputs
block so notice that there's a block and
you specify some stuff there you can
optionally provide a description it's
not necessary but generally with outputs
I would recommend putting that in there
you can also Mark it as sensitive so it
does not show in your terminal this is
important if you're doing like logging
stuff you don't want to compromise those
values there but understand that output
values even though they might not be
outputted to your terminal or SD out
they will be visible within the state
file so if somebody opens up the state
file they're going to be plainly visible
there so just understand that sensitive
does not protect the values there okay
now in terms of how we would use the CLI
with the output values if we type
terraform output it's just going to
print out all the values that are within
the state file I don't show this in the
example here but if you wanted to use a
um a like bash command to parse Json you
could extract them out and see they're
just plainly in the Json okay if you
need to get exactly a particular field
you type in terraform output and Then
followed by the name if you wanted an
adjacent format all the output then you
could give that flag I don't know if it
would work with this one I actually
didn't test I just thought about that
here for this one here if you want the
raw output of it meaning like if you
output a string and you want it to be
escaped or what have you then you could
use it pragmatically by passing it to
something like curl to do something but
the idea with all these output values is
that it's one way of inspecting but you
could also use this in a configuration
script or or something to do kind of
like an after action okay
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look at
local values also known as locals that
assigns a name to an expression so you
can use it multiple times within a
module without repeating it so here what
we're going to do is Define our local
block up here and then the idea is that
we're assigning these names or IDs
expressions or values so that we can
reuse them throughout our code notice
that we can Define multiple local blocks
in the same file and I just say this
because like when you use required
providers you're only allowed to have a
single block but this case like with
variables or locals you can have many
and you could even Nest them within each
other so notice down here we're
referencing local within a local so
that's totally possible and I imagine
it's in the order to which it is
specified we can do static values or
computed values so we can actually
here's a function write an expression
and then it will output a value
once a local value is declared you can
reference it via the dot as local dot
the name so here notice within our it
was resource we have local and common
tags I have to point this out but when
you're referencing you use the singular
local because you might get an exam
question which shows you local dot or
locals Dot and the trick here is you got
to remember which one it is locals help
can help dry up your code it is best
practice to use local sparingly since
it's uh in terraform it's intended to be
declarative and overuse of locals can
make it difficult to determine what the
code is doing this call comes back to
describing terraform as declarative plus
where they give you functionality that's
imperative like but the idea is that you
know if you overuse these you can run
into trouble okay
[Music]
hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we are taking a look at data sources for
terraform so the idea here is you want
information to find outside of terraform
and it's defined by another separator
from configuration or Modified by
functions so the idea here is we are
going to Define ourselves a data block
and we have an external resource we're
looking for so we're saying hey I want
to see if I have an AWS Ami we're going
to use these filters as a way of of kind
of selecting it within our AWS account
so we'd have a provider set up and so
it'd be looking within that account to
find it and it's even saying look for
the most recent Ami okay and once we
have found that data source we can just
reference it so notice we're using data
to reference it there so data AWS
ami.web ID so there you go
[Music]
we're taking a look here at name values
and these are built-in Expressions that
reference uh various values you'll find
your configuration scripts we do cover
these in their respected sections but I
wanted to consolidate them here in one
place just so that you get a second
chance to reinforce this information
because Crux of questions of the exam
could be based on knowing how the name
values work so let's go through them the
first is resources I'm going to get up
my pen tool here and so the way
resources work is that you start with
the resource type so AWS instance and
then you're going to do the name of it
so there's nothing that uh
starts before the left hand side of it
so just remember it just starts with
that resource type then you have input
variables and that starts with VAR
period so that's the singular VAR then
we have local values and again that's
singular so local period for child
modules it starts with module period
again singular for data sources it's
going to be data singular just remember
singular because they can have a matchup
on the on the exam questions whether
it'll be like data or datas for file
system and workspace info we have
path.module this is the path of module
where the expression is placed we have
path.root this is the path of the root
module of the configuration we have path
CWD this is the path of the current
working directory and in practice the
default CWD is the same as the roots so
those would be technically the same we
have terraform.workspace this is the
name of the currently selected workspace
then we have block local values these
are things that appear within a body of
a blocks so this could be within a
resource provisioners things like that
so we have if we're using the count meta
argument we're going to get count and
with that we'll have count dot index so
we can say okay this is the fourth
iteration of you know uh this this
account Loop then we have for each and
this allows us to have the key and the
value so we can access that during our
iterations we have self uh so selfless
uh references information within
provisioners or connections so it's just
like a self-referencing thing name
values resemble the attribute notation
of map or object values but are not
objects and do not act as objects you
cannot use square brackets to access
attributes of name values like an object
so there you go
[Music]
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at resource
meta arguments so the terraform language
defines several meta-arguments which can
be used with any resource type to change
the behavior of resources and so we'll
quickly go through the list here and
then we will Deep dive on each so the
first is depends on so this is for
specifying explicit dependencies we have
count which is for creating multiple
resource instances according to account
we have four each which is used to
create multiple instances according to a
map or set of strings provider so this
is for selecting a non-default provider
configuration life cycle this is for
life cycle customizations provisioner
this is and also for connections for
taking extra actions after resource
creation so there's the Quick List now
let's jump into them
[Music]
all right the First Resource meta
argument we want to look at here is
called depends on and this is the order
of which resources are provisioned and
is important when resources depend on
others before they are provisioned
terraform implicitly can determine the
order of provision of resources but
there may be some cases where it cannot
be determined or like the correct order
so this is where you can be a bit more
explicit so here we have some terraform
configuration where we have an AWS
instance and it relies on a policy and
so what we're doing is we're setting an
explicit depends on here so that it
knows that it requires that now in a
normal use case you would not have to do
this but it's hard to find use cases
where this happens but when it does
become a problem you'll know because
your resources will not provision
correctly you'll get an error so there
you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at the count
resource meta argument and this is when
you're managing a pool of objects so an
example here would be a fleet of virtual
machines where you want to use count so
here on the right hand side we have an
example of us using that in terraform so
we can specify the amount of instances
we want so here it is four and then
we'll have access to this name value
called count dot index so the tags will
start at zero so it'll be server zero
one two and three then just down below
here I just want to show you that with
count you can accept a numeric
expression so you know if you had a
variable that you had set as the subnet
IDs or even just an arbitrary number
like you want to have X amount of
servers this would allow you to do that
okay but just so you know those numbers
must be whole and a number must be known
before the configuration which you'd put
in your input variables okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
four each which is for iterating over
resource meta arguments but it's
slightly different because it allows you
to map over Dynamic values giving you a
little bit more flexibility so here's an
example of us defining A4 each and
notice that we have defined a map
sometimes I call it an object because
they're so similar but this is a map and
the idea is that once you have your map
defined with your 4-H you will now have
access to these name values so you can
do each dot key or each dot value to
extract that out
you can also just use it like with an
array so here we have an array and then
we use two set to turn it into a set
which it will accept as well and then we
can just pull out the key because there
will be no value so just an example of
with a map and then with something that
looks like an array okay
[Music]
to understand the resource meta argument
life cycle we need to understand how
resource Behavior works and so when you
execute your execution order via
terraform apply it will perform one of
the following to a resource so the most
common one you'll see is a create so
these are resources that exist in the
configuration but are not associated
with a real infrastructure object in the
state the way you can tell it's creating
it will have this nice little green plus
sign the next one is destroy so
resources that exist in the state but no
longer exist in the configuration and so
that's going to tear down your resources
out of your Cloud providers this is
represented by a minus symbol then you
have update in place so the resources
who arguments have changed so the idea
here is that if you have a virtual
machine and let's say you change the
size of it it's not going to destroy it
it's just going to modify its settings
this is represented with a tilde and the
last one here is destroy and recreate so
resources who arguments have change but
which cannot be updated in place due to
remote API limitations so there are just
some Cloud resources that always require
destroy and recreate and this is
something very easy to trigger if you
are using the replace command or the
older terraform tank command in order to
replace a degraded or damaged instance
so let's talk about life cycle so
lifecycle blocks allow you to change
what happens to resources on the create
update and Destroy lifecycle blocks are
nested within resources so here is a
resource which is just an Azure Resource
Group and within it we have a life cycle
block and we're setting our first option
here that's possible called the create
before destroy so this is a Boolean and
when replacing a resource first create
the new resource before deleting it so
the default is destroyed old first so
this is more about just the order of How
It's destroyed prevent destroy so
ensures a resource is not destroyed then
we have ignore changes and this is based
off a list of attributes that you feed
to it so don't change the resource on
create update to store right if a change
occurs for the listed attributes so
maybe
um maybe you uh you're just changing a
tag and you say don't don't change uh
like don't tear down create or do
anything strange if we change a tag okay
so there you go that's uh life cycles
[Music]
so we're looking at our last meta
argument here which are resource
providers and this goes along with the
idea of an alias so here we are defining
ourselves a provider in Google Cloud but
there's a case where we might need to
override the provider uh at a at a per
resource level and the way we do that is
by creating an additional provider and
setting an alias and then here we could
change something like the region and
then once we have that set we can then
reference our provider explicitly under
a resource and so that's all there is to
it definitely on your exam you will see
a question about Alias or you'll see
that example so definitely want to know
how to do that okay
[Music]
thank you
all right so we're starting our
introduction here into terraform
Expressions because there's a lot we can
talk about here so expressions are used
to refer to or Com or compute values
within a configuration so terraform
Expressions is a large topic and we'll
be covering types and values strings and
templates reference to values operators
function calls conditional Expressions
four Expressions Splat Dynamic blocks
type constraints actually I don't think
we covered type constraints just because
there's nothing really to say about it
but we definitely cover version
constraints so yeah let's start off the
section and go to it
[Music]
so we're taking a look here at types and
values for expressions and so the result
of an expression is a value and all
values have types and so we have
primitive types no type and complex
structural collection types that last
one is a bit more complicated than what
we are presenting here we're going to
simplify it and then cover it later okay
so for primitive types we have strings
so you have your double quotations which
represent your string then you have
numbers so it's going to be integers or
floats then you have booleans so this is
either true or false for no types we
have null and so null is different in
all different types of languages so it's
very important to understand how it
works and so null represents absence or
Omission when you want to use the
underlying default of a provider's
resource configuration option so when
you're saying null doesn't mean it's
nothing it's going to be whatever the
default is and the default also could be
nothing it's just depending on what that
is on the provider so for collection or
for a collection types complex
structural types we have list or Tuple
and this generally looks like an array
the then you have map and object and
this looks like basically like a Json
object or a ruby hash or I think they
call it in Python a dictionary so that
gives you an idea of the basic types but
for this last one here because this I
found really confusing list tuples map
object we definitely explain this more
in the course okay
[Music]
okay so we're giving a little bit more
attention to the string type because
there's a little bit more going on here
so when quoting strings you got to use
double quotes uh at one point terraform
I believe supported single quotes I
think it only Sports double quotes now
and honestly you generally want to just
use double quotes because double quotes
always support Escape sequences this is
pretty much standard across all
programming languages but the idea here
is you can do things like new line
carriage return tab literal quotes
literal backslashes Unicode characters
both basic multilingual plane and
supplementary planes there are some
special Escape sequences this makes
sense when we look at the next slide for
string templates but there's these
things where you can do interpolation
and so you might not want to actually do
them you might want to do it without and
so if you just use double of the symbol
that will allow you to do it then there
is also the ability to have multi-line
strings and we use hear DOC for that and
so here Doc is a little bit different in
all languages but here we're using Unix
style so that means that we're going to
start with these two two angled brackets
to the left our opening angle brackets
followed by some word that is all in
uppercase it doesn't have to be eot it
could be whatever you want I always like
to type here Doc and then it has to end
at the same indentation level with the
same word all uppercase and then
everything in between will be treated as
um
as multi-line the nice thing about this
is that when you have this you can
actually just use double quotes wherever
you want because you don't have to
escape them okay let's take a look at
string templates because this is the
real power of strings so the first is
string interpolation and this allows you
to evaluate an expression between the
markers so the idea is instead of having
to do double quotations and do plus
signs to stitch together uh strings what
you do is just do a dollar sign uh curly
braces and then put the the expression
or variable that you want uh to be
converted okay then you have string
directives and these are slightly
different this allows you to evaluate an
expression for a conditional logic
between the markers so let's say we want
to have an if else statement so if the
name is blank
then use VAR name or sorry if it's not
blank then use the name provided
otherwise put it as unnamed okay you can
also use interpolation directives with
hear docs so you know just to show that
you can do it and then the last one
thing here is you can strip out white
space that would normally be left by
directors blocks by providing a trailing
tilde so just notice this little tilde
here on the end because these do take up
space so if you were to view it there'd
just be an empty space there if you want
that space to vanish then you just put
that tilde on the end so there you go
foreign
let's take a look here at the possible
operators that we can use within
terraform expressions and so just a
refresher operators are mathematical
operations you can perform two numbers
within Expressions I'm not going to show
full examples here and the outputs of
them because this is pretty common for
programming or scripting languages and
also the exam is not really going to
focus on the use cases for these so it's
just more so to tell you what is
available too so you know what you can
use the first is multiplication so you
take two numbers and times them to get a
larger number division so it uses a
forward slash modulus and if you've
never used modulus I really like this it
allows you to see if something is
divisible by a certain amount and then
you get the remainder you have addition
subtraction if you need to flip to a
negative number you can just put a minus
sign in front of it if you need to do
equals its doubles if you want to do
does not equal its exclamation equals
then we have a less than so that's a
open angled bracket less than or equal
so that will be followed by an equal
sign greater than is a closing angle
bracket and Then followed by an equal
sign for greater than or equal you have
or which uses the double pipes you have
n which uses the double ampersands if
you need to flip a Boolean you can just
put an exclamation in front of it so if
it was true now it is false if it was
false now is true I'm not sure what it
would do for an all I would think that
it would turn it to true but uh yeah so
there you go
foreign
we're taking a look here at conditional
expressions and this is pretty much the
only way that you can do if-el
statements within terraform but it works
out fine and so it's actually using the
ternary style of ill if else so what
that looks like it's a single line so
the it starts with a question mark so
that's the if and then it's the True
Value and then the colon represents the
else and then you have your false value
it's ternary because there's three
things one two and three okay so that's
the way I remember this thing it's not a
a preferred way of doing Ethel
statements in other languages because it
is a little bit condensed but it makes
sense when you're using scripting
language and you're really restricted on
per line actions so this is what it
would look like in action so we'd have a
variable that is a if a does not equal a
blank then use the variable or set it to
default a as a string so that's kind of
an example there
I'll just wipe that away there the
return type of it of of the if and else
must be the same type so if you have a
number okay and the one if statement and
then you have a string they have to be
the same so uh obviously we want a
string to be returned in both cases so
what we'll do is use this built-in
function to string to turn this into a
string so that we're not going to run
into any problems so there you go
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
four expressions and so these allow you
to iterate over a complex type and apply
Transformations a four expression can
accept as input list set Tuple map or an
object I want to distinguish this
between four each which is a resource
meta argument which allows you to
iterate over a a resource or a
collection of resources that are similar
but four expressions are for these
primitive types or not these primitive
types but these collection structural
types that we talked about in types and
values okay so here's an example of
something we might want to do imagine we
have a list of names and we want to
iterate through our list and make them
all uppercase so we could do that with
this four so we have the four with the n
and then we're providing the value of
each item in our list it's easy to think
of list or Tuple as an array so I'll
just call it an array okay
then you have a map and so this is where
it has a key and value this is going to
be for maps or objects and the idea is
that we can then go apply
Transformations and notice that we are
returning only a single string so we're
actually going to get back something
like a tuple and so how does it decide
whether it returns a um a array or
something that looks like an object
we'll explain that here in a moment the
last one here is we have a list with an
index so it's very similar to the first
one but in this case we want to know the
index here so imagine this says zero is
Andrew one is Cindy two is Peter and it
would come back as an array or list so
let's talk about the return types the
return types are defined by the um uh
the braces or brackets that are around
the actual expression so if you have
square braces we're going to go back to
Tuple so it's just think that array so
for in this case where we had our list
it was returning back a tuple okay
if we have curly braces it's going to
return an object so here we have a list
so it's like an array that's coming in
here and then we were specifying as the
return uh this kind of object structure
and so that's how we're going to get
that so that's that there's one other
thing we want to mention which has to do
with
um reducing or ordering so an if
statement can be used to reduce the
amount of elements returned so in this
case what we're doing is we're using an
if statement
and so we're saying unless this is true
so if this is true then return if it's
not then return less of what is there so
if there's any blank names that are in
our list they just won't show up it'll
just only show names that are actually
there
um then we have implicit element
ordering so since terraform can convert
an unordered type so map objects and
sets to an order type list or tuples it
will need to choose an implied ordering
so for maps and objects they're stored
by key A to Z set of strings stored by a
strings A to Z everything else is going
to be arbitrary ordering so there you go
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
spy expressions and these provide a
shorter expression for the four
expression which we just looked at so
what is the Splat operator a Splat
operator is represented by an asterisk
it originates from the Ruby language and
Splats in terraform are used to roll up
or soak up a bunch of iterations in a
for expression so here is an example
where it's for list sets or tuples so
here we have a list and the idea is that
we're iterating over this ID or in this
game we're iterating over
um its objects or sorry a array and then
that array is containing a bunch of
objects and so we're accessing the name
within it and so instead of writing it
like that we don't even have to use it
for at all what we can do is put this
asterisk here and this is going to
equate to the same thing so here this is
going to return all the IDS and in this
case it's going to return a all the
lists and allow us to access the
interfaces along to the name okay
so let's take a look at spy Expressions
uh when we're applying them to lists so
if the value is anything other than a
null value then the Splat expression
will transform it into a single element
list if the value is null then the
expression uh the then the Splat
expression will return an empty Tuple
and so this behavior is useful for
modules that accept optional input
variables whose default value is null to
represent the absence of any value to
adapt the variable value to work with
other terraform language features that
are designed to work with collections so
I know that's a big mouthful it's just
kind of like an edge case to these Spa
Expressions this is not going to show up
in the exam but I just wanted to show it
to you in case you're interested here
and just notice the spots being used
over here okay
foreign
[Music]
so we're taking a look here at Dynamic
blocks and this allows you to
dynamically construct repeatable nested
blocks so I want to emphasize that this
is a very powerful feature that can lead
to abuse where your code becomes uh
difficult to read but it's also very
flexible it will absolutely show up in
the exam so pay close attention on how
this works so let's say you needed to
create a bunch of Ingress rules for your
ec2 security group and so this would
lead to a lot of repeatable elements for
rules within your resource and so what
you can do with Dynamic blocks is you
can Define objects locally so here I
have my Ingress rules as an object so
here's one and here is two and then
using Dynamic block what I can do is use
a 4-H to reference those Ingress rules
and within this Dynamic Ingress block
we'll have our content and this will
specify the things that we're swapping
out so the idea is that it will iterate
over this and apply all those values
there so it's something you can't do
with a 4-H or account this is basically
the the most advanced iteration but just
understand if you remember this use case
and it's very easy to understand or
remember how to use it when you're doing
an exam okay
[Music]
we're looking at version constraints so
terraform utilizes semantic version for
specifying terraform providers and
module versions so semantic versioning
is an open standard on how to define
versioning for software management so
you have your major minor and your patch
and so here are examples or variants on
this here so we have
um you know where you see major minor
then you can have this RC this rc1 or
you could not have it or you can have
beta and this can all be read about on
the samver.org but just to quickly go
through it
major version is when you want to make
incompatible API changes minor is when
you add functionality that is backwards
compatible in matter
patch is when you make backwards
compatible bug fixes there are
additional labels for pre-release build
metadata that are available as
extensions so that's where we see those
little additions there at the top a
version straight is a string containing
one or more conditions separated by
commas so you have your equals or no
operators or sorry your equals or no
operators so match exact version of the
number so it's either with the equals or
not with the operator at all okay that's
what I'm trying to write there excludes
an exact number uh version so if we just
said does not or will not be uh 1.0.0
then you have a comparative ones so they
have the version has to be greater or
equal to 1.0.0
um and then we have one with the tilde
so allows only the rightmost version of
the last number to increment so what
this means is that the the last number
here is only allowed to increment okay
so let's talk about Progressive
versioning because this kind of ties
into semantic uh versioning but
Progressive version is the practice of
using the latest version to keep a
proactive stance of security modernity
and development agility and we like to
describe this as practicing good hygiene
when we're uh working with our code okay
so by being up to date you're always
pushing left on things that need to stay
fixed or compatible you'll have to deal
with smaller problems instead of dealing
with a big problem later on run nightly
builds is a good example where you might
have golden images and the idea is to
provide a warning signal just to kind of
elaborate on that a nightly build is an
automated workflow that occurs at night
when developers are asleep so if the
build breaks because A change is
required for the code the developers
will see this upon arrival in the
morning and be able to budget
accordingly so what I'm trying to get at
is that when you are like
putting in your providers especially if
you copy from the terraform
um
the terraform website to get the
providers and modules what they'll do is
they'll actually have it set as the I'm
just going to roll back here for a
second but they'll actually have it set
as the equals what I'm saying to you is
you want to use something like a tilde
or a greater than or equal sign so that
you are staying Progressive okay so
that's just one thing I want you to
watch out for and we will talk about
that when we go through the follow
alongs okay
[Music]
hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we are moving on to our expression
section starting with string templates
let's learn all about that and we are
going to have to CD into a new folder
here
so I have one called expressions and we
will make ourselves a new file called
main.tf we'll Define a local back end
and I'm going to just Define a new
variable
I'm going to call this variable hello
and I'm going to give it a type of
string
okay and that's all I'm going to do
there and then what we're going to do is
create ourselves a TF VAR file so we'll
say
terraform Dot tfvars and in there we'll
just set hello
to world
and so what I want to do is enter
terraform console
okay this is going to allow us to just
run arbitrary Expressions I want to show
you how you quit it you just type exit
and so we'll do is make a string so
we'll just first do a Hello World
I want to show you that you can put a uh
a new line there and we'll get back a
multi-line document this is a
um this console doesn't allow for
multiple lines so we can't write our own
here doc but I can show you what it
looks like
and then we can interpolate a uh a
variable there so we'll just say hello
and notice we get hello world so that's
how interpolation works it's not super
complicated directives is a little bit
different
where we have string right so we can do
instead this
but the control word is a bit different
because you're using the uh this um
percentage sign the directives when
you're doing something like an if else
statement so what we could do
is say something like
um barsoon here
okay
and what I'm going to do is just exit
out here clear because I don't know if
it um it reloads the uh the variables
there if you just change them on the Fly
but what we'll do is we'll just say
hello and we will write ourselves an if
statement so we're going to say if VAR
dot hello equals
bar soon
what it's going to do is then print out
um
it's going to instead print out Mars
okay
otherwise
what we're going to get is
um
world okay
you know what's really interesting is
we're using the if and else
here
but I I could have swore that the only
thing you had was ternary operators so
like if you look at the conditional
expressions
notice here that it's doing this and
it's not showing the documentation the
FL so you know maybe maybe that's just
for a one-liner and if else does exist
for expressions and I might have missed
that in the course but you cannot blame
me if the documentation shows it like
that okay
so what I'm going to do here is just go
ahead and hit enter
and here we get hello Mars so that
pretty much
uh shows you how string interpolation
works for both interpolation and
directives we'll just type in exit and
so that's all we want to do there okay
[Music]
all right so let's learn about four
Expressions so four Expressions allow us
to kind of iterate over something and do
something fun with it and so what we're
going to do is create ourselves some
more complex types here so how about
instead of like this was just hello a
second ago but we'll change this over to
Worlds and what I'm going to do is just
list out a bunch of Worlds here from the
uh the book uh John Carter books so we
have bar soon we have
jasum
we have things like sesum
okay and then we have whoops
so assume and then we have something
like cosume okay
and so the idea here is now that we've
defined that there we've got to go back
to our main TF I'm just going to update
this to the worlds this will just be a
list
all right and so what we'll do is make
our way over to terraform cloud or sorry
terraform console
and we will try to do a four Loop here
so I'm going to do Square braces four
and we'll just say w in VAR dot worlds
and then what we can do here is
make a colon whoops
okay and then type upper
W and so that returns them all in
uppercase there
and if we were to use the Splat operator
and technically this is something we
want to move on to the next part
but
um yeah we'll leave it for the next
video I'll just keep that separate so
that is for just if we had a list
imagine if we had this as the as an
index here
um or we'll say map
because what we can do is actually map
these two names
so bring this down here
and this would be Earth
now you can use the colon or the equals
it's just whatever you want to use here
they're both supported actually this is
an Earth this is Mars and then this one
here is Earth
and this one here would be
Jupiter
and then this one here would be Venus
okay
um and so I think we still need to
Define it over here
so I'm just going to say world's map
and then what we can do here instead of
having list we can say map
and we'll try to iterate over this so
it's going to be very similar except the
difference is now we have a key and we
have a value
and so if we just want to return the
names in capital we can just do K here
oh that's the index uh what if we do
oh you know why it's because
um
we have to do Worlds Map
okay
so reference to Undeclared variable map
so we do have to exit and restart
and oh sorry the input was complaining
there so I'll just copy the one up here
so I have to type it again
nope it did not work as we thought okay
so I do have to type it by hand
kind of a pain but I guess that's just
how it works so we'll say 4K V invar Dot
worlds
map
and then we say upper
B here
okay or we could just say take the K
here and get the other values now I
didn't show you this a moment ago but if
we do worlds here we can specify an
index and an index would come first so
it would be the value like the world the
second and the index is first so notice
that I is all a number the index of it
and then the that is the value there
um
we could probably also return this as a
map so notice that square braces are
going to give you a list or and then
curlers are going to give you map which
kind of correspond to their actual data
structure so if we wanted to turn this
into the opposite here what we could do
is just say uh we probably do string
interpolation
like this here and do I
and then do equals or even maybe a colon
here
and then do the world like that
and it didn't like the way I specified
it so I'll try it like this instead
extra characters after the line four
so I don't see that wrong there just
give me a moment I think um
oh you know what it's we need to use in
this case I think we have to do it this
way
okay so we use use the hash rocket so in
that particular case you have to use the
hash rocket that's what that symbol is
called the equal zero
um and so that's how we can get that
value there so that pretty much outlines
how to use
um the for loops and next we're going to
go probably look at the Splats okay so
I'll see you back here in a moment I'm
just going to exit this actually before
we move on to Splats I just want to add
one more thing to four Expressions which
is filtering so we'll just go back here
and get back into
our terraform console here
and what I'm going to do is just write
another four
and it probably would make sense to use
the uh the the world's list we just did
there so I'm going to do KV type in VAR
world's map
and so the idea here is that I only want
the let's say we'll say the upper I only
want the
key value here but I would just say at
the end here I can say if the V the
value equals I can't remember what we
set these as
so this is key in value so if it is Mars
I think it's double equals so if it is
Mars
then only return it that way or we could
say the opposite say
give me everything but Mars okay so I
just wanted to show you you could use
that if to do that filtering so I'm
going to exit there and we'll move on to
spots okay
[Music]
all right so we're moving on to Splats
and what we'll have to do is create
ourselves a new variable here I'm going
to call this one world's
Splat and this one is going to be a list
and so if we go back up here to tfvars
we'll make ourselves a new variable down
here and we'll just call this one splat
and it's going to be a list but it's
going to contain inside of it a bunch of
maps
okay so we'll do pretty much this up
here
okay but what's going to happen here
it's going to be slightly different
where we are going to
set what is the name
so we'll just say like
um
Earth name
that's actually Mars name so it's a Mars
name here
for all these
and then over here these are going to be
the Earth name
so I think that is valid and what we're
going to do here is just type in
terraform console
and if we wrote that correctly oh no we
got an error so it says expected an
equal sign to Mark the beginning of a
new attribute value
so I mean this should be okay
uh oh you know what I think this Colon's
just missing here
put it up again
there we go we're fine so if we just
want to look at that variable I think we
just type it in here and it might print
it out if we're lucky
yes so there it is
um so what we're going to do here is use
a Splat to get maybe the Mars name or
something so if we used a for Loop what
we'd have to probably write we could try
this
but we'd have to do four and then it
would be for the actual map so say m for
map in world's splat
and then we would have to do m
Dot Mars name
and so a reference to the attribute
by one axis treatment specifying the
resource name
so I mean that looks oh you know it's
because we didn't write VAR okay
I say we but it was really me so you
know that's that but we could write this
in a more concise way
okay and so we use a splat
Mars name
okay so you know that's a lot more
convenient if we're just trying to
access variables like that
um I think that if you're trying to do
things like
if you want to do upper here
I think you still have to use A4
expression
okay I don't think you can do this we
can try it but I really don't think that
will work
no and if we look at the documentation
they don't show an example like that so
you know it's not that bad but you can
see that it's for a particular use case
you can't use that for uh Maps or
whatever the equivalent the other map is
object but it's useful for this one
particular use case okay
[Music]
hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we are on to the dynamic blocks follow
along so this one should be uh pretty
fun because it's uh quite a powerful
feature so what I've done is I've
created a new folder here called Dynamic
blocks I'm going to make a new file here
as always it's going to be main.tf and a
really good example for this would
probably be a database Security Group
just because there's all those Ingress
and out outgress or egress rules so what
we're going to do is just Define our
terraform settings block and I'm just
going to pull up over here and make our
way over to the registry for terraform
and what we're going to do is go over to
the AWS provider and go to the
documentation and actually I first want
to grab the provider itself because that
is something very easy that we can do
here we'll just move that on over so we
can see what we're doing and paste that
on in and we're going to have to Define
our provider of course so we'll name
that as AWS the profile is going to be
defaults and our region will be us East
one
okay and so now what we need is to
co-create ourselves a security group
so we have of course done that
previously here but
let's pull up the uh documentation here
I believe it was actually under VPC so
let's just go down to VPC here and we
will expand that and then underneath
here there should be a AWS Security
Group
uh there it is and if we scroll on down
there's the thing okay so what I'm going
to do is copy uh this code here and go
over and we'll just paste that on in and
there is our security group so I
remember that we had to have the
description if you remember it
complained about that
so outgoing
for everyone
and we need to also have a few
additional things
we will just scroll on down here because
it wanted the prefix list IDs
okay
remember we needed that I think there
was like self false
and there was like security groups
I think it was actually AWS security
groups in particular let's just double
check to make sure that is the case
it is called
uh oh it's just security groups okay
so
we'll say self equals false
we do not need cider block four here or
six
um we do not need this one here and it
doesn't really matter what we set this
to so it could be set to the main side
or block that's totally fine but we are
going to need to add a data source just
like last time for the VPC
so we'll say VPC we'll call that Main
and I think it just needed the VPC ID it
was as simple as that
and so we will go over to AWS over to
VPC
and from there we are going to go to
rvbcs and I will go grab that VPC ID
Okay so we've grabbed our VPC ID and
then we just need to name this as data
and then we're going to name this as
data we don't really care what the cider
block is it's just again for
um this demo purposes we don't need tags
we'll take those out
and
um
yeah everything else is fine okay so
this now comes to the fact that we want
to use Dynamic blocks before we do that
let's just well I think I didn't leave
the console there last but what we'll do
here is
just to our terraform inits
and as that is pulling that stuff we're
going to look up Dynamic blocks
uh terraform
so we'll go here and so Dynamic blocks
is like way more powerful than um the
four each where what we can do I'm just
trying to
find that example there but we have
uh we have to set the dynamic part the
4-H you know what I'm pretty sure I have
these in my slides so let's just use my
slides as the reference here
dynamic
ah here it is okay so the idea is that
we'll just set up a locals with all of
our information here and then we will
create this Dynamic block and then
provide the content okay so I'm just
going to move that off screen so I can
see what I am doing here as we type it
in and we'll see if we run into any
problems
um failed to query the available product
for packages could not retrieve the list
of the available versions for the
provider uh not have a provider registry
terraform name all models should specify
the required providers so I'm not sure
why it's complaining here but we'll
scroll all the way to the top and the
required providers is correctly set here
so it shouldn't be a problem
not sure what it doesn't like
um so let's just type in terraform
providers here
the VPC
um is VPC a module
you know what it's probably because I
didn't do AWS VPC that's probably my
problem here
terraforming net
and as that's thinking there we'll just
pull this on down and we'll start to
make our locals block okay so we can go
here make some locals and we'll do our
Ingress
and we'll just
go like that
and the idea is we can say Port whoops
we can set the port like that 443
we have to always have a description so
we'll just set that as well so port
443 we can set
as much as we want here so I'll just go
ahead enter
okay
and
I think that looks right yeah so we have
one Ingress here and then we'll just
copy this and make a comma
vs code is not really formatting the way
I wanted to and so we'll do port 80.
and then down below we will need to
specify
hour
um
for each okay so that's going to be
within our Dynamic block so what we're
going to do is tab in here I'm going to
say dynamic
and we'll type it Ingress because that's
a match for what we're doing
um and then from there we can do our
four each equals local Ingress
and then we need to specify our content
I don't really understand why it's
called content and things like that but
I just know that that's what we have to
do and it's not really that big of a
deal so
we'll go here and paste that in we can
take out our Ingress block there we know
we're going to need self these all here
but what's going to change
are these ports so
we will go here it will say Ingress
Value Port and this will also be Ingress
Value Port
and then this will be Ingress value
description
if we really wanted to we could also set
the protocol
protocol Pro
Tove call
and this could be then TCP
and so we would just say Ingress value
protocol
so it just saves us from repeating these
over and over again if they're all the
same
there's a lot you can do with Dynamic
blocks but honestly you shouldn't do
anything
too crazy
we'll do our terraform plan and see if
this works whoops
bring that up there
um an argument VPC ID as not expected
here okay so
that was me just guessing from memory
and I guess I guessed wrong
uh so what we'll do
is we'll just look that up
AWS VPC data source terraform
oh it's just ID okay
so what we'll do is just set ID here
and then we'll just hit plan again
and that should resolve our issue there
uh inappropriate value for a tribute
egress security groups is required okay
that's fine
well this one says doesn't say uh Syria
groups
and this one doesn't say Security Group
so that's probably our problem here so
we'll just hit terraform plan again
and here it says this VPC ID does not
exist probably what happened is they
might be in the wrong region
it's very common problem
on AWS just because of the way their UI
works
if I can get this window over here and
so this is because we're in USC's we're
supposed to be in U.S east one here
and I'm going to go up
to here
we'll save that
let me hit terraform plan
and we could probably like use the
filter and also just say choose the
default but it's just so easy to put
that in like that so
doesn't seem like we have any problems
here so let's go ahead and execute let's
just double check to make sure these
values are correct
so for the Ingress
um Port 443 Port 443 it's probably just
because I didn't update the description
probably because of a copy paste job yep
okay and let's just make sure this works
so we'll say terraform apply Auto
approve
and we'll give it a moment
and it's already created so it's that
fast we can go here and take a look at
it if we like
it's not that big of a deal
um so we should see it in here I just
have so many
uh junk security groups here this is a
bit hard to find
oh allow TLS is what we called it so
here it is
go to our inbound rules
80443 and that's pretty much it so
terraform apply
destroy Auto approve
okay
there we go
[Music]
all right so I want to talk about
versioning very quickly here and so I
have a new folder called versions I'm
going to just make a new file called
main.tf and we're going to create a
terraform block but what we're also
going to do is set required
uh providers or sorry required uh we're
not providers required version and so
what this is going to do is say
explicitly what version of terraform we
want to use and I'm sending it this as
1.0.0 and I'm using this tilde Arrow if
you're wondering you know what is the
logic behind all those things I think
it's all explained in the semantic or
semver.org so if you want to learn more
I strongly recommend you read through
this to understand all the stuff inside
and out highly applicable across the
devosphere not just to terraform
um but you know if we go over to
terraform GitHub repository and we drop
down the branches and go to tags here we
can see all the versioning we are using
version 1.0.0 and it all goes up to
1.1.0 Alpha which is not out yet and if
you wanted to really know what's going
on here you go to releases and you can
read what they have done so here 1.0.7
remove check for computer attribute
prevent object types with optional
attributes for ETC empty containers so
when you're looking at the patch the
patch which is the third number the the
rightmost number that's going to keep
you up to date in terms of security for
the the major minor version that you
have for the 1.0 and you absolutely
always want to be using the latest and
so that's what this tilde does it says
take the far Road uh the the farthest
number to the right and make sure that
it's the latest version that has been
published
um and you know this comes back to my
Progressive versioning slide which is if
you want to have really good hygiene in
terms of your devops we should be doing
is at least setting the tilde for sure
like this the tilde Arrow or I would
even go as far as saying equals arrow
and if you're really concerned about
um you know not using the next major
version you could say you will less than
you know like less than
um less than you know one point
2.0 even if it's not out that's a good
indicator to say okay well I don't want
to go too far ahead of time but if you
want to have Progressive versioning you
should really be setting it like this
okay
and this is going to be applicable for
your image providers anything else so
you know if we go over to
if we go over to the registry
and we choose
whoops
AWS and we drop this down here we have
that required version as well so as you
copy it in you're going to notice that
it's actually hard coded but I would
strongly recommend again
if we go here
and take this and at least at least do
this
and if you're really really being clever
you could do that okay and these are
also all in GitHub repositories as
that's how everything works so you can
go here and click and you can go over to
the tags and see the versioning and you
can go over to the releases and it's the
same thing you can read about all the
things that have changed okay and that's
something that you should uh you know
consider doing all right so that's all
there really is to this I might want to
show you one more thing and this one is
with terraform Cloud so I'm going to go
to terraform IO and we're going to open
up our terraform cloud and I'm going to
sign in I probably haven't signed in a
while so probably ask oh nope no
username password that's great what we
can do is in a workspace we go to
settings
and is it Version Control no it is
general and under here we can actually
set the terraform version so if you
happen to be working with a particular
version you can go and say okay only use
this version for terraform cloud and
that will
um that will not upgrade it'll just keep
you there if you need for legacy reasons
but again you know what you really
should be doing is using that
Progressive versioning doing nightly
builds and discovering overnight that
things are breaking so you can go fix
those in the morning okay and that's it
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at terraform
state so what is State well it's a
particular condition of cloud resources
at a specific time so give an example
imagine we expect to have a virtual
machine running Centos on AWS with a
compute type of T2 micro that would be
the state that we are expecting okay so
how does terraform preserve State well
when you provision infrastructure via
terraform it will create a state file
named terraform TF State it's very
important to remember that name because
it literally is an exam question the
exact naming of that okay this state
file is a Json data structure with a
one-to-one mapping from resource
instances to resource or to remote
objects and if you're wondering what is
a remote object versus a resource
instance I cannot tell you I would
imagine one is the representation of
things that are deployed in the cloud
and the other one are objects or or
things represented in the state file but
they don't clarify it so I just have to
take a guess so this is kind of what the
Json structure looks like like you can
see you see resources this is describing
like a type of instance and stuff like
that there's not really any case for you
to ever go through the terraform State
file and look at it but we might take a
peek just so that we get familiar as to
what it is doing
so just to kind of give it a diagram to
help you visualize this imagine you have
your configuration file so you have your
main TF maybe a variables TF a TF bars
to load in your variables and then you
run a terraform apply command what it's
doing is using the terraform API and
it's going to create what we'll say
these we'll call these remote objects
but maybe these are resource instances
um but it will go ahead and create those
things and then those will get
represented within a state file so the
idea is that whatever is in the cloud is
going to match what's in that file okay
now there is a CLI commands for
terraform State and it's good just to
quickly go through them so we have
terraform State list this will list
resources in the state terraform State
move this will move an item in the state
terraform State pull pull current remote
State and outputs to St out terraform
State push so update remote States from
a local state terraform State replace
provider so replace a provider in the
state terraform State removed so remove
instances from the state terraform State
shows so show a resource in the state
some of these are a little bit
interesting so we'll definitely look in
Greater detail to move and some of these
people just explore through our follow
alongs okay
foreign
[Music]
special attention to terraform State
move because it's definitely on the exam
uh and it is a little bit interesting to
what it can do so terraform State moves
allow you to rename existing resources
move a resource into a module move a
module into a module so if you were just
to rename a resource or move it to
another module and run terraform apply
terraform will destroy and create that
resource but State move allows you to
just change the reference so you can
avoid a create and Destroy action so an
example for renaming a resource we would
have terraform State move and then we
would have the we would identify the old
one so here we have packet device dot
worker and we are renaming it to helper
so it's we that's just how we're doing
it okay if we wanted to move a resource
into a module what we do is say
something like packet device dot worker
and then do
module.worker.packetdevice.worker okay
so the idea here is that we're moving it
into this module here
uh and I think we could probably even
rename it at the same time but uh we're
not doing that okay so move module into
a module so here we have module app and
then we're moving it into the parent one
so we go module.parent module.app okay
so what's important to remember for the
exam is that terraform State move is
when you want to rename existing
resources they're not going to get into
these more complicated use cases but
that's how you rename a a resource okay
[Music]
okay let's talk about how we back up our
state file so all terraform state
subcommands that modify state will write
a backup file so read-only commands will
not modify it so imagine listen show
will not cause a backup file to be
created terraform will take the current
state and store it in a file called
terraform.tsstate.backup so this is what
it would look like backups cannot be
disabled this is by Design to enforce
best practices for Recovery to get rid
of the backup file you would need to
manually delete the files so there you
go
[Music]
foreign
from exam Pro and we are taking a look
at terraforming knit so it initializes
your terraform project by downloading
plug-in dependencies so providers and
modules creating a DOT terraform
directory so that's a hidden directory
and creating a dependency lock file to
enforce the expected versions for
plugins in terraform itself so on the
right hand side here we can see we have
that hidden directory but also notice
here that we have a DOT terraform
lock.hcl that is our dependency lock
file and so our dependencies are all
going to end up within this sewers as
providers that's the provider version
there okay so terraform in it is
generally the First Command you will run
for a new terraform project if you
modify or change dependencies run
terraform in it again to have it apply
the changes you need to know that for
the exam because they will absolutely
ask you that the First Command here is
and these are ones with flags so you can
just do terraform in it but we have some
extra options so terraforming it hyphen
upgrade upgrade all plugins to the
latest version that complies with the
configuration version constraint
terraforma knit hyphen get plugins and I
think it's supposed to be equals false
there but skip plugin installation
terraform init plug-in hyphen dir equals
pass so Force plugin installation to
read plugins from only target directory
and then we have terraform init hyphen
lock file so you can change the lock
file mode it actually doesn't say what
the modes are so I don't even know what
you'd do in that case and I could not
find any examples but it is an option I
just want to make it very clear that
there is a dependency lock file but
there's also a state lock file and the
way you know that they're different is
that one has Dot Lock in it and the
other one has dot TF State this one up
here is for dependencies this one of
course is for State a terraform and it
does not create a state lock file that
is going to happen when you do a
terraform apply okay
[Music]
let's take a look at terraform get so
terraform get command is used to
download and update modules in the root
module so when you're a developer you
own terraform modules and you may need
to frequently pull updated modules but
you do not want to initialize your state
or pull new provider binaries and so the
idea here is terraform get is a
lightweight way it's because it's only
updating the modules it's not pulling
providers in most cases you want to use
terraform init with the exception of
local module development this will not
show up on the exam but I saw terraform
getting I was just so confused about it
so I just wanted to make sure I included
it here okay
[Music]
okay so we're going to be looking at
three CLI commands that are used to
improve debugging configuration scripts
the first is going to be terraform
format this rewrites terraform
configuration files to a standard format
and style terraform validate this
validates the syntax and arguments of
terraform configuration files in a
directory and then you have terraform
console an interactive shell for
evaluating terraform expressions and so
let's go jump into these three okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at terraform
format so this command applies a subset
of terraform language style conventions
along with other minor adjustments for
readability so terraform format will be
by default look in the current directory
and apply formatting to all your dot TF
files so let's look at some examples of
what it would format so the first is
adjusting spacing two spaces indent so
here we have something and it's over
indented and so by running terraform
format it fixes the indentation we can
also get syntax errors so notice here
that we have a problem and so what it's
saying is is that this bracket okay
is supposed to be up here okay but it's
all it's down here uh and the last one
here is we can do terraform format
hyphen hyphen diff that's going to show
what it would change okay so there you
go
[Music]
let's take a look at terraform validate
so this runs checks that verify whether
configuration is syntactically valid and
internally consistent regardless of the
provided variables in existing state
validate is useful for General
verification of reusable modules
including correctness of attribute names
and value types so here's an example
where I just had some code and there was
a problem it's just saying you're
missing your argument because for an AWS
instance you always have to specify an
instance type so when you run terraform
plan or terraform ply validate will
automatically be performed one thing I
need to mention about terraform validate
is that it does not go to external
resources to check things are valid so
if you have a a value and it's expecting
a string that's all it's going to check
for it's not going to check that the
string is actually a proper uh like type
of size so if it's supposed to be like a
t2.micro and you write you know
gobblegoop in there it's not going to
know that that's not a valid type so but
we do cover that in the follow along so
I think we have like some practice exam
questions that cover that use case okay
[Music]
we're taking a look here at terraform
console and this is an interactive shell
where you can evaluate expressions so
the idea is you type in terraform
console and what I can do is I can you
know use like built-in functions and
expressions so there I'm using Min and
I've actually entered it in incorrectly
so there it's throwing an error and here
I'm using the correct way of using it so
I get the output so this is a great way
just to kind of test very simple things
you can't do things like Define
variables or or resources or Define
providers but you if you need to figure
out how the Expressions work before you
apply them in your code this is a great
place to do that okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about terraform
plans so this command creates an
execution plan also known as a terraform
plan and it consists of reading the
current state of an already existing
remote object to make sure that the
terraform state is up to date comparing
the current configuration to the prior
State and noting any differences
proposing a set of change actions that
should if applied make the remote
objects match the configuration and so
this is an example of one that's
generated you're going to see it uh
throughout this course multiple times so
it's not going to be unique that's why I
don't have to make that too big for you
there terraform plan does not carry out
the proposed changes that's going to be
the responsibility of terraform apply
and a terraform plan file if you happen
to generate one out is a binary file so
if you open it up it's just machine code
you cannot make sense of it okay so when
you run terraform apply you have
speculative plans and save plans and so
speculative plan plans is what's going
to happen when you run terraform apply
so the tear so terraform will output the
description of the effect of the plan
but without any intent to actually apply
it when you have a save plan you're
going to have this hyphen out flag to
save it and you can name that file
whatever you like and it will generate
out that save plan file and again that's
a binary file so you're not going to be
able to see what it does and what you
can do is then pass it along to
terraform apply so you do terraform
apply whatever the file name is and when
you are using terraform apply what you
have to understand is that it will not
allow it will not ask to manually
approve it as you normally would it
would just be Auto approved so that's
one thing you have to watch out when
using those safe plans but you know I
just wanted to make it concretely
understood that terraform plan can
generate at a file uh and it's not
actually the one that's doing the apply
okay I don't have it written in here but
when you do terraform apply it also is
running terraform validate as well okay
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about terraform apply here so
terraform apply command executes the
actions proposed in an execution plan
and it has two modes the automatic plan
mode and the saved plan mode so for
automatic plan mode that's just when you
run terraform apply what it's going to
do is execute the plan validate and then
the apply uh you can or you have to
manually approve the plan by writing yes
but if you want to skip that process you
can use the hyphen Auto approve flag to
automatically approve the plan
we just saw save plan mode like how it
worked in the previous slide but let's
cover it again so when you provide a
file name to terraform to the save plan
file it's going to be terraform apply
file
and it's going to perform exactly the
steps specified by that plan file it
does not prompt for approval so if you
want to inspect a plan file before
applying it you can use terraform show
okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about managing
resource drift so drift or configuration
or infrastructure drift is when you're
expected uh resources are in different
state than your expected State and the
way we can resolve drift are in three
different ways in terraform we can
replace resources so when a resource has
become damaged or degraded that cannot
be detected by terraform we can use the
hyphen replace flag we can import
resources so when an approved manual
edition of a resource needs to be added
to our state file so we use the import
command and refresh state so when an
approved manual configuration of a
resource has been changed or removed
we're going to use the refresh only flag
to reflect the changes in our state file
it's very important to know these three
different ways they will all show up an
exam and in practice you're going to
need to know them okay
foreign
let's first here take a look at
replacing resources so we can use the
terraform tank command it is used to
Mark a resource for replacement the next
time you run apply and why would you
want to Mark a resource for replacement
well the idea is that um you know and
here's the command here but a cloud
resource becomes damaged or degraded and
you just want to return the expected
resource to a healthy state so that's
the idea behind it and the unfortunate
thing is that terraform taint was
deprecated in version
0.152 however there is a better way of
doing it now and so it is recommended to
use the hyphen replace flag and
providing it a resource address when
you're doing a terraform apply so it's
basically the exact same thing the
reason why they made this change was so
that
um you actually have an opportunity to
confirm your change beforehand because
terraform tank would just run and this
one down below will actually prompt you
to say are you sure you want to do this
okay but it's not complicated you just
do a hyphen replace and then you use the
resource address of the thing that you
want to
use that for and this can be used for
both plan and apply the replace flag
appears to only work for a single
resource so you can't use multiple
resources it's just one at a time and
that's something that you should
remember okay
[Music]
so we just saw a resource address and
resource addressing is very important to
know for the upcoming commands let's
just give it a bit more attention here
so resource address is a string that
identifies zero or more resource
instances in your configuration an
address is composed of two parts so the
module path and the resource path and
just expand out that module path it
would be module.module name module index
and then on the resource spec this is
resource type.resource name and then if
there's multiple instances you give it
an index so module path addresses a
module within a tree of modules a
resource spec address is a specific
resource instance in the selected module
so a module is the namespace of the
module module name is user defined name
of the module module index when the
multiple so when there's multiple
specifying index on the other side
that's your resource type your resource
name an instance ID most of the times
you're going to be just working with
resources but once you start getting to
modules it becomes pretty simple it's
always going to be module period because
that's just I think that's the name of
the name value so it's always going to
be module Dot and then the module name
but here we have a very simple example
just for resource type so here if we had
a resource called Abus instance and it
was web and there was four of them and
we wanted to select the third one we do
AWS instance dot web Square braces three
and that would get us the third virtual
machine so there you go
foreign
[Music]
terraform import and this is a command
that is used to import existing
resources into terraform so this is how
you define it so you'd say what resource
you want and you can just leave it blank
so do you define a placeholder for your
imported resource and configuration file
and you can leave the body blank and
fill it in after importing but it will
not be autofilled so you do have to
specify all the values okay so the idea
here is you're going to do terraform
import AWS instance dot example and then
the name of the ID so that Maps over to
the resource address and the ID okay the
command can only import one resource at
a time this sounds very similar to that
other command we saw for replace not all
resources are importable you need to
check the bottom of the resource
documentation for support okay
[Music]
okay so we're going to look at
refreshing and so we're going to break
this between the old command refresh and
the new command refresh only across two
slides so terraform refresh command
reads the current settings from all
managed remote objects and updates the
terraform state to match so here we have
the terraform refresh and I just want to
point out that the terraform refresh is
basically the Alias for terraform apply
hyphen refresh only hyphen Auto auto
approved so you technically have this
functionality in the latest version it's
just that you can't use the old Alias
terraform refresh terraform refresh will
not modify your real remote objects but
will modify the terraform state so
terraform refresh has been deprecated
and the refresh only uh and with the
refresh only flag like it's been
replaced with it because it's not safe
since it did not give you the
opportunity to review proposed changes
before updating the state file so that's
why the reason they got rid of it let's
take a look here at the refresh only
mode so hyphen refresh only flag for
terraform planner apply allows you to
refresh and update your state file
without making changes to your remote
infrastructure just to really make this
clear I want to give you a scenario and
I want you to pay close attention here
to understand the difference because
this is so important on the exam and
also extremely useful for your
day-to-day operations so here's a
scenario imagine you create a terraform
script that deploys a virtual machine to
AWS you ask an engineer to terminate the
server and instead of updating the
terraform script they mistakenly
terminate the server via the AWS console
because they don't know any better so
what happens if you were to run a
terraform apply versus with a refresh
only flag so that's what we'll do with
and without the flag so without the flag
first terraform will notice that the VM
is missing terraform will propose to
create a new VM so the state file is
going to be what's considered as correct
and the changes and so changes to the
infrastructure will be made to match the
state file okay if we use terraform
apply hyphen refresh only terraform will
notice that the vmu provision is missing
but with the refresh only flag it's
going to know that the that the VM is
missing it's an intentional okay so I
have a couple spelling mistakes there
but the idea is that it knows that the
VM is supposed to not be there so
terraform will propose to delete the VM
from the state file so just the Json
code from the state file so the state
file is considered wrong and changes to
the state file will be made to match the
infrastructure so hopefully that makes
it clear okay
[Music]
foreign
how we would actually go about
troubleshooting terraform so there are
four types of Errors you can encounter
with terraform uh the first is language
error so terraform encounters a syntax
error in your configuration for the
terraform or HCL language you have state
error so your resources States has
changed from the expected state in your
configuration file core errors so a bug
that has occurred with the chord Library
provider errors so the provider's API
has changed or does not work as expected
due to emerging edge cases and when we
talk about what's easy for us to solve
and what's hard well the first two are
very easy and the other two are harder
to solve so for language errors we can
use format validate or version to
resolve our language errors version
would just be say hey what version are
we using maybe we need to update it
right validate with detect if
something's wrong with
um the uh the the syntax and format
would fix formatting syntax but you know
that probably wouldn't fix that much
there for State errors the idea here is
we might want to use refresh apply
replace everything that we saw in the
drift section for core errors we might
want to go check out the log so TF
underscore log is basically just the way
of saying like hey these are where the
log files are or is logs turned on we
have a whole slide on that but really
like all you're going to do is use the
logs to find information and then report
a GitHub issue since all terraform is on
GitHub you just go there and then
somebody would try to resolve it and the
same thing with providers providers are
all hosted on GitHub and so you would
just use TF logs to try to find some
information there but we'll take a look
a greater look at TF log and how to you
know get that information for the harder
to solve cases okay
[Music]
okay so let's talk about how we would go
about debugging terraform via the log
file so terraform has detailed logs
which can be enabled by setting the TF
underscore log followed by the type
environment you want to run so the
variables that we have or the
environments we can specify is Trace
debug info warn error or Json Json will
output logs at the trace level or higher
and use parsable Json encoding as the
formatting okay so logging can be
enabled separately so you can do this
via TF log core or you can get it at the
TF log provider so if you just want core
stuff or if you just want provider stuff
you just set those environment variables
and as we saw in the previous thing that
there you know there was core errors and
provider variables so that could be a
good way to do that and so TF uh TF core
TF log core and TF log provider take the
same environment variables we see on the
right hand side there Trace debug info
Etc okay if you want to choose where you
want to log things you just can set the
TF log path I don't think I actually say
where the default path is I think it's
actually in the the project directory
but if you want to override that you can
I imagine it either takes an absolute
path or a relative path and here's an
example of a terraform log so this is
for everything and so there you can see
information I'm going to get my pen tool
out here for a moment but you can see we
have information about the provider this
is using
um there then there's some back-end
local stuff so you know there's some
information you're not expected to
understand this information generally
but you could go bring it to the
provider but you could probably solve
something you know if you were to read
the core code or the provider is okay
[Music]
okay so we looked at TF log which is the
terraform log but there's also a crash
log and so if terraform ever crashes and
basically this means it goes into panic
because it uses the go runtime it saves
a log file with the debug logs from the
session as well as the Panic message and
back Trace to the crash.log and so I
imagine this is golang information so I
don't use golang that often but you can
see we have dot gopanic.go so I think
that there's not much you can do with it
so this is where you would just create a
GitHub issue and pass it along to the
terraform team because they're going to
be able to make sense of it okay
[Music]
foreign
so we're on to our module section uh so
let's first talk about how we would go
find a module I know we already saw this
earlier when we were looking at the
terraform registry but let's just cover
it again and talk about some of the uh
uh details of search okay so terraform
modules can be publicly found in the
terraform registry and so on the left
hand side when you're under the modules
within terraform registry you can filter
your providers okay but another thing
you can do is you can type in Search
terms and you can do partial Search
terms like Azure compute but what I
really want you to know is that only
verified modules will be displayed in
Search terms and so I assume that means
verified and also official ones and the
reason I'm giving this extra emphasis is
because it was an exam question so I
just want you to know that only verified
and official ones are going to show up
when you search okay
foreign
let's talk about using modules and
there's our public modules and private
modules so public modules are going to
be on the terraform registry and private
modules are going to be in terraform
cloud or I suppose terraform Enterprise
so terraform registry is integrated
directly into terraform so it makes it
really easy to start using them so all
you're going to do is use the module
block so I'm just going to highlight
that there then we have the name of our
module we're providing the source of our
module and then there's the version of
our module terraform init command will
download and cache any module referenced
by a configuration now looking at
private modules it looks very similar
um it's just that the name is different
so we're specifying the host name in
front here and a namespace as well so to
configure private module axis you need
to authenticate against terraform Cloud
via terraform login so that's something
there we definitely cover that a lot in
the Brax exam so just in case you know
you know all the education is there
alternate alternatively you can create a
user API token and manually configure
credentials into CLI to configure the
file so there you go
foreign
let's talk about how we would go about
publishing modules and this in
particular is for the terraform registry
so these are public modules so if we
want to publish modules it supports
versioning automatically generating
documentation allowing uh users to
browse the version histories showing
examples and read Maze and all of these
modules are actually going to be hosted
on GitHub so the idea is you're going to
put your module there first and once a
module is registered to push updates you
simply push new versions to properly
form get tags you have to name the your
your modules in a very particular way on
GitHub so the thing is it has to start
with terraform hyphen then the provider
so AWS and then the name so hyphen VPC
and the way you publish it on terraform
registry is you have to connect and
publish via your GitHub account so you
just hit sign in with GitHub and it's
just going to give you a drop down and
you're just going to choose the repo and
that's as simple as it is okay
foreign
all right let's talk about verified
modules so these are reviewed by
hashicorp and actively maintained by
official contributors to stay up to date
and compatible with both terraform and
their respective providers so here's an
example of a module from our friend
Anton down below and as you can see it
has a little badge that's how you know
that it's verified so verified modules
are expected to be actively maintained
by hashicorp Partners verified badges
aren't an indication of the flexibility
or feature support but just to kind of
go through some things here very simple
modules can be verified just because
they're great examples of modules
unverified modules could be extremely
high quality and actively maintained
unverified modules shouldn't be assumed
to be poor quality unverified means it
hasn't been created by a hashicorp
partner so you know that again it's not
indicative of quality but it just means
that it's gone through a bit of vetting
okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
standard module structure and this is a
file and directory recommended for
module development and this is the idea
if you were to go and publish your own
module this is what people would expect
to see so if you had root modules that's
what it'd be and you have nested module
I want to point out that when you are
running terraform you technically are
creating modules even if you aren't
intending them to publish them into the
terraform registry but you know when you
make a main.tf you've basically made
your own root module okay so the primary
entry point is the root module and these
are required files in the root directory
so your main.tf is the entry point file
for your module variables TF is the
variables that can be passed in
outputs.tf are outputted values readme
describes how the modules work license
the license under which the module is
available for NASA modules which are
optional but must be contained in the
modules directory a sub module that
contains a readme is considered usable
by external users a sub module that does
not contain a readme is considered inter
for only internal use and the idea is to
avoid using relative paths when sourcing
module blocks so hopefully that gives
you an idea okay
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about core terraform
workflows and these have three steps
write plan and apply so write plan and
apply we saw this kind of in the
terraform life cycle and the idea here
is that you know it's just to try to
describe what it's going to be for your
team and requirements as you grow and
you're utilizing this workflow so if
you're talking about individual
practitioners so a single person a team
using OSS so they're not using they're
using open source software using
terraform but they're not using the
terraform Cloud platform and then what
it would be like if they're using the
terraform Cloud platform in terms of
this right plan apply you're going to
see these examples don't perfectly fit
here I am just presenting a summarized
versions of the documentation and the
reason why is because on the exam this
is one of the sub domains that you need
to know so I'm not saying that I think
these are perfectly presented but I
think that I have to cover them because
they are in the exam and I you do learn
something here so we will go through
them okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at a terraform or
team workflow for a single person an
individual practitioner looking at the
right step first so you're going to be
writing your terraform configuration in
your editor of choice on your computer
um but the thing is you'll be storing
your terraform code in something like
GitHub even if you are an individual
user you're going to be putting in git
or GitHub or some kind of Version
Control System you're going to be
repeatedly running terraform plan or
even possibly terraform validate to find
syntax errors and the great thing about
this is that you get this tight feedback
loop between editing the code and
running your test commands because it's
all on your local machine we're not
sending things off to build servers or
other services so it's very fast and
easy talking about the plan stage so
when the developer is confident with
their workflow in the right step that
commits their code to their local
repository this is the stage where it's
a local limit it's not a remote commit
they may be only using a single Branch
so just probably working in Maine or if
you're still using the old syntax Master
Branch once their commit is written
they'll proceed to apply that'll bring
us to the apply stage so they will run
terraform apply this is on your local
machine it's not part of any other
process you're just running terraform
apply and it'll be prompted to review
their plan after the review the final
review they will approve the changes and
await provisioning after a successful
provision they will push their local
commits to their remote repository so
this is where you will then finally
commit your code so there you go
[Music]
so we looked at what it would be like if
we had a single person working with
terraform let's talk about if it's a
team and they're not using terraform
Cloud they're just doing it uh the
old-fashioned way okay so each team
member writes code locally on their
machine in their editor of choice as per
usual a team member will store their
code in a branch in their code
repository whether it's a uh per feature
per user per whatever is up to you
branches help avoid conflicts while a
member is working on their code but
branches will allow an opportunity to
resolve conflicts during a merge into
main it's no different than working with
you know code because that's what it is
terraform plan can be used as a quick
feedback loop for small teams so we
still have that option but as your team
grows larger a concerned over sensitive
credentials becomes a concern and so
this is where you may need to introduce
a CI CD process so that it's it's going
to be in control of the credential so
the idea is that you don't run plan you
just push to your branch and it can run
it or it only happens on pull requests
that's up to you know your team and how
they decide to set it up when a branch
is ready to be incorporated on pull
requests an execution plan can be
generated I guess when we say execution
plan this could be a speculative plan
okay so it's not something we're going
to run it's just something we're going
to review and displayed within the pull
requests for review to apply the changes
the merges need to be approved and
merged which will kick off a code build
server that will run terraform apply
that's the apply stage there so this is
all good but what we need to kind of
highlight is all the work and labor that
goes into setting up your own team if
you're going to do it all from scratch
without terraform Cloud so the devops
team has to set up and maintain their
own CI CD pipeline they have to figure
out how to store the state files whether
they're going to be in a standard back
in a remote state or they're going to
encrypt it and put them into the code
repository which is not recommended they
are limited in their access controls so
they can't do granular actions to say
okay I only want to allow this person to
destroy and this person to apply it's
not like that with get repos they have
to figure out a way to safely store and
inject secrets into their build server's
runtime and that's not argue argue it's
not very hard depending on the solution
that you choose but it is a thing that
they have to figure out they might need
to manage multiple environments and this
can create additional overhead because
for each environment you'll have to
create another ciccd pipeline okay so
hopefully that gives you the idea of the
effort here and this is going to set us
up to say what terraform cloud is going
to solve okay
[Music]
let's take a look at what our team
workflow or our terraform workflow will
be if we were using terraform clouds so
18 we'll use terraform Cloud as a remote
back-end of course they were using uh
their favorite editor as per usual
working on their local machines to write
that code the input variables will be
stored on terraform Cloud instead of
their local machine terraform cloud
integrates with your version control
system such as git to quickly set up a
cicd pipeline a team member writes code
to a branch it commits per usual so that
doesn't change a pull request is created
by a team member in terraform Cloud will
generate the speculative or execution
plan however you want to call it for
review in your version control system
the member can also review and comment
on the plan in terraform Cloud after the
pull request is merged terraform cloud
in the terraform Cloud runtime sorry the
terraform Cloud runtime will perform a
terraform apply and a team member can
confirm and apply the changes within the
terraform Cloud UI okay so terraform
Cloud streamlines a lot of the CI CD
efforts storing it storing and securing
sensitive credentials and makes it
easier to go back and audit the history
of multiple runs so in terms of the exam
if and I didn't see any questions on
this but I know they exist they're just
going to be asking you
you know which like they might describe
something and say which kind of workflow
does this fit and so if you generally
know the difference between terraform
Cloud working with the team open source
software without terraform cloud and
individual workflow it's not too hard
you'll be okay all right
[Music]
foreign
we're taking a look here at back ends
and each terraform configuration can
specify a back end which defines where
and how operations are performed and
where State snapshots are stored so
terraform divides their backends into
two types we have standard and enhanced
first looking at standard this is where
you can only store the state and it does
not perform terraform operations such as
terraform apply so to perform operations
you have to use a CLI on your local
machine and the reason why is that
standard back ends are basically
third-party backends so a standard back
end could be AWS S3 and so you know this
is a storage service it doesn't have the
capabilities of pragmatically triggering
things okay
uh when we have when we're talking about
enhanced back ends we can store both the
state and perform terraform operations
so enhanced backends are subdivided
further so we have local so files and
data are stored in a local machine
executing terraform commands and remote
so files and data are stored in the
cloud so terraform Cloud the reason why
they can perform terraform operations
and when you look at local and remote
local is your machine so of course it
can execute terraform and then remote is
terraform Cloud which has its own
runtime environment it's basically a
build server so it of course can do both
those operations and that's how you're
going to remember the difference between
those two okay
[Music]
all right so we were just talking about
standard and enhanced back ends and I
was saying that standard back ends are
basically third-party providers that is
something other than terraform Cloud so
let's take a look at what options we
have available to us starting with the
major cloud service providers so AWS has
simple storage S3 Azure has block
storage account notice it says Azure RM
because that's just the name of what
they call it I don't know what the RM
stands for resource manager I imagine
Google Cloud Storage is an option then
we have Alibaba we have openstack we
have 10 cent and then we have Manta
which is part of joynet's cloud storage
so I don't think a lot of people are
going to remember joinet joynet was very
popular provider like post or pre-2010
so I remember them 10 cent is a Asia
provider I think they were a texting
service they're very popular but they're
not the largest provider over in Asia
Alibaba is and of course we have the the
three major ones here and then openstack
is for uh private Cloud okay then on the
other side of it when we're looking at
more exotic or things that aren't Cloud
server providers we have
um artifactory we have hashicorp console
etcd postgres database kubernetes
secrets and you can also use the ACP
protocol
now notice I have these little locks
here that's indicating which have state
locking which do not if you don't know
what state locking is don't worry we'll
talk about it here in a moment
um would there be a question on the exam
saying oh which service you know doesn't
have state locking and the answer is no
they would never ask that it's too
minute but just notice that the only
thing that doesn't have state locking is
uh artifactory which I'm kind of
surprised because it's a universal
repository manager and there's the one
case like with HP protocol where it's
optional so it's not that you can't have
it it's just that it's not it doesn't
necessarily have to be there and in
particular some the the state is or the
Locking State locking is
buy another service so for AWS it's
dynamodb that is doing the state locking
and then with Alibaba uh alibaba's cloud
storage it's table store okay so uh you
know there's not much to know here but
uh you know it's just kind of
interesting if you want to have a
different kind of backend maybe you want
to use postgres because you're really
familiar with it you can actually store
it there okay so let's take a look at
what it would look like if we were to
use a standard back end so here's an
example for AWS since I think S3 is very
popular so if you were to set up your
back end so here I have a bucket here
and I've have to name the state file so
I call it State file and then I give it
the region and there it is so the backup
of a state file will reside on your
local machine so the backup's not going
to be an S3 configuring a standard back
end does not require terraform cloud
account or workspace because
you know it's it's totally separate from
it so that's something I wasn't sure
when I was first using it was okay can I
use a standard back end but I still have
to have a terraform account or workspace
and the answer is no all right
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look at
enhanced back end so we're going to
start with local and then move on to
remote so for the local back end we
store the state on the local file system
and it locks the state using the systems
API it also performs operations locally
and when we say local we just mean a
local machine we don't necessarily mean
it has to be our workstation a code
build server could also be considered a
local machine okay it just means
anything but terraform Cloud that is
running the terraform code so by default
you are using the backend State when you
have not specified any kind of back end
so normally you'd see a background
defined in here we don't so it's going
to just default to the local you can
specify the back end with an argument
local most people don't you just leave
it blank and you can change the path to
the local file
a working directory so I think that if
you were to specify you'd want to put
the path
in but generally again we keep that
blank you can set a back end to
reference another state files so you can
read it outputted values this is a way
of cross-referencing stacks so just
notice that we have this thing that says
terraform remote State we're going to
repeat this later on in the course
because this is a very important concept
and I feel that it gets overlooked in
the documentation but it has to do with
local backends so the idea is that you
could say hey I have this other file
that has a back end and I'm just going
to use data sources specify its backend
and then point to its actual terraform
State file okay
foreign
[Music]
we're taking a look here at remote back
ends for the enhanced back-end type and
a remote back end uses the terraform
platform which is either terraform cloud
or terraform Enterprise
by default I usually just say terraform
Cloud when I'm referring to the
terraform platform but just to
understand there is a distinction
between terraform cloud and terraform
enterprise Enterprise being the
on-premise
offering okay so with a remote back end
when terraform apply is performed via
the CLI the terraform Cloud run
environment is responsible for executing
the operation so that's what you get
when you get terraform cloud is you get
this run environment so it's basically
just a built-in code build server to run
terraform commands for you one thing I
really want you to know about remote
back-ends because this really tripped me
up uh when I was actually trying to make
the follow along which is the fact that
because the terraform Cloud run
environment is the one exiting the
command your provider credentials need
to be configured in the environment
variables in terraform Cloud so you know
if you had a project and you configured
it with um TF bars locally and then you
were to swap out your remote backend
it's not going to work the way you
expect it to because
um again the terraform Cloud run
environment is not going to take your
credentials and then move them to the
cloud okay you have to do that yourself
when using a remote backing you need to
set a terraform Cloud workspace
so you would go ahead and go to
terraform cloud and just go create one
you create one or multiple ones for a
single project if you use a single
workspace for a project you're just
going to use the workspaces uh name and
if you set multiple workspaces via
prefet you can use a prefix okay and the
way this prefix works is that you're
going to say like my app or something
and when you go to run terraform apply
what it's going to do is prompt you to
say which environment do you want to use
so and this is what you've created in
your terraform Cloud workspace you've
created one called Dev you've created
one called Product saying which
workspace do you want to deploy to I
want to know that you can only set
either name or prefix you can't set both
okay so just understand that
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look at the
cloud backend
um uh code block here and so this is
very similar to terraform backend remote
if we're specifying terraform as our
back end but now instead of having to do
backend remote we can just give it a
cloud block and the reason for this is
well I don't know you can still
foreign
all right let's take a look at the cloud
backend block so when using terraform
Cloud as a remote back-end State you
should instead use the cloud block to
configure its usage so uh previously in
previous uh terraform versions it would
look like this so you'd have terraform
back and remote and the way you know
it'd be using terraform cloud is that
the hostname would be set as app.t
terraform.io and so this has been
changed so now that all you have to do
is use this Cloud block and so you just
don't specify that hostname and for the
most part
um uh you know the configurations
between them are very similar so the
only thing that we're seeing different
is this prefix maybe that prefix is
still there we'd have to double check
the documentation on that but what's
important to understand is that there's
this Cloud block and it is the record
amended way to do it now I do want to
point out that I tested both and the
remote the remote version still works so
you can still do it this way if you're
doing it the old school way and this is
just an alternate way uh would they ever
make it so you could not use the remote
state in the future for uh terraform
Cloud you have to use the block I don't
know but I can tell you right now that
they do have that cloud block
so both are valid options and the latter
of course being the recommended uh use
one so yeah there you go
thank you
[Music]
so since we're talking about back ends
let's talk about back-end initialization
in particular the back end hyphen config
flag this is more of an exotic option
but I figured we should go over it
because it could appear on your exam so
the flag for the back end config flag
for terraform init can be used for
partial back-end configuration so in
situations where the back-end settings
are dynamic or sensitive so they cannot
be statically specified in your
configuration file this is what you
would do
so here would be your main.tf and notice
it says back in remote
and it has no details in it
so then what you do is you create a
separate file called backend.hcl and now
you're specifying the workspace the host
name the organization and then uh with
terraform and net you're going to then
say Okay use this file as the backend
information that we're going to inject
into our backend remote so there you go
[Music]
okay we're taking a look here at
terraform remote State and I give this a
lot more attention in the course because
I feel that it gets overlooked within
the terraform documentation it's such a
powerful feature and something that I'm
used to having in cloudformation which
is cross-referencing Stacks so I want to
make sure that you know it too so
terraform remote State data source
retrieves the root module output values
from another terraform configuration
file using the latest State Snapshot
from the remote back end so the idea is
that you can reference a state file from
somewhere else you can do it uh via a
remote backend and a local backend so
just take a look here we see data and
the data sources terraform remote State
and we're setting the back end as a
remote on the right hand side here it is
local and if it's a local back end we
give the path to the TF State file if
it's remote that means it's another
workspace and terraform Cloud so we set
the workspace that we want to access and
then when we want to access those
resources we're using data sources so we
do data Dot and it's terraform remote
State and then we specify it knows that
it's no difference whether it's remote
or local but you're going to be getting
datas from outputs okay so only the root
level output values from the remote
State snapshots are exposed resource
data and output values from nested
modules are not accessible to make
module outputs values accessible as a
root module output values you must
explicitly configure a pass-through in
the root module so here's an example of
us doing a pass-through so we have a
module called app and it has a source
and then we're just setting an output
notice that we are just grabbing the
value and passing it along
I want to tell you about the alternative
to terraform remote State because if you
can you should use these as opposed to
using terraform Road States so terraform
remote state only exposes output values
its users must have access to the entire
State snapshot which often includes some
sensitive information it's recommended
explicitly uh it it's recommended to
explicitly publishing data for external
consumption to a separate location
instead of accessing it via a remote
state so what would be Alternatives well
you've seen this because when we looked
at data sources we were technically
we're using Alternatives but the idea is
that you are going to say AWS S3 bucket
AWS rep 53 zones and these are kind of
already set up to work with AWS or
whichever provider okay so that's that
there
but uh yeah hopefully that's pretty
clear so the idea is that when you can
use these data sources because you know
they're actually working off of live
data right like it's hitting a resource
it's not just looking at a state file
that contains data okay
[Music]
so we had mentioned State locking just
briefly when we were looking at standard
back ends but let's go take a look in
detail what these are because they're
very important for your workflows so
terraform will lock your state for all
operations that could write State this
prevents others from acquiring the lock
and potentially corrupting your state so
State locking happens automatically on
all operations that could write State
you won't see any message that it's
happening if the state locking fails all
right so terraform does not output when
a lock is complete however if acquiring
the lock is taking longer than expected
terraform will output a status message
so neither on failure and neither when
it is complete just if it takes too long
so there's a transient issue something
with like a networking issue you can
disable lock so what you do is use the
hyphen lock flag but it's generally not
recommended you can force and unlock
there's cases where uh you know just
does not unlock or add so what you'll
have to do is use the force unlock
camera and if you unlock the state when
someone else is holding the lock it
could cause multiple writers Force
unlock should only be used to unlock
your own lock in the situation where
automatic unlocked failed to protect you
the force unlock command requires a
unique lock ID so terraform will output
this lock ID if unlocking fails so this
is what it would look like so we have
terraform Force unlock and then whatever
the ID is hyphen Force so yeah there's a
lot going on here but yeah that's what
it is
[Music]
all right so let's talk about protecting
sensitive data so terraform State file
can contain sensitive data so long-lived
database credentials and is possible
attack Vector for malicious actors and
so when you're dealing with the local
state when you're using local backend
the state is stored in plain text Json
files you need to be careful you do not
share the state file with anyone you
need to be careful you do not commit
this file to your git repository when
you're using a remote state with
terraform Cloud the idea here is the
save file is held in memory and is not
persisted to disk the state file is
encrypted at rest the state file is
encrypted in transit with terraform
Enterprise you have detailed audit
logging for tampering evidence to take
it one step further so you can just see
that there's a lot of work that has to
be done when you are using it locally
but with terraform Cloud this is kind of
the cell for terraform cloud is that
it's just going to do everything
possible to make that secure would it be
secure to use a remote say with a
third-party storage let's talk about
that so you can store state with a
various third-party back-ends but you
need to be careful to review your
backend's capabilities determine if you
meet your security and compliance
requirements some back-ends are not by
default as secure as they could be so
for example AWS S3 you could have you
have to ensure encryption and versioning
is turned on and you need to create a
custom Trail for data events so you can
get
tamper evidence logging if you turn on
data events for custom cloud trail
events but one thing that if it's
important to you is that you know if you
use S3 it's not held in memory you know
that'd be using a cloud HSM or KMS so
you know you have to understand there
are some trade-offs okay
[Music]
let's take a quick look here at
terraform ignore files and if you know
what git ignore files it's pretty much
the same thing so when executing a
remote plan or apply in a CLI driven run
an archive of your configuration
directory is uploaded to terraform cloud
and so you could Define paths to ignore
from upload via the dot terraform ignore
file at the root of your configuration
directory if this file is not present
the archive will exclude the following
by default so dot get dot terraform and
Dot terraforming Nora works just like a
DOT get ignore with the only difference
is that you cannot have multiple dot
terraform ignore files in subdirectories
only the file in the root directory will
be read so there you go and yes I know
there's a double the okay so don't worry
about that
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about resources so resources
in configuration files represent
infrastructure objects such as virtual
machines databases virtual Network
components and storage and so it pretty
much looks like this a resource type is
determines the kind of infrastructure
object it is so here it says AWS
instance and this would represent an AC
AWS ec2 instance this is all defined
within the providers documentation so
you have to kind of look at what name
they use to figure out what it is and
even though you don't see provider
explicitly set here a resource does
belong to a provider and you can
explicitly set it and you would do this
when you'd want to set a resource
outside the default provider that you
have in your configuration file and so
one little thing that I hadn't mentioned
anywhere else and that's why I made this
slide was to mention about special
timeout nested blocks within resources
so some resource types provide a special
time on asset block argument that allows
you to customize how long certain
operations are allowed to take before
being considered to have failed okay so
there you go
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about complex types so a
complex type is a type that groups
multiple values into a single value and
complex types are represented by type
Constructors but several of them are
have shorthand keyword versions okay so
there are two categories of complex
types we have collection types for
grouping similar values so list map set
and structural types for grouping
potentially to similar values so Tuple
an object and it's now that we have an
overview let's go jump into collection
types and structural types
[Music]
a collection type allows multiple values
of one other type to be grouped together
as a single value and the type of value
within a collection is called its
element type the three kinds of
collection types are list map and set
and so looking at our first one here
what we're doing is we are setting
ourselves something that looks kind of
like an array and it's these list type
here and what we can do is use our index
so the indices 0 to reference the first
element which is Mars so that's going to
make our username Mars for a map it's
very similar to a ruby hash or
singleness to Json object and the idea
here is that it's very similar to the
first except now we're doing a key and
value and then we access it by based on
the key name so plan B is going to
return 50 USD okay
we have set it is similar to a list but
has no secondary index or preserved
ordering
all values must be of the same type and
will be cast to match the first element
okay so it's a great way to kind of have
um well I guess no secondary index but
yeah so you do two set and then it would
turn into this okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
structural type so a structural type
allows multiple values of several
distinct types to be grouped together
with a single value structural types
require a schema as an argument to
specify which types are allowed for
which elements so this is what they're
talking about when they say this schema
so when you actually Define the variable
notice where it says object and you are
actually setting a is going to be a
string and B is going to be a string
there's this optional option which I
think is right now in beta but hopefully
by the time this course is out or it's
the future you have that option there
but just assume that they're all
required so that's what they're talking
about is that you are specifying exactly
what you expect the schema to be okay so
there are two kinds of structural types
we have objects and tuples and they're
going to look very familiar to maps and
lists because they're pretty much the
same but with explicit typing so object
is a map with more explicit keying so
this example we'd have name for string
age for number and so that's what it
would expect the data structure to be
for Tuple multiple return types with a
parameter so we can have string number
or Boolean so so this is where we'd have
a as a string 15 or true as a Boolean so
you know there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're going to look at the
collection and structural type so I have
a new folder down below just in case we
need to Define some things so I'm going
to go here and just call this main.tf
and we are just going to configure this
for a local terraforms we'll just give
the brackets there and so the idea is
that we might have different kinds of
variables
and we had done this previously where we
created a list and a map but we can do
that again so we'll have like planet
right
so that's list and then we just default
that to a value Mars
Earth
Moon
and then we could also have you know
plans here and that would be our map
type
okay and so here we'll just set it
the curlies
plan A
Plan B
plan C
um
so we'll do terraform console and so
that should load these variables for us
to use
and so if I do var.plans
I get that and if I do VAR dot planets
uh didn't like what I did there input
variable has not been declared
I suppose just plan it there so I should
have named that planets up here
and so what we're going to do here is
just go ahead and exit
type clear
I'm just going to expand this a bit
bigger so we're taking over more of the
screen and let's take a look at
structural types so these require you to
actually Define
um
parameters so what I'm going to do is go
down below and we're going to do the
object
and object is very similar to the map so
let's go down here
plans object
and so here what we do is we'd say type
object
and we would just have to Define some
settings here
um
so we could say
a is a string
all right we'll see if that works
the default value is now compatible with
the variable type constraint attribute a
is required
so that's fine what we could do is just
Define this as like plan A
Plan B
plan C
and now if we just do VAR plans object
when you are using this you know you
might want to specify some different
kinds here so you could just say like
you say like plan here
as soon as they plan name
plan amount
maybe it's like number
and so then we'd say plan name
plan amount
basic
maybe this will be 10.
okay and we'll just uh
type exit here and go back into
terraform Cloud hopefully we don't get
an error here so the plan amount is
required so you know we can't have a
spelling mistake here
just do VAR plan here
um
well we named it correctly there and
when we went up here and specified it I
think we got it right plan object
so
tripler doesn't like here oh you know
what we're not in terraform Cloud okay
that's fair
and we're still spelling this wrong
oops
okay so there we go we get our basic
plan
um and then we could do a tuple here so
I don't know if I've ever defined a
tuple before so let's just try it here
and so we'll just say uh
groceries or value or random
type equals Tuple
I'm just looking up if there's any kind
of definition I can find here
I'm not really finding anything but I'm
just going to go Define this here
because I thought maybe it needed like a
schema or something but maybe it doesn't
so we'll just say
hello 22
false okay
terraform console
dribble Constructor requires one
argument specifying the element types as
a list
okay so if that's the case then what we
could do is say string
number
Boolean
the type Constructor requires one
argument specifying the number of
elements so clearly I'm doing this wrong
so just give me a second I'll be back in
a moment okay all right so I think the
problem here was just that I need to
make brackets here like this
we'll give that a go
boolean's not a valid option what if we
try Bool
okay we say VAR dot random
good and so I'll just go ahead and exit
that out I'm just going to see what
happens if I change the order here so
let's say I do instead of 22 here
we go here
okay so notice that you know we can have
all sorts of Kinds but they have to
match exactly the order that is there so
yeah that's pretty much it so there you
go
[Music]
the terraform language includes a number
of built-in functions that you can call
from within Expressions to transform
your combined values so we have numeric
string collection encoding file system
date and time hash encrypto ipnetwork
type conversions so we are going to go
through all of these we might not go
through every single function but we'll
go through every single major category
in terms of the exam the only thing
that's going to show up might be string
functions why they do this I don't know
it's not a very good exam question but
those might appear but I think that this
is one of the strongest features of
terraform over something like cloud
formation and I really want to just show
you the Gambit of them okay
foreign
[Music]
let's take a look here at numeric
functions starting with absolute so
Returns the absolute value of the given
number so 23 is 23 0 is 0 and if you get
a negative number it's going to flip to
the positive for 4. what it does is it
rounds down to the nearest whole number
so see where it says 4.9 becomes a 4.
you have logs so it Returns the
logarithmetic I can't say that word
logarithm logarithm of a given number in
a given base so log 50 comma 10 is going
to give you that 16 comma 2 is going to
give you 4 okay seal it it's where it
will always round up so see where it
says 5.1 and it goes all the way to 6.
we have Min so take one or more numbers
and return the smallest number from the
set and Max take one or more numbers and
return the greatest number of the set I
don't have examples because that's
pretty straightforward you know if
there's a two and a four it's going to
return the two in Min if it's a two and
a four it's going to return the four for
Max we have parse n so parse is the
given string as a representation of an
integer in the specified base and
Returns the resulting number so if we
have a hundred here in strings it's
going to and we say comma 10 we're going
to get 100 because that's the base
system it's base system 10 base system
16 we can see letters in there right so
it's able to translate that this is two
so that's basically binary so zeros and
ones so you get the idea there
uh pow so calculates an exponent by
raising its first argument to the power
of the second argument so that's just
the way of doing powers and then we have
Signum so determine the sign of a number
returning a number between negative one
and one to represent the sign so there
you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
string functions the first being chop so
removes new line characters at the end
of a string so you know if there's a
hyphen n or sorry backslash n you don't
want to see that there that's the way
you get rid of it then you have formats
it produces a string by formatting a
number of other values according to the
specification so here there are
percentage Delights so this is
representing a a digit so it's taking
that number this says it's going to be
formatted as a string okay
format list so produce a list of strings
by formatting a number of other values
according to a specification string so
here we have an array and then we have
our specification so you can see it's
substituting the name there
um we'll look at indents so adds a given
number of spaces to the beginnings of
all but the first line in a given
multi-string so here we have a string
and what it's going to do is see where
we have the interpolation here and then
we have indent I know the the
highlighting is not great because it's a
single string but we have interpolation
we have parentheses two so give it a a
layer of two indentation and then it's
going to break that up and give it
indentation so we have join so produce a
string by concatenating together all
elements of a given list of strings with
a given deliminator so use delimiters is
double click or sorry it's a comma and
so it's going to glue that together to
make this okay
if there's only a single one there just
won't be any comma in there we can lower
all the text it's pretty straightforward
we have regular Expressions so that is
an extremely powerful feature so here we
have the regex I don't know what the
regex format is uh maybe it's Pearl I'm
not sure there's like a bunch of
different types of regex Standards so
you know do you have to figure that out
so you know how to use it and then
there's a regex all so applies to a
regular expression to a string and
returns a list of notches where this
just is returning uh one okay
We have replaced so search is a given
string for another given substring and
replaces each occurrence within a given
replacement string this is just like the
JavaScript replace we have split this is
the opposite of join so if we want to
split on the comma we specify comma here
we have Str rev so string reverse so
reverse is a string so hello becomes Ole
we have sub ol
sure I don't know
um so substring so extracts a substring
from a given string by offset and and
length so we have a substring and we're
saying we want one to four so we only
want one two three four here okay
because it starts at zero we have title
so make a title okay so capitalize the H
and the w we have trim removes the
specified character from the start and
end of the string so we don't want these
and we tell it to remove those
there's a lot of string functions uh so
we have trim prefix so it removes the
specified prefix from the start of the
given string if the string does not
start with the prefix the string is is
returned and unchanged so here we say we
want to get rid of hello in the front so
we do that suffix is the opposite so we
want to get a rid of world out of the
suffix so we do that we have trim space
so removes all types of white space from
both the start and end of the line so it
gets rid of the new lines and the spaces
upper is going to put everything to
Upper and there you go on the exam they
probably will ask you uh like what
string function does or which one does
not do something so this is the only
part of the built-in functions you have
to know for the exam I don't think it's
a very good exam question but it does
appear there so you need to know it okay
foreign
[Music]
functions and these are the most
powerful built-in functions and there's
a lot of them and I made sure to give
you an example for each one because I
really do want you to know these because
this is the power of terraform the First
on our list here is altru's returns true
if all elements in a given collection
are true are true or it also returns
true if the collection is empty so it's
either true true right or we have true
false so because there's a false it's
not going to be true so any true is very
similar but there only has to be one
that is true so if this is true and
there's a false that's going to be true
if it's blank it's going to be false
okay
we have chunkless splits a string list
into fixed size chunks returning a list
of lists so here we're telling it to
chunk it every two so grab every two and
make them into their own little array or
list I suppose we have coalesce takes
any number of arguments Returns the
first one that isn't null or empty
string if you're used to postgres you
use this all the time but the idea is
it's going to grab the a in this case
it'll grab the B because that's blank in
this case we'll grab the one because
that's the first value we have coalesce
list takes any number of list arguments
and Returns the first one that isn't
empty so very similar it's just using
lists or if we want to call them array
so the first one is available so it
takes that one we have compact so it
takes a list of strings and returns a a
new list with an empty string elements
removed so it's just going to get rid of
that space there and we'll get ABC
we have concat so it takes two or more
lists and combines them into a single
list so that's very convenient we have
contain so determines whether a given
list or set contains a given single
value as one of its elements so does it
have an A yes it does does it have a d
no it does not we have distinct so takes
a list and returns a new list with any
duplicate elements removed so we just
want to make sure we only have one of
each so do we have any duplicates here
we have two a's and two B's so we're
going to end up with just a single list
so only exactly one of each letter
we have elements retrieves a single
element from a list so get me the
element at uh at three here so
um wait retrieves a single element from
a list
okay well that's what it does you give
it a three and it gives you an a I don't
know why it's not clicking for me but I
I'm not following through here index
finds the element index for a given
value in a list so we say where is B and
the index of B is is one because it'd be
zero and this would be one still really
confused about this one
flatten takes a list and replaces any
elements that are are lists with a
flattened sequence of list content so
basically it says give me a bunch of
eraser let's turn into one flat list
uh Keys take a map and return a list
containing the keys from the map so we
just want the keys a c and d
we want length this is pretty
straightforward so what's the length of
this zero this is two this is one
because it's a one uh mapper one thing
key value in there and if it's a string
it's going to count the characters so
there's five characters
we have lookup so retrieves the value of
a single element from a map
given its key if the given key does not
exist the given default value is
returned instead
so we say look up a and what we get is a
y right look up C and it could not find
C so by default give us what instead
key a match Keys construct a new list by
taking a subset of elements from one
list whose indexes match the
corresponding indexes of values in
another list
that sounds complicated let's read that
one more time so constructs a new list
by taking a subset of elements from one
list who indexes match the corresponding
index of values in another list that is
confusing so we have one less than
another one so we have this one here
and we have us West Us East USD so we
say okay we have uses so the elements
here is two and three so give us two and
three so that's what it does
that was a that was a tricky I can't
think of what you use that for but
that's a interesting function merge
takes an arbitrary number of maps or
objects and returns a single map or
object that contains a merged set of
elements from all arguments
so it just merges them together so it's
just like concat
or I suppose like flatten uh one takes a
list set or Tuple values from with
either zero or one element if the
collection is empty one returns null
otherwise one Returns the first element
if there are two or more elements then
one will uh one will return an error so
it returns null on an empty List It
Returns the first one and then here it
says invalid function so it's just
saying is there one right is it one or
zero ranges generates a list of numbers
using a start value a limit value and a
step value so we say three and we get 0
1 and 2.
during its a list of numbers using a
start value limit value and a step value
okay
uh reverse so takes a sequence and
produces
res oh not reverse Reserve sorry Reserve
takes a sequence and produces a number
induced sequence of the same length with
all the same elements as the given
sequence but in reverse order oh it is
reverse r e reverse I guess I spelled it
wrong here sorry reverse one two three
three two one just notice this is a
spelling mistake okay
uh set intersection so function takes
multiple sets and produces a single set
containing only the elements that all of
the given sets have in common in other
words it computes the intersection of
the sets well it's tiring so from what I
can tell it's like they all have B so
give us B right
set product functions find all the
possible combinations of elements from
all of the given sets by Computing the
cardistarian product we're really
getting into math here so we got app one
and app2
and so we got uh development develop
okay so this continues on so it's going
to say give me app one with development
give me uh app two with development then
Apple Mustang and then app2 with staging
and etc etc because that's why I put the
three dots there set subtract function
returns a new set containing the
elements from the a from the first set
that are not present in the second set
in other words it computes the relative
complement of the first set in the
second set
uh it lost me there but it says set
subtract so here I see a B and C A and C
minus it you get B okay
set Union function takes multiple sets
and produces a single set containing the
elements from all the given sets in
other words it computes the union of the
sets so it says set Union so we have
a b b c and d and in the results we get
d b c a so I guess
um single set containing the elements
from all the given so yeah yeah I guess
it's just we get unique ones across the
sets uh we have slice and notice like
we're going through all these things
it's like you probably won't use these
more exotic ones so it's not a big deal
if we don't nail them here but it's
important that we go through these so
that you know you just know all the
options are here so slice extract some
constructive consecutive elements from
within a list so here we are saying one
and three so we have B and C that's
where they start index one
um and then extract some consecutive
elements from within a list one comma
three
okay
sort takes a list of strings and returns
a new list with those strings sorted
lexicographically so we have e d a and x
and so now they're alphabetical so a d e
and X
well I think this is the last one uh
some takes a list of set numbers and
Returns the sum of those values that's
pretty straightforward add them all up
transpose take a map of list of strings
and swap the key and values to produce a
new map a list of strings so kind of
like inverts it values takes a map and
returns a list containing the values of
the map so we saw this earlier we got
the keys this is where we just want to
get the values zip map so construct a
map from a list of keys and a
corresponding list of values so we have
a b one two and this turns it into a
equal one b equals two I think I saw
this on the exam so that one you might
want to remember but yeah that's
collection functions as you can imagine
they're extremely powerful but they can
also be really confusing so maybe just
use them a little bit when you need to
okay
[Music]
we're taking a look here at encoding and
decoding functions so functions that
will encode and decode for various
formats so imagine we need to encode
into base64 so we do hello world or
imagine we give that encoded string and
we want to decode it back to hello world
that's what we can do so there's a lot
of different encoding decoding functions
most of them are the same they're just
kind of variants so we're not going to
go through every single one but I'll
list them out so you know what they are
so we have base64 encode Json encode
text and code base64 yaml encode base64
gzip URL encode base64 decode CSV decode
Json decode text decode base64 yaml
decode and just notice that you know
these aren't one to one so there is one
for this we have one for here uh we have
one for yaml
uh this is unique this is unique this is
unique okay just so you can tell for
your own code I think this one's a very
common one that you'll use but the idea
is that let's say you have hello world
you want to replace that string with a
uh whatever friendly for a URL right so
it just encodes it okay it's very useful
when you're making URL links so there
you go
[Music]
we're taking a look here at file system
functions so this has everything to do
with the file system so the first is
absolute path so the idea is you give it
something that's relative and it's going
to give you something absolute directory
name so this is a string containing a
file system path and removes the last
portion from it so we don't need the
file name so we just remove that off of
there we have path expand so takes a
fossils and path that might begin with a
tilde and expands it into its absolute
path so this would be like for home okay
um base name so it takes a string
containing a file system path and it's
basically the opposite of directory name
we just want the file here okay
onto the next page here this file will
read the contents of the file pretty
straightforward we can check if a file
exists so we just do file exists here we
have file set so it enumerates a set of
regular file names given a path and
pattern file base64 so it reads the
contents of a file at a given path and
Returns the basics before encoding that
might be good for images template file
so reads the file at a given path and
returns its content as a template using
a supplied set of template variables so
that's really useful if you want to do
some kind of templating
uh and just notice it's a two-step
process so this is the template file the
actual file itself and then we load it
here it's called a DOT TPL so there you
go
[Music]
we're taking a look at date and time
functions the first is format date so
the idea is that we provide a format
that we want and then we give it a
timestamp that is in the RFC 3339 format
and we get a variety of different
um formats out there we can add time so
again it's going to be that RFC 3339
format and we say add 10 minutes add one
hour then we have timestamp so you it
returns a UTC timestamp string in the
RFC 3239 format so you just say
timestamp it's I guess it would get
right now and then you get it in that
format okay
[Music]
let's take a look at hash and crypto
functions so generates hashes and
cryptographic strings so the most
popular one out there would probably be
B so here we just say hello world
and we're going to get this thing here
understand that a hash cannot be
reversed so once it is turned uh into uh
you know this format the only way you're
going to be able to confirm the contents
of it is to Hash something that is
similar and then compare it against it
okay so we have base64 Shaw 256 we have
512 we got B Crypt we have file Bay 64
Shaw 256 file based 64 Shaw 512 file md5
file Shaha one file Shaw 56 file Shaw
512 md5 RSA decrypt sha-1 Shaw to V6
Shaw 512 uuid uid V5 so I only showed
the one because you know it gets kind of
boring to go through all these and
really it's just going to be based on
your use case what you're going to be
using on a day-to-day basis is probably
bcrypt md5 and you uids so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at IP network
functions these are the coolest
functions I think that are built into
terraform so we have cider host so what
we can do is give ourselves a
a address and then we can give it a
subnet Mass size and we'll get back an
IP address and so you can see we have
this both in the ipv4 and the IPv6 we
have cider net mask so here we are doing
cidernet math so we just say forward
slash 12 and it's going to translate it
into the full ipv4 then we have cider
subnet so this is just where we say Okay
I want a subnet of a particular size so
we say 172 1600 comma 4 2 and look it's
going to give us 18 0 back doesn't make
sense that's okay I mean networking is
really hard but I just want you to know
that these functions are here for you
okay cider subnet calculates a sequence
of consecutive IP addresses within a
particular cider prefix so 4484 and then
you get those sizes there okay
[Music]
all right we're on to type conversion
function so the first we're looking at
is can so can evaluates the given
expression and returns a billion value
indicating whether the expression
produced a result without any error so
can we use this right so we say
local.food.bar and so you know if if
this Foo wasn't defined then it would
say false but apparently we've made it
all the way to borrow okay
we have defaults a specialized function
intended for use with input variables
whose type constraints are object types
or collection of object types that
include optional attributes and I don't
show that one here because it's not that
exciting but non-sensitive takes a
sensitive value and returns a copy of
that value with the sensitive markings
removed therefore exposing the sensitive
values so if we have an output here and
we want to make it non-sensitive that's
what we could do then sensitive as you
imagine is just the opposite okay
we have two Bool so converts its
arguments to a Boolean value so if we
have a string that's true we can turn it
into a real Boolean value we have to map
converts an argument to a map value to
set converts it to a set to list
converts it to a list to number converts
it to a number string to string and then
we last we have is try so evaluates all
of its arguments expressions in turn and
Returns the result of the first one that
does not produce any errors the thing
that's the hardest to figure out is set
I cannot find really good examples or
documentation on the use case of set
there are some cases where you need to
use sets which is an actual type but
even talking to DA's and
technical writers they weren't even sure
themselves so this is not something
you're going to come across very often
but
there's like one case where I saw it so
I'll probably point that out when we do
hit it okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are going to go take a look at um
built-in functions as soon as my
terminal decides to be responsive I
don't know why as soon as I start
recording it decides to lock up so we'll
just give it a moment there there we go
and so I have a new folder there I
figured we could just find some
variables so that we don't have to uh
you know constantly write stuff in so
we'll just say main.tf
we're going to go terraform here
and so might be fun to you know kind of
some kind of variable here and so I have
off screen here all the functions so
we're just going to kind of pick some at
random here to play around with so we
get some experience okay
so just going through strings
I think what we can do is Define like
our strings so we just say Str here
and we'll just say type equals string
and we'll just say default here able to
say hello
world
forward slash n
something like that
okay
and then we'll do terraform console here
I gotta remember to do it this way
so we do var.str
okay and so that accesses our string
there
maybe we might want to take out the new
line for now
so I'm just going to kind of pull this
up over here
look at some kind of things we can do
okay maybe collapse that get that out of
the way all right so there's a lot of
string functions and on the exam they
might actually ask you some which is in
my opinion I don't I don't really like
that but that's what they do
and so you know we might want to look at
something like split or something so
here we could do
hello world
okay
start that up again
so we'll do split
comma
VAR Str okay and that would split that
into a list
we might want to do something
like upper so I think we did that
earlier where we did upper
okay
you might want to do trim remove specify
characters from the start and end of the
string so maybe we have this here
and so we'll say trim
VAR Str
and whoops
it's not what I wanted to do
trim far Str
UCT like that okay
and there's again there's not a lot
that's exciting here maybe we'll try a
replace so we can do replace
and we'll we want to replace we won't
provide our string
and then the substring that we're
looking for so world
replace that with bar soon which is Mars
there we go
so nothing super exciting over there
what's more interesting are some things
like these hash encryptos
so something we might want to generate
out is a uuid I think that we might be
able to do this here so let's just see
what happens if we try to call it like
that
clear
to our form cloud
oops terraform console that's what I
meant to type
and so functions can't be called in here
which is totally fine
so go back and just set that like that
I just wanted to show you that
so if we did uuid we would get that
if we used bcrypt
so I might say bcrypt
hello world
okay
might be something interesting the IP
network here
so we might want to generate out a cider
subnet
right
the typing conversions is something that
you might come across a bit so we
already saw that when we converted a set
to a list and things like that
so maybe we might want to convert
something to a Boolean so we might say
two Bool
true
okay
these are pretty complicated the
collections
but we might have something that we want
to do here so coalesce might be
something that's interesting where we
have an array so or a list I suppose
so we might say like items
and make that a list
null null empty
last okay
bar items
so we might say coal
Plus
okay
and that didn't look like it pulled
anything out of there to reform coalesce
operation with this list of strings use
this symbol so we could use that
um
to do that so that just kind of expands
the arguments and so that what happened
here is null didn't exist Alden exists
this didn't exists so it pulled out last
okay
maybe we might want to just use keys
maybe we might just want to use Keys
here
okay so it might sound like hello
world
goodbye
Moon and remember we can do uh hash
Rocket Arrow equals or colon it's just
up to your preference I just wrote that
in for whatever reason I'm used to using
Ruby and that's what we use as hash
Rockets that's the name of the symbol
the equals Arrow
um okay it didn't like that so I guess
we do have to do it this way that's
totally fine I'm not upset by that I
thought it supported all three
maybe it's like minus equals or
something I don't know but what we'll do
say is save our stuff
and then what we can do here is do keys
okay
and it didn't look like it grabbed oh
yeah I grabbed the keys that's fine okay
and then we might say values
all right
um
you know maybe we might want to try
reverse that one's pretty clear
one two three
okay so nothing super complicated I
wonder if absolute would work in here
like the file system so we have absolute
path
I don't know if I don't know if this
would produce anything here oh it does
okay so we could ABS path
say path dot root
there you go
okay so that pretty much gives you a
general idea of built-in functions so
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
terraform Cloud again but in Greater
detail so terraform cloud is an
application that helps teams use
terraform together and so there is the
UI there and terraform cloud is
available as a hosted service on
terraform terraform.io it's actually at
the app.t terraform.io once you're
logged in and it has a lot of different
features so it can manage State files uh
have a history of your previous runs a
history of your previous States easy and
secure variable injection tagging run
trigger so chaining workspaces together
specify any version terraform per
workspace Global State sharing
commenting on runs notifications via
webhooks email and slack organization
and workspace level permissions policy
is code via Sentinel policy sets MFA
single sign-on cost estimation
Integrations with service now Splunk
kubernetes and custom run tasks and that
is not the limit to what it does but
this is what I could fit on the slide
okay
[Music]
let's take a quick look here at the
terminology or anatomy of terraform
clouds so we have an organization and
with an organization we have our
workspaces and a workspace represents a
unique environment or stack then you
have your teams these are composed of
multiple members and a team can be
assigned to multiple workspaces then you
have runs a run represents a single run
of the terraform-run environment that is
operating on an execution plan runs can
be triggered by like you your the UI
itself or maybe like a git repo it could
be API driven or CLI driven so there you
go
foreign
[Music]
so there are three types of cloud run
workflows so when you create a workspace
you have to choose a workflow and you
have either Version Control workflow we
have CLI driven workflow or API driven
workflow okay so just going over them in
Greater detail for the first one which
is that version controlled workflow
terraform cloud is integrated with a
specific branch in your VCS so githubs
via web hooks whenever pull requests are
submitted for branch speculative plans
are generated whatever a merge occurs to
that Branch then a run is triggered on
terraform Cloud then you have API driven
so workspaces are not directly
associated with the Version Control
System repository and runs are not
driven by web hooks on your VCS provider
a third-party tool or system will
trigger runs via uploading a
configuration file via the terraform
Cloud API so this configuration file is
a bash script that is packaged in an
archive and you're pushing it as a
configuration version so you're
basically creating configuration
versions every time you do that then
there's CLI driven and this is the way
we're going to be using mostly in the
course so runs are triggered by the user
running terraform CLI commands so you'll
run terraform apply and or plan locally
on your machine it's going to just work
as per usual okay
[Music]
let's take a look at organization level
permissions which manage certain
resources or settings across an
organization so the first things that
you can set would be something like
manage policy so create edit delete the
organization Central policies manage
policy override so override soft
mandatory policy checks manage
workspaces so create administer all
workspaces within an organization manage
VCS settings so set of VCS providers and
SSH Keys available within the
organization and for an organization we
have this concept of organization owners
so every organization has at least one
organization owner and you can have
multiple this is a special role that has
every available permission and some
actions only available to owners so this
could be publishing private modules
invite users to organizations manage
team memberships view all secret teams
manage organization permissions manage
all organization settings manage
organization Billings delete
organizations and manage agents so just
understand that there are these special
ones just for this organizational owner
and then these are these other ones here
that you can set for other types of
organizational level permissions okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at workspace
level permissions that allows you to
manage resources and settings for a
specific resource and we have granular
ones and then we have pre-made
permissions so let's go through the
granular permissions first so these
granular permissions you can apply to a
user via a custom workspace permissions
and so we have read runs queue plans
apply runs lock and unlock workspaces
download signal locks read variables
read and write read State outputs read
State versions read and write State
versions and so the idea is that what
you can do is just go and cherry pick
out what you want to assemble your
permissions for your user now if you
want something a little bit easier to do
you can use fixed permission sets and
these are pre-made permissions for quick
assignment and they're based on the read
plan and write so we have read runs read
variables read State versions for plans
we have q plans read variables read
State versions We have write so apply
runs lock and unlock workspaces download
setting unlocks read write variable read
write State versions and then there are
workspace admins and this is kind of
like the organizational owner so a
workspace admin is a special role that
grants all level of permissions in some
workspace admin only permissions those
admin only permissions would be read and
write workspace settings set or remove
workspace permissions of any team and
delete workspaces so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at API tokens so
terraform Cloud supports three types of
API tokens users teams and organization
tokens so for organization API tokens
they have permissions across the entire
organization each organization can have
one ballot API token at a time only
organization owners can generate or
revoke an organization token
organization API tokens are designed for
creating and configuring workspaces and
teams they're not recommended as
all-purpose interfaces to terraform
Cloud so basically you just use them
when you are setting up your
organization for the first time and you
want to do it pragmatically okay then
you have Team API tokens so this allows
access to workspaces that the team has
access to without being tied to any
specific user each team can have one
valid API token at a time any member of
a team could generate or revoke that
team's token when a token is regenerated
the previous token is immediately
becomes invalid designed for performing
API operations on the workspaces same
access level to the workspace the team
has to access to I would imagine this is
when you're sending out your own custom
CI CD pipelines or something like that
I'm not really sure exactly the use case
for team API tokens we have user API
tokens the most flexible token type
because they inherit permissions from
the user they are associate could be for
a real user or a machine user when you
do terraform login this is what you're
getting a a um a user API token okay
foreign
[Music]
so I just wanted to quickly show you
this axis levels chart that helps you
understand uh what kind of permissions
you were giving at the access level and
notice there's implicit and then
required or explicit permissions I'm
assuming that this means that you need
to assign those permissions to the user
first before they'd have it so just
because you have a user token doesn't
mean you get all of these orange
diamonds it's just the ones that you've
assigned to that user or team where I
believe that the organization you're
going to run into a chance where you're
going to have all these permissions by
default whether you want them or not so
just understand uh that you have to
double check this before you use your
tokens and that this chart exists okay
[Music]
all right so we covered private registry
earlier in the course when we were
looking at the terraform registry the
public one but let's cover it again with
a little bit different information so
terraform Cloud allows you to publish
private modules for your organization
within terraform Cloud private registry
and tour from Cloud's private module
registry helps you share terraform
modules across your organization include
support for module versioning a
searchable filterable list of available
modules a configuration designer which I
didn't find this thing but it sounds
really cool all users in your
organization can view your private
module registry authentic for
authentication you can either use a user
token or a team token so I guess this
would be the case where you might want
to use a team token for authentication
but the type of token you choose May
Grant different permissions as we saw
with the access levels just the slide
prior using terraform login will obtain
a user token just a reminder and to use
a team token you'll need to manually set
it in your terraform configuration CLI
file okay
[Music]
so there's a feature within terraform
Cloud that can do cost estimation and it
is a feature that will give you a
monthly cost of resources displayed
alongside your runs this feature is only
available starting at the teams and
governance plan and above but the idea
is that it will tell you for specific
resources and give you a summary so
notice here that we have some pricing
I'm going to get my pen tool out but we
have the overall cost and then it's
broken down per resource and so you can
see we have an hourly monthly and
monthly Delta
I don't know what the monthly Delta is
but um you know it gives you kind of
idea of cost you can use sentinel
policies to assert the expectation that
the resources are under a particular
cost so that's just kind of a bonus
there where you're like okay I want to
assure my spend is this the only
downside at least at the time right now
for cost estimation is the amount of
support it has so we have AWS Azure and
gcp so these are the resources that it
will support and so you have to look
through here and say okay you know is
there any resources I'm using outside of
this that I really care about
um and that so I think that if you're
using like core services so like ec2
instances load balancers things like
that that should help you out so like we
see AWS instance the load balancer the
volume some cloudwatch logs ALB for
Google it's just disk instance and
database so yeah it's just really
dependent on you know what's here so you
know it may meet your needs or you might
say okay this is not enough okay
[Music]
here's just a few options that I think
are worth noting within the terraform
Cloud workflows we have a whole section
of workflows but I decided to put it
over here just because let's talk about
it one thing you can do within terraform
cloud is set whatever version you want
so you can go as far back as you want uh
and this is great if you need to mix and
match different workspaces because you
have different stacks and they were
built on different terraform versions
and you're just not ready to upgrade
them yet you can choose to share State
globally across your organization for a
particular workspace this could be
really useful if you need to reference
things wherever you can choose to Auto
approve run so if you don't want to
always do that manual approve you can do
that this is great if you are looking
for that kind of agile kind of workflow
where if something is merged then it
should be rolled out okay
please
let's talk about if we had to migrate
our local state and we're using just the
default one two terraform Cloud how
would we do it so to migrate terraform
projects it only uses the default
workspace here from cloud it's pretty
easy you're going to create a workspace
and terraform Cloud you're going to
replace your terraform configuration
with the remote backend so if you have
nothing it's using local and you just
put in your remote State and then once
you have that in there you do a
terraform and knit and it's going to say
hey do you want to copy the existing
state you're going to type yes and once
you've done that I believe you have to
delete your old State file if you are
migrating multiple
um
multiple environments or you're moving
from a standard remote back end it's a
little bit more complicated they
definitely have guides in the docs but
this is the pretty much standard one
that you're going to come across when
you're working very early and we'll
definitely see this as we are using
terraform in our follow alongs okay
foreign
I want to talk about what kind of
Integrations we have for terraform for
Version Control Systems so we have
GitHub GitHub auth GitHub Enterprise get
lab gitlab EEG and CE I assume that's
Enterprise Edition and Community Edition
bucket Cloud bitbucket Server and data
center Azure devops service Azure devops
server so it's very simple you're just
going to choose from the one of the four
right and then you're gonna just drop
down and choose what variant it is there
and connect your repo every single
provider has different configuration
settings so you might have to meet those
depending on what they are you can get
from private repos you might have to add
your SSH key or something like that okay
[Music]
let's talk about terraform Cloud run
environment so when terraform Cloud
executes your terraform plan it runs
them in its own run environment so what
is a run environment a run environment
is a virtual machine or container
intended for the execution of code for a
specific runtime environment a run
environment is essentially a code build
server so the terraform Cloud run
environment is a single-use Linux
machine running on the x86 or x64
architecture and the details of its
internal simple petition is not known it
is possible to install software on it
but the only issue is that we don't know
what it is is a Debian is it Ubuntu you
just can't tell terraform Cloud will
inject the following environment
variables automatically on each runtime
so we have TFC run ID this is a unique
identifier for the current run the
workspace name the workspace slug so
this is the organization followed by the
workspace just going to get my pen tool
to just kind of point out over here on
the right hand side we have the
configuration version and git Branch so
you know if it is going to be on Main
it's going to tell us that if it's going
to be a particular version we'll know
that as well we can get the shaw of the
current commit there's that version and
if you want to access these variables
you just Define variable and the name
and then you can access it throughout
the code okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at terraform
Cloud agents this is a paid feature of
the business plan to allow terraform
Cloud to communicate with isolated
private or on-premise infrastructure
it's kind of like an in-between uh
between a terraform cloud and terraform
Enterprise where you want to use
terraform Cloud but you have uh
on-premise infrastructure but you're not
ready to move to terraform Enterprise so
this is useful for on-premise
infrastructure types such as vsphere
nutanix and openstack the agent
architecture is pole based so there are
no inbound connectivities required any
agent you provision will pull terraform
Cloud for work and Carry Out execution
of that work locally agents currently
only support the x86 architecture or the
x64-bit Linux operating system okay so
you can also run the agent within Docker
using the official terraform agent
Docker container if you just prefer that
over a VM agent supports terraform
version 0.12 and above the system
requires
request the system requires I'm going to
change that in the slide later on but
the system requires at least four
gigabytes of free to space for temporary
temporary local copies and two gigabytes
of memory needs access to make outbound
requests so you need to have open port
443 for app terraform i o registry
terraform i o releases hashicorp.com and
um
archivist.terra for my IO so there you
go
[Music]
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we are on to our terraform Cloud uh
follow alongs now we already did
terraform Cloud uh Version Control
System earlier than I thought we were
going to do so I'm going to remove from
the list and what we'll do is focus on
permissions and maybe the API tokens and
things like that so what I want you to
do and I've got some old tabs open here
but I'm going to make my way over to uh
terraform.io
and I'm going to go log into terraform
Cloud here
and I don't think I've ever done this
but I can upgrade to the trial count
because the thing is is that when we are
in our account here and we're trying to
look at permissions and we're not using
Force unlocking anymore I might just
keep that around for a little bit but if
we were to go to our user settings here
we go to organizations
um that might not be a very good example
like I said I wanted like the
organization settings here
which would be
maybe here yep up here and so you know
when we go to our teams and our users
our users everyone's being added as an
owner we don't have like granular
permissions and that's because we'd have
to upgrade and so I figured this would
be a good opportunity for me to just
kind of upgrade to show you those uh
more detailed uh role-based Access
Control permissions just so you know
where they are so I'm gonna go the
upgrade now and notice that we're on the
free plan and also take note because
later on the course I talk about pricing
or we've already already acrossed it but
notice that we have a team plan and a
team and governance plan this one's at
twenty dollars and this one's at seventy
dollars so you know this is not
something that's reflected at least not
right now on the terraform website and
so it just looks like there's a team in
governance plans for twenty dollars in
this middle one's missing the key
difference here is this one has Sentinel
policies code but you can see on the
free plan we are able to do
team-based stuff
let's go switch over to the trial plan
I'm going to see if I can do this
without entering a credit card in so
here it says you're currently on trial
planned I didn't have to enter anything
in that's really great and so that means
now I have all these Team Management
options so if I go over to team
management
I can actually go ahead and create some
teams
uh so I'll just say like Developers
okay
and so now I have all these options so
we can say this person if someone's in
this team they're allowed to manage
policies they're able to do that
a visible team can be seen by every
member or you can keep them secret we
can generate team API tokens which I
guess we could just like cover this as
we do it but notice we can go here and
that generates out that token that we
can use I'm going to go ahead and delete
that token
um so nothing super exciting there you
know it's not like that complicated
if we want to set things on the
workplace now if we go back to workplace
or workspaces here
and now we have Team access
and notice I can go to add team uh
permissions here
and we can say select this team for
their permissions
and so these are these uh pre-built ones
in
um
so we have read plan rights so these are
those three predefined ones that we
talked about previously and then we have
down here like assign permissions for
the admin of a workspace
we are able to set customized
permissions so if we toggle this
um we should be able to do it I mean
this looks like it's the same thing no I
guess it's more granular so here I guess
we have our granular permissions that we
can set so for runs we can do read plan
or reply
Locker unlock a workspace
send a locks things like that
it's not super complicated
if we want drain out API tokens for
uh well there's the organizational one
there's the teams one and then there's
the user one so
if we go to the organization
we can see that we can generate out one
here so I can say create an API token so
there it is let's go ahead and delete
that
and if we go back to our teams
we did this earlier but we can generate
one here
and then if you want to generate one for
your users probably under user settings
yeah so we generate tokens there as well
okay
so I mean again there's not a lot to
talk about here but um yeah so I guess
that really covers permissions and API
tokens okay okay so that finished
deploying there and so we can see our
resources have been created but one
thing that we didn't set was the prefix
I'm actually interested to see that that
worked properly but what I could do is
say prefix
and then do an underscore here and I
don't know how that would affect it
and this actually happened over in this
repository here I'm actually using a
hyphen so I'm going to just change that
to that
might have to do a terraform edit there
migrate the state
so that was a complete mistake on my
part but I guess my thought was that I
thought I had to have
um this is still on Main and I guess
we'd never really set up a production
Branch but yeah so now when we have the
prefix in it's actually going to prompt
us for the other one so the currently
selected workspaces are default does not
exist and so Dev is showing up and
notice that we can't deploy to main so I
think the thing is is that if we wanted
a production one we would just create
that workspace and then it would reflect
here so the way you make uh multiple
workspaces here would actually have to
make them all so we'd have to make a VCS
terraform prod and I'm very certain that
it would just show up here and then you
would select the number that you'd want
though what's interesting is the fact
that we are in the dev branch and we
have to say oh I want to deploy the dev
one so that's kind of a little bit of a
caveat there but I guess there's not
really any way around it but I mean this
pretty much
you know explores what we need for
multiple workspaces with terraform cloud
and we did the remote ones and we're all
good so there we go I guess the last
thing here we should probably do is just
clean up so if we go to terraform Dev
here we're going to go down to
destruction and we'll run a destroy plan
here
okay
and once this is all done you know you
can go ahead and just delete these
repositories
and notice this one is it has a private
lock on it so oh because it's actually
running right now so it's being locked
so yep there we go so that's it
[Music]
all right now let's take a look at the
terraform registry the private registry
so just go over here and click on
registry at the top and we can bring in
public
um
public things here so I can just go here
and type this in and we can hit add
and so now
um we just hit add to terraform cloud
add to my organization and that's public
facing but we could also add private
facing modules
so if we go back to our registry here
just going to go ahead and uh
down to publish here
and we go to GitHub
and I guess custom
and so then I suppose we just have to
enter all the stuff in here so as an
optional display name for your V Version
Control provider
client IDs client secrets
so it seems like there's a lot of work
to do we'd have to set up the SSH key
pair but I mean that's generally the
details that you need to know for that
okay
just seems like a lot of work for us to
set that up
you know and the course is going to be
like hey can you add a private module
and be like yes okay
so we'll go ahead and just remove this
so you can add both public and private
modules
um you know so there you go
[Music]
I have mentioned terraform Enterprise so
many times in this course but we've
never really talked about in detail and
now is our opportunity to do so so
terraform Enterprise is the self-hosted
distribution of terraform platform and I
just want to point out sometimes I call
the terraform platform terraform Cloud
just because that's the more prominent
uh version of it but terraform cloud is
a separate product from terraform
Enterprise it's just one is uh assassin
the other one is self-hosted so
terraform Enterprise offers a private
instance of the terraform platform
application with the benefits such as no
resource limits with additional
enterprise-grade architectural features
such as audit logging so you do you'd
have tamper evidence saml single sign-on
and I'm sure there's a lot more other
options there so let's just kind of look
at the architecture really quickly on
how this works so the first thing is you
have the terraform platform which is
going to be installed on a machine and
in particular this is installed on Linux
and it's specifically installed on
Debian okay so I believe that is the
Debian logo as far as as I remember if
it's not we'll find it on the next slide
if I'm wrong okay you're going to have
to have some kind of storage and there's
a few different options probably the
most common is going to be on something
like S3 but you can store it on the
storage or on the disk itself you have
to have a postgres database so that's
part of the infrastructure because that
is what the platform uses and you'll
also have to have your own TLS
certificate to access the machine
but there are also cases where you know
these are going through air gapped
environments but the idea is that you
have SSL or TLS it's like end-to-end
encryption it goes all the way to the
machine that's where it terminates okay
you'll also need your terraform license
so you'll have to plug that in once you
start up the terraform platform say hey
tell us the code so you can unlock this
um this software for you to use on this
dedicated machine okay
foreign
[Music]
so the requirements for terraform
Enterprises is going to highly vary
based on your operational mode that you
choose to run it in and that is really
dependent on how data should be stored
and when we're looking at the uh the
architectural diagram that was uh the
operational mode of external Services
there's three types of operational nodes
the first being external Services that's
when you use postgres and then use cloud
storage so in that example we're using
S3 but you can use gcp Azure blob
storage or Mino object storage but the
idea is that postgres and the cloud
storage are external they're not part of
that Linux server okay then you have a
mounted disk so this would just be
having a a persisted disk attached to
the VM so you know in the best case it's
called EBS so this stores data in a
separate directory on the host intended
for external disk so that would be both
the postgres database and the storage
volume itself you know postgres is still
a requirement and no matter what mode
you use then you have demo so stores all
data on the instance data can be backed
up with snapshots not recommended for
production use so this is where you have
ethereal data so you know the data you
know can vanish if you restart the
machine unless you make physical
snapshots
another component is credentials ensure
you have credentials to use Enterprise
and have a secure connection so the
first is we need the terraform
Enterprise license so you obtain that
from hashicorp and the other part is
having a TLS certificate and private key
so you need to prove uh you're the uh
you own uh your own TLS certificate okay
then we have the Linux instance so
terraform Enterprises designed to run on
Linux and it supports more than one
version so you know I said it was only
Debian but I guess there's a bunch I
just forgot so we have Debian Ubuntu Red
Hat Centos Amazon Linux there's a
variety for those Oracle Linux so yeah I
guess I just a big fan of Debian so
that's I guess that was my my thinking
there for Hardware requirements we have
at least 10 gigabytes of disk space on
the root volume at least 40 gigabytes of
disk space for the docker data directory
so that would be the VAR lib Docker at
least eight gigabytes of the system
memory and at least four CPU cores so
there you go
foreign
let's talk about error gapped
environments so what is an air gap an
air gap or disconnected network is a
network security measure employed on one
or more computers to ensure that a
secure computer network is physically
isolated from unsecure networks so the
public internet so it's no internet no
outside connectivity Industries in the
public sector so government military or
large Enterprises finance and energy
often employ air gap networks and so I
want you to know that hashicorp
terraform Enterprise supports an
installation type of air gap
environments okay so to install or
update terraform Enterprise you will
supply an air gap bundle which is an
archive of a terraform Enterprise
release version so that's how you would
um you know provided okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at terraform Cloud
features and pricing so I just want to
quickly go through it here so we have
three models we have the open source
software so OSS we have the cloud
offerings and the self-hosted offerings
I know these tiers we have free teams
and governance technically it's teams
and then teams and governance so they're
two separate plans but this is the way
they display it in their marketing
content but it really is a separate two
separate tiers in there you have
business and then Enterprise which is
considered self-hosted so in terms of
feature set
across the board you have IAC
workspaces variables runs resource
graphs providers modules the public
module registry which is terraform
registry workspace is a bit odd because
there are terraform Cloud workspaces
right
and then you have local workspaces so
technically those should be broken up
into two separate things or named
differently but that's just how it is
with terraform so you know just asterisk
on that workspaces there for the free
tier you get remote state or sorry for
everything outside of the open source
you get remote State vs VSC connection
so that's Version Control State
connection so connecting to GitHub or or
git lab or whatever workspace management
secure variable storage remote runs
private module registry once we get into
Cloud we get Team Management Sentinel
policy as code management cost
estimation the reason why I have that in
Red is because on the exam it could ask
you when is Sentinel policy available is
it available at what level and the thing
is it goes from teams and governments
all the way to the Enterprise level now
technically there is again one called
teams and there's teams and governance
so it's part of teams and governance not
part of teams okay
uh once we get into business this is
where we start to get single sign-on and
audit logging so you know if you need it
in the cloud or if you need it
self-hosted both options are available
in the business we have the you can have
the self-hosted agents for configuration
designer servicenow integration you have
it for those uh as well in terms of how
many runs you can have this is very
important because this is how many this
is going to put a bottleneck in terms of
your infrastructure rights on the free
Terry you can have one current run of a
workspace and teams you could have two
and then at the business level and
Beyond its unlimited current runs for uh
how you would actually interact with um
terraform you know this is going to be
through the local CLI for the open
source software for these it's Cloud
meaning that
um it's Cloud that is triggering the
execution commands and then self-hosted
it's not in the cloud it's on that
private machine okay
uh then we have support So for support
it's all community so that's just going
reaching out to DA's maybe there's a
slack Channel I believe that they have a
form so they have like a form where you
can ask questions and then they have
these layers like bronze silver and gold
I could not determine what these are
like what is offered in them and the odd
thing is is that you know there's a
silver and gold but it's offered both at
business and Enterprise so I don't know
if like you can upgrade to from silver
to gold so it's optional or you always
get silver and gold could not get
clarification I tried asking the sales
team no one would tell me so I think you
have to really be deep in that sales
funnel to find out in terms of pricing
it's zero to up to five users so the
thing is and this is really confusing
about terraform cloud and they really
shouldn't have called it teams up here
but you can start using terraform Cloud
for free up to five users as a team okay
so just negate the fact that it's not
called teams what they're saying is that
teams is really about getting a
base workspace Remote Manager which is
actually our RBA like
our ABC controls
uh role-based access controls so that's
the whole point of using teams so if you
need that and that's when you're at five
that's going to use it but you can use
it in the free tier as a team and you it
absolutely should once you get to the
teams plan it's going to be twenty
dollars a month and then if you need
teams and governance it's actually like
seven dollars a month so again it's kind
of like a bit misleading how they've
labeled this out but if you go and open
up teams Cloud you can see what the
actual packages are
for uh business that self-hosted your
contact and sales so I have no idea what
the cost is there so there you go
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
workspaces so workspaces allow you to
manage multiple environments or
alternate State files such as
development reproduction and there are
two variants of the workspace we have
CLI workspaces a way of managing
alternate State files locally or via
remote back-ends and then we have
terraform Cloud workspaces that act like
completely separate working directories
I'm going to tell you these two are
confusing because they don't exactly
work the same way but they have the same
name and originally workspaces were
called environments and so you know when
you're using terraform Cloud it makes a
lot of sense to call them environments
and the CLI workspace it's just a little
bit different so you know I'm not sure
if I'm going to do a great job
explaining the difference of these
things you really have to go through the
motion of it to really get the hang of
it but I'll do the best I can here okay
so think of workspaces as being similar
to having different branches in a git
repo workspaces are technically the
equivalent to renaming your state file
okay so in terraform 0.9 they used to be
workspaces used to be called
environments but people got confused
which I have no video why but you know
that's what it is now so by default you
already have a single workspace in your
local backend called default and the
default workspace can never be deleted
so even if you don't think you're using
workspaces you absolutely are even the
first time you use terraform at least in
the CLI workspace okay
[Music]
let's get a little bit into the
internals this isn't really that much
detail but depending if you are on a
local or remote back end changes how the
state file is stored so if you're on a
local state or a remote State it's going
to be different so uh terraform stores
the the workspace States in a folder
called
terraform.tfstate.d on the road State
the workspace file are stored directly
in the configured backend in practice
individuals or very small teams will
have been have known to commit these
files to the repos but using a remote
backend instead is recommended when
there are multiple collaborators so I
guess there's not really much to say
here but just understand that when you
have a local state file it's going to be
in that terraform TF State D and then
when it's remote State you don't have to
worry about it okay
[Music]
let's talk about interpolation with
current workspaces so you can reference
the current workspace name via the
terraform.workspace named value so we
saw that in the lineup way earlier in
the course so the idea here is that if
you wanted to
um see if the default like let's say you
want to say am I in the default
workspace then return five as opposed to
one because maybe you're very
comfortable spinning up more in the
default than whether it was something
else and just another example maybe you
want to use it to apply the name of the
workspace as a tag so here that would
actually give this virtual machine in
AWS the name web hyphen whatever it is
production or development so there you
go
foreign
let's talk about multiple workspaces so
a terraform configuration has a back end
that defines how operations are executed
and where persistent data is stored so
like the terraform state so multiple
workspaces are currently supported by
the following backends Azure RM console
cos GCS so that's Google Cloud Storage
kubernetes local Manta postgres remote
S3 they're not going to ask you this on
the exam which ones are supported but
you know for your own purposes if you
want to use multiple workspaces with a a
standard back end you probably want to
know which ones certain back ends
support multiple name workspaces
allowing multiple states to be
associated with a single configuration
that the configuration still has only
one back end but multiple distinct
instances of the configuration to be
deployed without configuring a new back
end or changing authentication
credentials why would you want to use
multiple workspaces for something like a
standard
um
a standard back end well the idea here
is that you know if let's say you're
using terraform cloud and you've reached
your limit of five users and it just
gets too expensive to go to the sex user
where you have to pay for all of them uh
you know then the thing is is that you
know this is an option for you it's just
kind of like another option out there
until you are ready to pay for terraform
Cloud at the next tier up so that's the
reason why I'm mentioning it here for
you okay
[Music]
all right let's quickly walk through the
terraform Cloud workspace and the
easiest ways to just show you a
screenshots so you create a workspace on
terraform Cloud so first you'll create
an organization mine's called exam Pro
and within that you'll create multiple
workspaces from there you'll click into
your workspace and you'll see uh like
previous run States variable settings
we'll click into runs from runs what
we'll get is a list of what happened
previously we can click into one of
those and we can see our plan and our
apply we can leave a comment on each run
that has happened if we if we just want
to expand the plan and apply here for
plan we will see all the details of what
it would change and then apply is it
actually setting up that infrastructure
and whether it was successful or not
notice you can also download Sentinel
unlock files we'll come and talk about
that later when we get to our Central
section we can also see a history of
previously held States so these are
snapshots of that infrastructure
and so you can click into there and
exactly see what it looks like this is
useful if you want to go and download it
if you were to need it so here's a diff
of what changed since the last state
okay and of course you can download that
stuff so you know hopefully that gives
you an idea of what you can do with
terraform cloud workspaces
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about terraform Cloud run
triggers so terraform Cloud provides a
way to connect your workspaces to one or
more workspaces via run triggers within
your organization known as source
workspaces so run triggers allows runs
to queue automatically in your workspace
on successful apply of runs in any of
your source workspaces and you can
connect each workspace to up to 20
source workspaces so run triggers are
designed for workspaces that rely on
information or infrastructure produced
by other workspaces if a terraform
configuration uses data sources to read
values that might be changed by another
workspace run triggers lets you
explicitly specify the external
dependencies so the idea is just allow
you to say okay I have one workspace I
I've triggered that I wanted now to do
that so this is really great if you have
a bunch of uh of environments or or
Stacks that are reliant on each other
and you want it to kind of have a chain
reaction the reason I'm mentioning run
triggers is a I think it's a cool
feature and B Because triggers is
something that is also uh something else
when we're looking at provisioners and I
just wanted to just clarify that there's
run triggers from terraform cloud and
then there's triggers that are for
um well I said provisioners I really
mean null resources they have triggers
in that okay so it's not going to show
up an example it's just a good to know
feature I just want to make sure there's
no confusion with the other triggers
[Music]
let's take a look at some of the
terraform workspace CLI commands that we
have available to us the first starting
with terraform workspace list so list
all the existing workspaces and the
current workspace is indicated by an
asterisk so that is our current
workspace there terraform workspace show
show the current workspace so right now
we're working in development terraform
workspace select switch to a Target
workspace so here we could say select
default and now we're in the default
terraform workspace new so create and
switch to a new workspace and then we
have terraform workspace delete so
delete a Target workspace now
understand that this is affecting your
local ones for the CLI commands Okay but
um yeah so this would actually show up
in the exam they might ask you like you
know which is Select and what does list
do and things like that so make sure you
know these commands Okay
[Music]
all right so I just wanted to contrast
against the local or CLI driven
workflows via the terraform Cloud
workflows because there's this great uh
table chart that's from the
documentation that I want to show you so
to our firm cloud workspaces and local
working directories serve the same
purposes but they store their data
differently so just looking here we'll
go down to components here so for
terraform configuration it's going to be
on disk for local for terraform cloud in
linked Version Control repositories or
periodically uploaded via the API or CLI
we have variable values so this is where
we use tfrs and when we're in terraform
Cloud it's in the actual workspace the
terraform Cloud workspace and so that
means that we are setting environment
variables to propagate that into our
code or inject those variables into our
code on execution for State it's on disk
or in a remote back end and in the
workspace for terraform Cloud it's
actually in the workspace credentials
and secrets are in Shell environments or
our internet prompts and workspace
they're stored ascent the variables
these are environment variables again so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are on to our terraform Cloud uh
follow alongs now we already did
terraform Cloud uh Version Control
System earlier than I thought we were
going to do so I'm going to remove from
the list and what we'll do is focus on
permissions and maybe the API tokens and
things like that so what I want you to
do and I've got some old tabs open here
I'm going to make my way over to uh
terraform.io
and I'm going to go log into terraform
Cloud here
and I don't think I've ever done this
but I can upgrade to the trial account
because the thing is is that when we are
in our account here and we're trying to
look at permissions and we're not using
Force unlocking anymore I might just
keep that around for a little bit but if
we were to go to our user settings here
we go to organizations
um that might not be a very good example
I guess I wanted like the organization
settings here
which would be
maybe here yep up here and so you know
when we go to our teams and our users
our users everyone's being added as an
owner we don't have like granular
permissions and that's because we'd have
to upgrade and so I figured this would
be a good opportunity for me to just
kind of upgrade to show you those uh
more detailed uh role-based Access
Control permissions just so you know
where they are so I'm gonna go the
upgrade now and notice that we're on the
free plan and also take note because
later on the course I talk about pricing
or we've already already acrossed it but
notice that we have a team plan and a
team and governance plan this one's at
20 and this one's at seventy dollars so
you know this is not something that's
reflected at least not right now on the
terraform website and so it just looks
like there's a team in governance plans
for twenty dollars in this middle one's
missing the key difference here is this
one has Sentinel policies code but you
can see on the free plan we are able to
do
team-based stuff
let's go switch over to the trial plan
I'm going to see if I can do this
without entering a credit card in so
here it says you're currently on trial
planned I didn't have to enter anything
in that's really great and so that means
now I have all these Team Management
options so if I go over to team
management
um I can actually go ahead and create
some teams
uh so I'll just say like Developers
okay
and so now I have all these options so
we can say this person if someone's in
this team they're allowed to manage
policies they're able to do that
a visible team can be seen by every
member or you can keep them secret we
can generate team API tokens which I
guess we could just like cover this as
we do it but notice we can go here and
that generates out that token that we
can use I'm going to go ahead and delete
that token
um so nothing super exciting there you
know it's not like that complicated
if we want to set things on the
workplace now if we go back to workplace
or workspaces here
and now we have Team access
and notice I can go to add team
permissions here
and we can say select this team for
their permissions and so these are these
uh pre-built ones in
um
so we have read plan rights so these are
those three predefined ones that we
talked about previously and then we have
down here like assign permissions for
the admin of a workspace
we are able to set customized
permissions so if we toggle this
um we should be able to do it I mean
this looks like it's the same thing no I
guess it's more granular so here I guess
we have our granular permissions that we
can set so for runs we can do read plan
or reply
Locker unlock a workspace
send a locks things like that
it's not super complicated
if you want to drain out API tokens for
uh well there's the organizational one
there's the teams one and then there's
the user one so
if we go to the organization
we can see that we can generate out one
here so I can say create an API token so
there it is just go ahead and delete
that
and if we go back to our teams
we did this earlier but we can generate
one here
and then if you want to generate one for
your user it's probably under user
settings
yeah so we generate tokens there as well
okay
so I mean again there's not a lot to
talk about here but um yeah so I guess
that really covers permissions and API
tokens okay okay so that finished
deploying there and so we can see our
resources have been created but one
thing that we didn't set was the prefix
I'm actually interested to see that that
worked properly but what I could do is
say prefix
and then do an underscore here and I
don't know how that would affect it
and this actually happened over in this
repository here I'm actually using a
hyphen so I'm going to just change that
to that
might have to do a terraform edit there
migrate the state
so that was a complete mistake on my
part but I guess my thought was that I
thought I had to have
um this is still on Main and I guess
we'd never really set up a production
Branch but yeah so now when we have the
prefix in it's actually going to prompt
us for the other one so the currently
selected workspaces are default does not
exist and so Dev is showing up and
notice that we can't deploy to main so I
think the thing is is that if we wanted
a production one we would just create
that workspace and then it would reflect
here so the way you make uh multiple
workspaces here would actually have to
make them all so we'd have to make a VCS
terraform prod and I'm very certain that
it would just show up here and then you
would select the number that you'd want
though what's interesting is the fact
that we are in the dev branch and we
have to say oh I want to deploy the dev
one so that's kind of a little bit of a
caveat there but I guess there's not
really any way around it but I mean
that's pretty much you know explores
what we need for multiple workspaces
with terraform cloud and we did the
remote ones and we're all good so there
we go I guess the last thing here we
should probably do is just clean up so
if we go to terraform Dev here uh we're
going to go down to destruction and
we'll run a destroy plan here
okay
and once this is all done you know you
can go ahead and just delete these
repositories
and notice this one is it has a private
lock on it so oh because it's actually
running right now so it's being locked
so yep there we go so that's it
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at Sentinel
which is an embedded policies code
framework integrated within the
terraform platform so what is policies
code when you write code to automate
regulatory or governance policies and
features of Sentinels include uh it that
it's embedded so enable policy
enforcement in the data path to actively
reject violating Behavior instead of
passively detecting so it's very active
or proactive fine-grained condition
based policies so make policy decisions
based on the condition of other values
multiple enforcement levels so advisory
soft and hard mandatory levels allow
policy writers to warn on or inject
reject Behavior we have external
information so Source external
information to make holistic policy
decisions we have multi-cloud compatible
compatible so ensure infrastructure
changes are within business and
Regulatory policy across multiple
providers and Sentinel is a paid service
part of the team and governance upgrade
package so Syrian team in governance
it's available for that
business and Enterprise okay
[Music]
let us expand a bit on the concept of
policies code and relating to Sentinel
so Sentinel is built around the idea and
provides all the benefits of policy of
code let's talk about the benefits we
get with this so sandboxing the ability
to create guardrails to avoid dangerous
actions or remove the need of manual
verification codification the policies
are well documented exactly represent
what is enforced Version Control easy to
modify or iterate on policies with a
chain of history of changes over time
testing so syntax and behavior can
easily be validated with Sentinel
ensuring policies are configured as
expected automation so policies existing
as code allows you to allows you to
direct integrate policies in various
systems to Auto remediate and notify
we're talking about senatal and policies
code we have language so all Sentinel
policies are written using the sender
language this is designed to be
non-programmer and programmer friendly
and embeddable and safe for development
Central provides a CLI for development
and testing and for testing Central
provides a test framework designed
specifically for for automation so
hopefully that gives you an idea of the
benefits of policy code and in
particular with Sentinel
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the
Sentinel language and also just a broad
uh range of of use cases that we could
use these for so you can start thinking
about how to start applying Sentinel the
great thing is that there are a bunch of
example policies provided by hashicorp
so you can easily
um you know start using them right away
but let's go through the big list to
kind of give you an idea where you would
use policies code so for AWS maybe you'd
want to restrict the owners of the AWS
Ami to a data of the data source maybe
you want to enforce mandatory tags on
taggable AWS resources restrict
availability zones used by ec2 instances
disallow a
0.0.0.04.0 basically anywhere address
out to the internet restrict instance
types of ec2 so maybe you only want
people using T2 micros require S3
buckets to be private encrypted by KMS
since that is a big
um a big problem for people on AWS where
their buckets get leaked require vpcs to
have DNS host names enabled we're
looking at gcp enforced mandatory labels
on VMS disallow allow anywhere cider and
force limits on gke clusters because
those can get really expensive restrict
machine types of VMS just like AWS for
VMware required storage DRS on datastore
clusters restrict size and type of
virtual disks restrict CPU count memory
of VMS restrict size of VM disks record
NFS 4.1 and cure Burrows I never can say
that properly on NAS data stores for
Azure enforced mandatory tags of VMS
restrict Publishers of VMS restrict VM
images restrict the size of azure VMS
enforce limits on AKs clusters restricts
cider blocks of security groups for
cloud agnostic allowed only say we can
only use these allowed providers say or
explicitly say what providers are not
allowed limit proposed monthly costs
prevent providers in non-root modules
require all modules have version
constraints require all resources be
created in modules and private module
registry use most recent versions of
modules in a private module registry
that's more so like about the tooling
around modules
now let's take a look at an example and
this is one for restricting uh available
zones on ec2 instances so like what data
centers you're allowed to use and so we
first import our language functions
that's going to allow us to use
particular uh feature functions in this
we're going to specify our azs we're
going to get all the virtual machines
we're going to filter that and restrict
the AZ for those VMS we're going to
Define that rule to make it enforceable
so there you go
thank you
[Music]
all right let's take a look here with
Sentinel with terraform so Central can
be integrated with terraform via
terraform Cloud as part of your IEC
provision Pipeline and where it's going
to sit is between plan and apply okay
so the way you do it is you're going to
have to create a policy set and apply
these to the terraform workspace so it's
not that complicated to get it hooked up
so yeah that's all there is to it okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're going to learn a bit about
Sentinel with terraform I'm not going to
say I'm amazing at it but we are going
to stumble our way through and see what
we can accomplish we know we can
download Sentinel box and there's also
the ability to set policy sets and I do
know that there are a bunch of pre-made
Sentinel policies so we go send no
policies here terraform
uh and we go examples uh there we are
probably here
there are a bunch of ones that we can go
in here so I'm thinking that there's
something that we can do here
um but we'll have to figure our way
through here because I actually haven't
ran any um policies myself so we have
these two environments I'm not using Dev
anymore I'm done with this I'm going to
go ahead and destroy that and we're
going to go down to terraform destroy
I'm pretty sure I don't have any running
infrastructure actually I'm going to
double check by going to the overview
everything has been destroyed and so
I'll go back over here and we're going
to destroy this I'm going to type in VCS
terraform Dev
great if we go into this workplace or
workspace nothing is provisioned right
now so I want to get everything running
again because last time we ran a destroy
so I think that if we want to get this
working it should be pretty easy I'm
going to go back to
our
workflows file here
and we're just going to revert some
changes so I'm going to go back and
change this to name
and I'm just going to go whoops we're
going to go into our 120 directory here
and we're going to check out Main and
that actually might just revert those
changes there I don't think anything
really changed much other than this part
here
and so what I'm going to do is just go
Um
make a minor change it doesn't matter
what it is maybe a space
get add all whoops
git commit hyphen m
changes
get push
I'll have to do a good pull here
sorry get push
and so what I want to see here is a
trigger for the Run
there we go and I'll see you here in a
bit when it's provisioned okay all right
so after a short little weight there it
looks like our branches Ran So I think
our resources are provisioned it's cool
we actually have cost estimation I
didn't have to do anything to turn that
on we already have it notice that it's
giving us an hourly of Zero 12 cents the
monthly is going to be eight dollars in
you know 35 cents there if there was
more resources there we would obviously
get that I assume that it would show up
here in the top right corner so
we're not really interested in the
provision infrastructure but more so
looking at these Sentinel locks so I'm
going to go ahead and download them
there and that's going to download as a
um a zip
or an archive of some sorts and so what
I can do here
is just unzip it so I'm just going to
make a new folder
here and we'll just call these um
Sentinel marks
okay I'm just going to open up the zip
and so here's all the stuff in here so
we have a variety of different files I
think some of them might be redundant
I'm not sure what we have to do with
them but I'm just going to go ahead and
grab these and drag them into the folder
here
okay and actually what I'm going to do
is
um I'm going to just make a new section
in my folder here whoops
just give me a second here
we'll just open up the Explorer to
anything
yeah we have a folder right here
because what I want to do is just drop
those files in so we can just see them
in vs code the contents of them
there we go
and so now I'm just going to go down to
here
and we'll take a look so we have
Sentinel HCL
all right and so that's just defining a
bunch of mocks
we have this Central File here
so I was hoping when we open this it
would be able to figure out what to do
with this and I have no idea so you know
what what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to do a little bit of reading and
I'm going to come back to you after I
finish reading this okay all right so
spending a little bit of time uh
watching some stuff so I was just going
through the Deep dive of Sentinel here
uh and just going through the
documentation and as far as I understand
it looks like that you write policies
and then you can also write tests for
your policies to assert that your
policies are doing what you expect them
to do and I guess those uh Sentinel
locks are written in a form of HCL but
it is a little bit confusing because you
get this folder with a bunch of stuff in
it and it can be either written as Json
or like this htl like format but as far
as I can tell it's just saying what it's
done is it's generated out these the
current state of exactly what your
infrastructure is and I think that it's
going to check to see is it exactly what
you expect it to be so I don't know if
MOX is that very useful and might be a
little bit too much for this particular
course so I'm just going to say okay
let's just kind of ignore locks because
they're just a little bit too too
difficult and out of scope here let's
follow focus on trying to get a policy
implemented so I'm going to go back over
here and what I'm going to do is I know
that if I go to settings
I mean I've seen it before I just can't
remember if it's under a workspace
no it's I think it's at the organization
level so we're gonna go to the settings
here
and there we have our policies so we
here we can create new policies so
managing individual policy terraforms
deprecated policy sets now supports VCS
integration with direct API uploads this
provides a streamlined policy management
experience policies which includes okay
so this is the old way of doing it and
so we'll go here and create a new policy
set so connect a new policy set
um okay so I guess what we have to do oh
boy this is a lot different than I
thought it was going to be so I thought
it was just like we're going to go here
and create it and then dump our code in
which apparently that's what it is but
it seems like we need to associate with
the policy set so just give me a moment
because I do want to show you the the
most up-to-date way to do this I'll be
back in a second all right all right so
doing a little bit of reading here it
looks like what we have to do is create
ourselves a sendile.hcl file and this is
going to say what policies we want to
enforce so I assume this is basically
the policy set as a file and here we
specify the policies that we care about
um I actually just want to go back to
the files we were looking at earlier
because we saw this HCL file so I guess
this would technically be a policy set
is that what we call that here but
notice it says mock so these aren't
policies per se these are just grouping
mocks but in any case I think we'll have
to create this file so what I'm going to
try to do
and I don't know this is going to work
but we'll just stumble our way through
here because it's the best way to learn
is we're going to create ourselves our
own Sentinel file here so we're going to
say
um
Sentinel dot HCL
and we're going to Define ourselves a
policy
this is going to be the one that we're
going to use but I'm just going to grab
it here notice there are different
enforcement levels so
um I don't really care we put in I just
want to see that we can successfully get
anything working here and I'm going to
go back to the examples
if we can go find that there so
Sentinel
policy examples and let's just go take
one of those and see what we can do with
it okay
so if we scroll on down
um
this allows zero zero zero cider Block
in the security group that seems like
something that would be pretty relevant
restrict instance type of ec2 instance
that could be something as well that we
could do
so you know I just have to decide what
it is we want to do here restrict owners
so there's a few that are good here
let's take this take a look at this one
because I feel like this might be very
simple
so yeah this is perfect okay so what
we'll do is we'll take uh this policy
here so I wonder if I could just go
download this file here it's probably
like a download button
well I can't find it so we'll just or
maybe it's up here
no okay we'll just create this by hand
here so I'm going to go copy and it
looks like we can just drop it in here
so I'm just going to new
file here
and put that there and we will just go
to Raw
and we will go ahead and drop that on in
there
so I wish I had like sandal highlighting
I don't know if there is such one for vs
code if there is it'd be really nice so
we would type in Sentinel
um uh yes we do
this one has more downloads so we'll go
with that one
no rating as of yet looks like it works
so let's go give them a five star
I think that's only fair because uh no
one's done that yet
might be a bit too hard to uh I've never
written a review before but we'll go
here and say works as expected
thank you for this uh
extension
okay so what I'm going to do is go back
over to here and so here we have some
kinds now we're running a T2 micro I
believe so this policy should cause it
to fail and that's exactly what we want
but I'm just going to go look up and
down to see if it's all correct looks
good to me so I think we'll have to
change over here is the name so I'm just
going to clear this out and we'll say
restrict
ec2 instance
type
we'll save that hard mandatory sounds
really good to me
um probably have to spell it right for
it to work r-e-s yeah strict okay great
and so what I'll do is just copy this up
here
okay and so we have our signal HCL file
and it's referencing a local file now
the question is you know can we use the
same repository I assume we would be
able to uh for our policy set but it
almost seems like it might encourage you
to have your policies separate from your
repository that you're testing and that
might be really good because let's say
you have multiple workspaces or
environments and they all require the
same policy set you wouldn't want to
have them in your code base like that
but for the purposes of this we're just
going to keep it simple I'm going to go
ahead and open up terminal here and
we're going to commit these uh these
changes to our Repository
and this will end up triggering a deploy
even though we don't necessarily want
that to happen but there's no way around
that so get well I suppose we could just
cancel it out but or not have the auto
apply but I don't feel like changing
that so we'll do get status here we'll
go get add all git commit hyphen M uh
simple policy here
get push
okay
and so that's being pushed to our
repository that's going to trigger a
deploy and we don't care I I assume that
it won't pick up the policy because we
have to kick the policy set
so
um apparently use the API to upload your
policy set which is kind of cool I
suppose we could have done that but um
well too late we probably should use VCS
anyway you know what I mean so we'll go
to GitHub here and we will find our
terraform repository which is here
um you know policy
well we should probably name this right
so we policy to enforce uh instance type
I don't know if we need a description I
guess we'll find it in a second here I
guess we could have also put the policy
in a um a subdirectory there that might
have been okay to do
it's going to default to the main branch
which is fine policies enforced On All
workspaces or policies and force on
selected workspaces and we only have one
but that's what we'll do down here so
we'll say update
the name is invalid
oh uh it has to be like
a proper name so restrict
ec2
now again this is a policy set so you
could just say like
um
you know basic server policy
set that'd probably be better and then
you probably want to list to say what it
does it restricts
um ec2 instances instance type
okay and we'll go down here and create
that policy set
and that looks like we're in good shape
so we applied it um now will it actually
happen on this run because it's already
running I believe we're going to this
workplace
workspace I like to say workplace it's
workspace and uh we go over here this is
already planned and finished so what I
want to do is just trigger another uh
um deploy here so there's nothing
changed
so
I'm not sure what we do here
um I guess what we could do and actually
this is something that I'm I don't know
but like how would you trigger a replace
on here because if we were doing let's
go to plan and see what happens I wonder
if we could do that in the plan here
reasons for trigger
do refresh only plan because one thing I
was thinking about is like imagine I
wanted to replace an element you can do
that hyphen replace but I don't know how
you do that through VCS but anyway what
I'm going to do is just go change
anything in our code
um so it could just be a space it
doesn't really matter
get add plus git commit
trigger uh change
and we just want to observe
the um
the policy working okay
so I'm just going to open this up here
I'm not sure if it's going to show up in
the plan section or the apply section so
we'll just wait here to watch see the
plan generate out
and so the plan finished
um we don't see any Sentinel uh Central
being applied there
apply will not run
let's expand that there this looks fine
I guess technically we didn't change
anything so that probably is not very
helpful so what I'm going to do is go
and change a variable because maybe
that's that's what's going to help here
so we have a micro here which is fine
we're just going to change this over to
Nano
that makes sense why I didn't do it so
we'll go back over to runs and I'm going
to trigger I'm going to start a plan so
uh changed ec2 instance type
we'll say Start Plan
okay so we have one change which is fine
we just okay so that part pass is going
to go to cost estimation
that passed it's going to apply it
because remember we have um Auto approve
on the server so it's not even going to
ask us to confirm it and so I want to
see if that policy is in place
well it's running I'm just going to go
review our policy here
just to make sure it's not like the
opposite saying like you cannot have
these so include now a loud easy to do
instance type so it's small medium or
large so it really should quit out on
this one here
but it seems like it's working like it's
not uh it's not picking up the policy
but I'll see you hear it back in a bit
okay all right so I didn't see the
policy trigger there so I'm going to go
back to policy sets and notice here it
says zero workspaces which is unusual
because I definitely selected one but
maybe I didn't click through or hit uh
add so I'm going to go down here and
click this one again and maybe I didn't
hit this button here
okay and now I'll probably have to hit
update um policy set before we do I just
want to read about this these parameters
are past the central runtime on
performing policy checks so I guess I'd
be like a way where you'd have a generic
policy and then you could kind of put
parameters in so that's kind of cool so
I'm going to go back here and double
check to make sure that we have a
workspace set and so what we'll do is
just change the variable again
um so we will go to our variables here
and I'm going to go change this back to
a micro and so I think this time we are
going to have better success okay so
we'll hit save we'll go back up to runs
we'll go and start a new plan uh change
instance type
again here
and we will save that plan and so that
plan is now running I will see you back
here in a bit uh when we see that
Sentinel policy I don't know when it
triggers so I'll see you back here in a
bit all right welcome back so after our
cross estimation it did a policy check
and you can see that it failed um and
here the error says import TF plans
function is not available so I'm not
sure why that's happening so I think
that um I mean our set failed but not
for the reason we wanted to so I'm going
to go investigate this I'll be back in a
moment okay all right so uh what I've
done here is I've gone and looked up uh
like how to create a policy set and
hashicorp learn has this example project
here and if we go into its GitHub
project and I go here you're going to
notice that it it's like this apparently
does basically the same thing restrict
AWS instance type and apparently tag as
well but it doesn't have the TF
functions the TF plan functions here so
um maybe we don't need that function in
there and maybe the uh the example is
just out of date at this time so import
common functions
for Sentinel
okay but this one doesn't have it it
does it does have it for mocks right
um
so maybe we just need to kind of like
walk through this really quickly and see
how we can fix this so the policy uses
the Sentinel TF2 plan import to require
that all ec2 instances have instance
types planned under the loud list
but I don't see that import there
okay and it is in here
so I guess what we'll do is just grab
this one
okay and I'm going to go ahead and just
delete this one out here
um
again this isn't working I don't know if
this would work with that one so I'm
going to take it out
this is pretty clear what this does so
we'll just have that allowed types it's
interesting like here it's underscore
and then here it's like a title case
there's some inconsistencies there so
they have a lot of types as well
um
and I'm just seeing if there's like find
resources in here
so allow types rule to enforce the name
tag
so I don't care about that
rule to restrict the instance type so
I'm going to go ahead and grab this one
here and let's just take a look at the
differences here
okay so instant type allowed rule all
ec2 instances as
that instance
change after instance type a lot type so
this is way way different
um
so I mean I fully don't understand this
but I do know that this one
it will probably work so I'm going to go
down here
we have count violations I'm not really
worried about that
and
the rule is different
like if I was really serious about this
I'm sure I could you know figure out the
logic here but again this is just for
the purposes of us learning so we don't
have to go too crazy here now this says
instance type allowed and mandatory
instance tags we're not dealing with
tags here so I'm just going to say this
okay and so I think this will produce
what we want
so allows those types
I don't know if it had this in here
get all instant types from the module
I think we didn't put this in here so
this might be kind of the equivalent
ec2 instances filter TF plan resource
changes
okay
contains a create or an update
[Music]
um
I mean this isn't bad we technically
have a name set so you know what I'm
just going to grab this whole thing
because then we're just going to have a
much easier time we don't have to worry
about it but it was nice to walk through
that file very quickly because the name
tag is set in our project a because we
can see we can see that's the server
name so what we'll do is we'll just go
ahead and add this to our repository
here and the great thing is that since
it's the vs code or it's in the same
Version Control System I would think
that it would update in time so what
we'll do is just do get add all git
commit hyphen m
fix the policy
git push
okay and we'll go back over here
and we will see
if the policy check happens and when it
does happen it's actually
airing out because we're not using the
right instance size right that's what we
want to see
a little bit of trial error it's not a
big deal I also read like over here that
the Sentinel file for HCL only contains
module and policies but then we saw a
sentinel file or htl file that clearly
had mocks in it so
I mean maybe maybe it just only used
locally maybe it's not intended for um
production
um so we'll go down here TF plan so it
didn't pick it up okay so what I'm going
to do is go back to my policy set and
maybe it's just like the order of how
this happened
so see this says it was updated uh last
five minutes ago
updated it a minute ago so this could
just be like a race case where
um you know this ran before the other
one so I'm going to try to execute this
again start a new plan uh trigger plan
and we'll see if that works now because
again this said
literally updated a minute ago so maybe
it didn't pick it up
so you can see why it would also be good
to have your policy set in a separate
repo because if you're deploying this
you don't want to keep triggering your
deploys
so I think probably that's what you know
we should have done I mean it's a lot
extra work but you know this way you
kind of understand why
SO waiting on that plan run I really
don't care about cost estimation I mean
you could make a policy to check based
on that I I'm assuming we just turned
that off if we wanted to
and we'll go over to cost estimation
here yeah we can just disable it
but the thing here is that it set our
policy passed
so we'll go here so the result means
that all Central policies passed
so restrict the instance type so
description
main rule that requires other rules to
be true
ruleton Force name tag is on all
instances that's true rule to restrict
the instance type
so maybe we don't understand uh maybe
this works in the opposite way oh the t2
micros here okay so
I just want to see it fail so what we'll
do is go back up to our variables here
and we'll go to our instance type
and we'll just change this to Nano
and we'll save that
we'll go back over here to our runs
oh this is still running the old one
here that's fine we can just queue up
another one here so we can just say
start a new plan
uh new instance type
okay and if we go back over to here
the last one wouldn't have done anything
because the infrastructure would have
been the same so
the previous one we just did here right
it would just been like oh no it's still
trying to apply it so I guess there is a
change
maybe we changed the instance type last
time I don't know
so anyway I'll see you back here when
this is completely done okay
all right great so we got an error if we
go into our instance type here
right and we look at it we can see that
it failed because uh it wasn't the right
uh type so
um I mean that's pretty interesting so
the other thing I would say that we
could do is also kind of check out mocks
now because I kind of feel like I have a
better grasp on it now that we have a
test running so just thinking straight
about it a mock really is a
representation of the state of
infrastructure at the time of so if we
go back to our runs and we go to a
successful run like the trigger plan
here and this one was successful we
could go to the plans here and then
download these mock files so we do have
the ones from prior and I think those
are totally fine and valid to use so
what if what we do is go back to our
project over here and we have
um
the mock files over here but really
where they need to be is within the
workflow directory because looking at
the documentation here
what it's saying is that you get all
these things and this basically
represents the state of those mock files
and then you need to make a test folder
and then a test data folder and then
there's gonna be something based on the
name of the uh the mock file so what
we'll do is we'll go
up to this folder here and we'll say new
folder test and then we'll make another
new folder here test data
those folders are files
I think those are files so I'll delete
that it's just out of habit to click the
um
the file there so we'll say new folder
so we'll say test
and then we'll say another new folder
there
test data
okay and so we have our sendle file here
so we need to have I think a similarly
named one here so if we go back over
here
um this is Foo whatever so I think we
need to have a folder in here because
it's all based on convention and I just
it's pretty not that hard to figure I
don't have to read the docs to know that
we'll just put that in here take out the
word Sentinel
and then I would assume that we need a
file in here what's it called like this
pass and fail so I'm going to just do a
pass
file new
pass.hcl
okay and then we have our test data so
that was what we had down below here so
I need to go grab that information
I'm just looking for a folder where
I might already have open here if I
don't that's fine we'll just go ahead
down below and just right click
and reveal and explore
we'll go over here
and I need to move all these over so I
just copy them over and we're going to
go over to our terraform work
flow here and I'm going to go here and
paste that data in
I don't know if these contain any kind
of sensitive data because if they're
based on the TF State file these might
be something you don't want to share
that might be a security vulnerability I
don't know but I definitely won't have
these available when I put this
repository up for free so we have those
files in the right place
and we have all this stuff here so I I
think that um like you notice it's not
there so I'm assuming that we need to
open up this file and copy into our main
HCL file so we'll go down below here and
then I think it's just a matter of
copying all this stuff right
we'll say cut
and then we will go to
um back up to here I suppose
into our
file it's getting a little bit confusing
with all this stuff eh
okay so that's in the right place our
test data is there good here we are okay
so what I'm going to do is just go down
here and paste that in
okay and so
we didn't write any kind of pass
data test
so that's something we will need here
I'm not sure what we'll get so we'll
just scroll down here
so you can find the contents of a
pass.hcl
it's not showing anything here so just
give me a moment I'm going to see what
we have to do for this this test okay
all right so a little bit of Googling it
looks like uh this one's on the same
tracker so since we probably copied the
mock data from this one or somewhere
through here we could probably just go
grab this so
um this is pretty much what our pass
file will look like
so we'll go ahead and grab this here I
don't know if we really need a fail to
write a failing test I don't really care
about that I just want to see anything
pass here
we'll paste that in here we do have to
be sure that we are accessing our data
correctly so if we're in test it's going
to go up one directory to the
terraform directory
but wouldn't it have to then CD into
uh test so I don't think that Source
path is correct
just going to double check that here
they do have an example repositories
let's take a look here what we have
um
yeah it's kind of odd so I think
that
if this is relevant it needs to go to
test data
because how else will it get there okay
so we'll do that so test rules main
equals true
um
okay so that's a pretty simple test
and so I think the way we run tests is
there's like a sentinel test
thing here
I don't know if we have Sentinel
installed I don't think so
so there's no Sentinel command
so I guess that's something we're gonna
have to install Sentinel
[Music]
um
CLI terraform
okay
over here
uh we're on technically Linux even
though we're on Windows we're on Linux
so here it's just saying uh download it
and then put it in the correct path
so install so we'll get the appropriate
package here
and we are technically on Linux
and I guess we are 64-bit
it's going to download here
scroll up oh it is already downloading
okay great and so I'm just going to go
to my downloads
and I'm going to open it up here
so there it is and so I need to um
get it into the user local bin here so
I'm just going to first get it in
anywhere so
because I'm just working here I'm just
going to go open this up so reveal in
the Explorer
okay
and this is not where I want it to be
I'm just dropping it here for the time
being
technically we could run it from there I
don't think it'd be that big of a deal
so I'm just going to go back to my vs
code here
and I'm going to just type signal
Sentinel
is there right
yep it's there
I'm not sure if it's executable but um
I'm just going to type in Sentinel here
Sentinel test
okay so it doesn't think it's command so
maybe I have to do like chamod U plus X
that makes it executable on Linux
so note command not found
well heck I'm right there maybe I have
to put a period forward slash like that
okay there we go so I mean of course you
don't want to leave it in here you and
this would also end up in a repository
so this will go to like your user local
bin probably so
I'm going to say like move sendle to
user local bin
and so now I should just be able to type
Sentinel it should get picked up
it does great so here I can do test
and down below it says open test no such
file or directory so it can't find the
mock data notice that it's going into
the test test data so that is no good
for us we did say to go up a directory
so maybe if I go up back one more like
this
would that work
no let's go put back in what they
actually had there which I have a hard
time believing that would be correct
so open mock okay so that's definitely
not right okay and so
personally I just want this to work so
I'm just going to cheat
this is absolutely what you should not
do but you know like I don't be fiddle
around with paths all day here
and so I'm just going to give it an
absolute path and see if that fixes our
problem
okay and so just say test data
here
um
so that should absolutely work I'm just
going to expand this here
this is mock TF plan
oh but it says pass in the name okay so
the problem isn't that it's the fact
that the mock data isn't named it's
because the thing is you could download
two different mocks right so you could
have a state that is successful and
failed and you'd probably want to rename
them to say passed or failed so we don't
necessarily have that so I think my
original thing was correct where we had
this test data
and so here we just have to make sure we
match the name so mock TF
uh V2 is fine here
okay again I don't understand the
difference between all these files I
definitely saw the documentation to
explain them all so you know that might
be something we want to read through
here
um so this is looking a little bit
better so mock TF plan hyphen version 2
Sentinel
so that
is correct
but the director it doesn't like the
direct it's going in that test again so
again I can just go back up one more
layer here
okay
there we go and it's passing so
um yeah so that's all it takes to
um do that again I think if we were to
commit this to our code I don't think
that these run so we can go like so we
can just go add it and see what happens
so we'll say get add
git commit hyphen M validation
and again I don't know if this mock data
should be allowed to be committed into
the Repository
because we have a TF State file here
right
okay I don't know but I'm going to just
do a push here to see what happens
but again I I really think that we're
probably not supposed to have it in
there
um so what we'll do
is go back to our terraform i o
sign in
and we'll just see what happens here I
mean we don't expect the uh this to pass
because it's still using the wrong
instance type but I was just curious to
see if the mock would appear in any way
here I don't think it does I think
that's just something that you have to
do uh beforehand and I think what you'd
have is you'd have a pull request and
the pull request could be used to run
those unit tests because that's
basically what it is okay so yeah that's
exactly what I thought would happen but
down below here it says the mock block
is not supported so
I wonder what you would do so if you
can't have mocks in the file
what would you do locally because you
need to I guess the thing is is that the
mock file the sentinel.hcl file would
not be in this fold so you might have
the central HCL file in your main
repository for mocking right and if you
committed it wouldn't run it because the
policy set would actually be in another
repository so I think that's how it's
supposed to work so
yeah I think really we want to have
policy sets in their own repository like
completely away from there because we're
seeing we're running into a lot of
problems but we pretty much accomplished
what we wanted to do with Sentinel more
than I thought we were going to do so
that's pretty great so there you go
um in terms of this we probably want to
tear this down uh we do need to do
something with vaults and stuff like
that but I think that what we'll do is
just tear this down and you know if we
need to bring it back up we'll do that
so I'm going to go to destruction here
Ed
we're gonna go ahead and just destroy
the plan here
okay
and we're all now in good shape
and so um yeah I'll see you in the next
part okay
but we're all done here for for Sentinel
all right uh actually I guess we're not
gone here just yet because it looks like
our destroy run failed uh because we
didn't pass here so
um that is a bit of a problem so we'll
have to go to the variables
I guess it's a good Edge case to know
about but um we'll go back and change
this to a micro even though it's going
to just tear it down anyway you know
so we'll go and type in micro save
variable and we'll go back to our runs
we'll start a new plan we're sorry we'll
go to settings here
destruction
cue the plan
I'm just curious the community plan
we'll redirect a new up output here
okay cool um so I'm just going to type
in VCS terraform again here
okay and so
this should work
and I will come back and just confirm
this with you okay so I'll be back in a
second all right so the real reason we
can't uh get rid of this is because we
have those darn mocks in there so
um
what I'm going to do is go over to our
signal file here
um up to I mean we don't use this one so
I'm gonna go ahead and delete that it's
not even something that's going to
happen and
we need to update our
HCL file here
okay
and I'm assuming that this supports uh
this okay
because this is not how we should be
doing this
um and here we go get add git commit
hyphen m
INE or change
okay and this is going to trigger a run
here
but I really wanted to destroy
so we'll just give it a moment there to
start so we can kill it
um
did I not push
oh maybe I didn't push
and we'll go back here
there's that run I'm going to go in here
I want to stop it uh cancel run
okay and so now what I'll do is go over
to the here
destroy this
we'll run that okay we'll destroy that
and I will again see if this is working
and I'll see you back here in a moment
okay all right so I just wanted to
confirm there that everything is uh
destroyed so we're all in good shape
okay so uh yeah so we're actually done
Sentinel now for real okay bye
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
hashicor Packer so it's a developer tool
to provision a build image that will be
stored in a repository using a build
image before you deploy provides you
with the following immutable
infrastructure your VMS and your Fleet
are all one-to-one in configuration
faster deploys for multiple servers
after each build earlier detection and
intervention of package changes or
deprecationable technology so let's take
a look at what that workflow would look
like so you'd have your code you commit
it to your CI CD Pipeline and within
that pipeline it would start up a build
server running uh Packer and that would
trigger a build image so you'd use a
something to provision it with so you
could use ansible or a variety of
different provisioners within Packer and
then Packer would then store it
somewhere so maybe this would be Amazon
machine image because you're deploying
to AWS
and then what you do is reference that
image in your terraform code and when
you provision it would get deployed to
your
CSP so this would be AWS in this case so
packet configurations is a machine uh
Packer configuration configures the
machine via oops
hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we are taking a look at hashicorp
Packers so Packer is a developer tool to
provision a build image that will be
stored in a repository so using a build
image before you deploy it's going to
give you the following benefits
immutable infrastructure your VMS and
your Fleet are all one-to-one
configuration faster deploys for
multiple servers after each build
earlier detection intervention of
package changes or deprecation volt
technology let's take a look at what
that workflow would look like so first
we'd have GitHub or or your git so
wherever you commit your changes and
from there that would trigger a CI CD
Pipeline with within that cicd pipeline
it would trigger a virtual machine so or
a build server that's a running Packer
and so that would trigger the build
image process from there Packer would
use some kind of provisioner like
ansible to provision the image and then
when it was done and and it was all good
it would store it summer like in Amazon
machine image once it is stored wherever
you want it to go then in terraform you
would just reference it using like a
data source and then from there you
could provision your resource okay so
Packer configures a machine via a packer
template and yes I know the E is missing
um so sorry about that but Packer
templates use the hashicorp
configuration language HCL which we saw
if you remember way earlier in the
course and that's what we're going to
review next is what that Packer template
file looks like okay
[Music]
all right so Packer configures a machine
or container via a packer template file
and Packer template uses the hashic
configuration language HCL so that's why
it looks very familiar to terraform and
a variety of other languages we've been
looking at in this course and so what
this file is doing is provisioning a
virtual machine on AWS so here you can
see that it's a TT micro and the US West
2 region that it's probably going to be
installing Apache since it's named httpd
and the way it's going to be created is
via an EBS volumes let's talk about kind
of the components that we're looking at
here so when you have a packer template
file you have to specify a source and
this says where and what kind of image
we are trying to build so the source is
Amazon EBS so it's looking for an Ami
image or it's being backed by that EBS
volume there okay in this case it's an
EBS back to Ami the image will be stored
directly in AWS under the ec2 images and
so we have the build step so the build
allows us to provide configuration
scripts Packers supports a wide range
your provisioners so we have shaft
puppet ansible power Powershell bash
salt whatever you want basically has it
and the post provisioners runs after the
image is built so they can be used to
upload artifacts or re-package them all
right and the place where this is going
to be stored is going to be on Amis okay
so there you go
[Music]
let's look at how we actually integrate
terraform and Packer together in terms
of a CI CD workflow we kind of saw this
in uh that overall graphic in the first
uh Packer slide let's just kind of look
at the code okay so to integrate Packer
there are two steps they're going to
build the image so Packer is not a
service but a development tool so you
need to manually run Packer or automate
the building of images with a build
server running Packer then the second
part of that is referencing the image so
once an image is built you can reference
reference the image as a data source so
if it's stored in Abus Ami we're going
to just Source it from there and the way
we select it is what we can do is say
okay get us the most recent one and use
this regular expression and the owner
has to be us and and those kind of
parameters to decide how to choose that
image so that's all there is to it
you're just using data sources to
reference them after they've already
been built okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at using Packer
with terraform and mostly it's just
about just using Packer uh and so what I
want to accomplish here is to generate
on an image and store that onto Amazon
machine images and then load that into a
terraform file or like reference it as a
data source so I've never done this
before but it should be fun and we'll
figure this out so what we're first
going to need to do is download Packer
so notice in the top right corner we
make your way to Packer however you want
to and we'll go ahead and download and
this one is for Windows it's a binary
but we are going to be using Linux we've
done this so many times these three two
commands so I'm not going to do that
again here but if you have yet to do so
you can go and run that and so I'm going
to go ahead and install Packer and once
Packer is installed I will come back
here and we will get to it okay all
right so after a short little weight
there Packer is installed and so what I
want to do is go into my Packer folder
here and I'm just going to run Packer
and see what we get
and so we have Packer build console fix
format a knit so install missing plugins
uh it looks kind of similar to terraform
build images from a template that sounds
kind of interesting so I think the first
thing we're going to need to do is
Define ourselves a template file so I
remember I researched one and and put
one in my uh slides here so let's make
our way over there and see if we can
kind of just like use our notes here as
a reference so going down to this Packer
file let's go ahead and just write one
here uh I don't say what the name of the
Packer file is that would probably help
but I believe that they're just named as
dot HCL files so what I'm going to do
is go into this here and make a new file
and we're going to say
um
uh I guess apache.htl since we are
already very familiar with how to
install Apache that seems like the
easiest way to do it and again this is
going to be very similar looking to
terraform because it's
you know all based on HCL so we'll do a
type
string
and we are going to need some kind of
default Ami so we can go grab the one
we've been using all along here
um I think we specified it
we can just go back to count Count's
always a good one to go to
um so I just want to go and grab
where is it
um count count count where are you you
see anybody see it
I'm blanking today so I'm just going to
grab it from AWS
it's not a big deal
I'm just pulling up AWS here we're going
to make our way over to ec2
and we're going to go ahead and launch
ourselves a new server actually I could
probably grab it from the old one no
I'll launch a new one just in case you
don't see anything there that might not
be fair I'm going to go ahead and grab
that Ami ID
and I'll just move that off screen here
for a moment and we're going to place in
that am ID because I assume we want one
to override then we're going to say
locals uh app name I think the example I
wrote here is is Apache because that is
what Apache is is httpd not sure how
they came up with that name but uh
that's how they call it so we need to
provide ourselves a source so we're
going to do Amazon EBS
httpdd
notice that like the source is not
called Data it's just called Source if
we go over to the documentation here
just what I want to show you here Docs
if it ever loads
come on docs you can do it
so down below here or on the left hand
side we have sources so I believe if we
were to go over to here and go over to
Amazon Ami
someone says Amazon MI
overview
uh
builders
ec2
EBS
I'm just trying to find the same kind of
information that it has there a
it's not really doing what I want but
anyway I know that this code is correct
even though we can't seem to find this
out probably just go type in Packer EBS
Amazon EBS I really like to always refer
to the documentation when I can here so
it does say it's a builder
Amazon abs
source
down below here we go
all right so yeah
um I don't understand this uh this
Builder flag as of yet but uh we'll work
our way through here and figure it out
okay so I'm gonna go back and pull up my
vs code here
and we're gonna put curlies here
and so we need our Mi name here
so my server
uh dollar sign local
app name
instance type
T2 micro
region this is going to be us East one
Source Ami this is going to be the
variable we set up above amiid
then we are going to do SSH username
that's going to be ec2 user that's the
default that AWS always has
uc2 user
we can do some tags here not really
necessary but it's good to probably give
it a name right so we'll just say name
Apache server
and actually we could probably just do
local.app name
maybe instead
and then we have our build step here so
we're going to specify our sources and
we're going to do
source.amazon ebs.htpd
and we're going to do provisioner
Pro
visioner
shell
and then we want to provide a script
I think we can we can actually do it in
line if we didn't want to do a script
there but we know our script works so
maybe we should just stick to that so
I'm just going to call this
userdata.sh because we already have that
somewhere
before so we'll do Post process we don't
need a post processor so we just want to
run that script
um
I believe we have that in our terraform
workflow
we go over there to our workflow
wherever it is
might also be under modules if we go
into our module here
didn't we create one there called user
data
oh that's a yaml file
uh okay
um I mean that's not a big deal we could
probably just
okay so we're not going to do it that
way all right um
if we're not going to do it this way we
probably can provide inline things we
don't probably have to do script equals
so what I'm going to do is go back to
the terraform documentation here or
Packer documentation I should say
and what I want to do is look at
provisioners
we're going to go look at Shell
so it has this inline step and I assume
that this is going to run in a
sequential order so inline array of
strings
okay so what we will do here is we will
type in inline
and I've done this like a thousand times
but I'm just going to go Google it
Apache install AWS tutorial
there's probably like one on the AWS
website for it
for like user data
and this is pretty much has some of it
here I was just kind of looking for
these commands like the Yum install and
the pseudosystem start
so we're going to go ahead and grab that
and then we're going to go
and grab the next few lines here
because we want to start and enable
what's the three things that we need to
do
not complicated at all
and so what I'm going to do is type in
Packer build and see what happens now I
didn't specify Ava's credentials or
anything like that I assume it would
pick up the defaults
and we're going to go to the top here so
it looks like we have to provide the
template name so maybe we'll do Apache
HCL here
and it says
error parsing Json invalid character V
for the beginning of the value
oh so it has to be
pkr.hcl okay
I'm really liking the user experience of
the developer experience for these clis
they're really good at telling us what's
wrong with them
PKR HCL if there's like a default file I
don't know what it should be called
uh so we got a bunch of Errors which is
fine unsupported argument locals an
argument locals is not expected here did
you mean to define a Local's Block it's
because I put an equals in front of it
supposed to just be this
not that we were really using locals for
much here
and looks like it is provisioning found
in Ami it's going to use that as the The
Source One creating a temporary key pair
authorizing to Port 22
uh name Packer Builder so I don't know
if this uses I don't think it does but I
don't know if it uses Amazon uh but
because there's like ec2 Builder image
there might be a way to use it with um
Packer directly but I'm not sure how to
do that
it's going to go through here I'm just
going to see to make sure it's not
running a pipeline here is it image
Pipelines
no okay that's good but what I will do
is go over to my ec2 here
and what I want to go do okay so Packer
Builders is running as a virtual machine
so it's actually
um uh going to spin up a VM and then
bake the Ami that way which seems a lot
better
um we'll go over to our Mis and see when
that happens there
um let's just unlock another those that
red stuff doesn't look good
seems like it didn't really matter
so the thing like AWS has an entire
pipeline for ec2 image Builder but it
does cost money to run where I kind of
feel like if all Packer is doing is
spinning up a virtual machine
temporarily to make that image that's
going to be a lot more cost effective
I mean we could go look up what the cost
is to use ec2 image Builder while we're
watching this
Builder can't seem to type today
uh it's pricing I just want to know the
pricing
happy free
oh is it there's a no cost I could have
swore there was a cost for this
no cost image Builders offered at no
cost other than the cost of the
underlying AWS resource I think the
thing is that it's that when you use
um ec2 image Builder you have to use of
a particular size
you know if you don't really use AWS
anymore in Azure gcp I can understand
why this is not much of an interest but
I'm pretty sure
if I go here
that the size that you get for the image
what size of
each image does ec2 image Builder use
because I remember it was like really
really large un like unreasonably large
and that was the cost involved in it
can't find it today it's not a big deal
but waiting for the Ami to become ready
so if we go over to our Amis here and
give us a refresh we can see that it is
spinning so it is provisioning that Ami
while that is going on what we can do is
just start setting up the next part of
this so
um Within
our Packer here we can say new file and
I'm going to say main.tf I'm going to go
as per usual and grab some default codes
from our account example which is for
right here
okay copy that we're going to go all the
way down to the ground here and
going to go into the main TF here paste
that on in
and we probably want to keep the public
IP around we actually don't really care
but I'm putting it in any way I'm going
to take out the tags oh I want to leave
the name in so I'll just say like server
packer
okay server Apache packer
and
uh this is the thing that we want to
replace out this all looks fine so this
is what we need to figure out is our Ami
here it's probably going to come in as a
data source it has to come in as a data
source and I'm pretty sure that's what I
wrote
in our documentation here so yeah AWS
Ami example things like that so
what we're going to do
is Type in AWS
am I
Packer image
and we'll just Define that data source
so AWS Ami
Packer image
and we have executable users executable
users equals self
I'm not saying I know what all these
options do but like you just go to the
documentation you grab them you got
something that works true name regex
okay and so we would do something like
start with the little carrot character
and what did we name this this starts
with uh my server hyphen
probably would have helped if we named
it with like something like
packer in the name but I think that's
fine
um
we might as well might might as well go
the full name here
and say httpd because that's technically
what it's going to be
we might want to match for more values
here so
I'm not sure I guess like we do that
because sometimes it's like three digits
or whatever but I don't know what Packer
is going to do if we keep pushing
additional ones I'm not really familiar
with with that so we'll just say owner's
equals self
and so now that should be all set up to
go as that is
running it finished so that's all good
we're going to say terraform init
and here it says block definition must
have a block content Eliminator
so we have a small problem here
it looks correct to me
uh this is not right okay
we'll see if we can knit this
now whether our build image works
properly I don't know
it'd be really good to write like some
tests for it I imagine that there is
some kind of way to do that
um
I guess it'd be like the post-processor
scripts maybe you'd want to do that
where you'd want to use that as a means
for
testing
I'm not really sure obviously different
provisioners might have that kind of
stuff built in so you know it might be
just part of the provisioning tool you
can use
so it initialized here we're going to do
a terraform plan
because I'm hoping that it might
complain about the data AWS Ami here if
it does not exist properly and it did so
your Curry return no results please
change your search criteria and try
again
so however I wrote this is probably not
correct so I will just take this out
here
try this
data a to the same at Packer no results
so what I'll do is go over to
bc2 here and actually that's the only
name that's here for the Ami so I guess
I could just go here and grab the name
but maybe that's not the problem oh no
that might be fine so we'll just do this
name reg X
okay
so let's go look up data AWS Ami
ex couple users most recent name regex
owners
maybe we can just do like a filter here
a regex to apply to an analyst returned
by AWS this allows for more advanced
filtering not supported by the AWS API
this filtering is done locally on the
AWS what returns
so I suppose that is good but like I
just need it to work
so I'm going to try the filter instead
and I'm actually going to put literally
the name in my server httpd
I'm going to take out the regex assuming
that is the problem
owners itself executable users itself
um please change the criteria
I don't know what executable users users
actually does let's maybe look up what
that is limit search to users with
explicit launch permissions on the image
is that required no so let's just take
that out
if more than one there isn't so let's
just take that out for the time being
who's the owner of this
we're the owner right we have to be
honors this IP address that must be us
or sorry not IP but like our account
number
so I mean that should be fine
incorrect attribute value type
oh okay so that was fine so we'll do dot
ID
but you know if you're doing this like
if you wanted a continuous pipeline
you'd probably want to get the most
recent and have a better regex
um and so I'll do a terraform apply Auto
approve and see if this works
one thing I kind of Wonder is like with
Packer how would you do like a
versioning
because that's what I'm not certain
about so like I'm just kind of like
looking through here and seeing what
they would do for that I would imagine
that uh you're probably supposed to like
increment it and have it part of the
name
nothing's really speaking to me there
but you know like
the idea is that you want to have things
like
zero zero zero zero one zero two zero
three
but I imagine like there's some
pragmatic way maybe there's like a
built-in function or something that we
can do to do that or what you do is you
just have a variable probably that's
actually what you probably do is you'd
have like variable
like version
right
string
and then you probably set it and it
would come through that way
like you you'd set it over here it says
our server has finished provisioning
let's go C and take see if that actually
worked we'll go up to ec2 instances here
that is running
copy that
paste that in
um the security group doesn't have any
open ports right
so it probably did work it's just we
didn't create a security group with us
so there are no open ports for us to
check I'm not worried about this I don't
care if it actually did work or not
because we more or less followed all the
steps there but I believe the reason
it's not working like there is just
because we don't have a security group
but I just don't want to fiddle with
that and put it into a state so that it
does not match so anyway we're all done
here so I'm going to do a terraform
apply Auto approve
destroy
so there we go we accomplished that with
Packer that pretty much wraps up all the
main follow-ons for the course so
hopefully that was a lot of fun
um yeah we'll just continue on here
[Music]
all right so let's talk about
terraforming console because you're
going to hear console mentioned
throughout the documentation and you
might think it's critical to the exam
but it's not so I just want to make sure
we understand its relation to terraform
so console is a service networking
platform which provides service
Discovery so central registry for
services in the network it allows for
direct communication so no single point
of failure via load balancers it has a
service mesh so managing Network traffic
between Services a communication layer
on top of your container application so
think middleware it has application
configuration capabilities so console is
useful when you have a micro service or
a service oriented architecture with
hundreds of thousands of services so
these are containerized apps or
workloads and so the way console
integrates with terraform is in the
following ways it is a remote back end
because console has a key value store
and this is where you could store the
state of your terraform files then also
there's a console provider because you
can use terraform to set up some things
in console for you but there's not much
else outside of that okay
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
hashicor Vault so vault is a tool for
securing accessing secrets from multiple
secret data stores vault is deployed to
a server where a vault admin can
directly manage secrets and we have
operators also known as developers can
access Secrets via an API Vault provides
a unified interface to any secret such
as AWS Secrets console key values Google
Cloud KMS Azure service principles it
provides tights access control so just
in time which is reducing surface
attacks based on a range of time and
just enough privilege so reducing
surface attack by providing at least
permissive permissions we can also
record a detailed audit log so we have
tamper evidence so this is kind of the
idea of our little hash Decor fault
stack so you have your secrets engines
these are third-party services or sorry
cloud services that actually store the
secrets you have your Vault cluster
which act as the adapter to your
resources and the resources which are
going to access them so again vault is
deploy to Virtual machines in a cluster
and vaults can be backed up via snapshot
so if you do provision them and you're
worried about the state of those vaults
you can definitely save those for later
okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at terraform and
Vault how they would work together so
when a developer is working with
terraform and they need to deploy a
provider like AWS they will need AWS
credentials so AWS credentials are
long-lived meaning a user generates a
key in secret and they are usable until
they are deleted so the Abus credentials
reside on the developers local machine
and so the machine is at risk of being
compromised by malicious actors looking
to steal this credentials so if we could
provide credentials just in time expires
or credentials after a short amount of
time so short-lived we could reduce the
attack surface area of the local machine
and so this is where Vault comes in
because Vault can be used to inject
short-lived Secrets at the time of
terraform apply so imagine you are you
are the developer and you run your
terraform apply at that point in time
it's going to inject the secrets the way
we do that is via data sources data
source is always the way we get data
into our terraform configuration file
but let's look at that in Greater detail
in the next slide here okay
foreign
[Music]
let's take a look at how this Vault
injection via data source works so a
vault server is provisioned a vault
engine is configured like AWS Secrets
engine The Vault will create a machine
user for AWS fault will generate a
short-lived AWS credential for that
machine user thought we'll manage and
apply database policy and then within
our terraform we can provide a data
source to the Vault so that's what we're
doing we're saying Vault Ibis access
credentials and we are getting the
output from our terraform remote State
admin outputs backend and then from
there we can reference them into AWS
okay so when terraform applies run it
will pull short-lived credentials to be
used used for the scope of the duration
of the current run every time you run
apply you will get a new short lived
credentials which is the whole point of
the short-lived idea okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at Vault
um and so the idea here is that we want
to be able to inject secrets from vault
in a secure manner for our local
developer environments I really kind of
wish I included this screenshot or this
graphic within my slides I just found it
as as of now because it does really
represent all the types of secret
engines and capabilities of Vault one
thing in particular I wasn't aware of is
that it has its own key value store so
that's what we're going to be using
we're going to keep it really simple
here
um but the first thing we're going to
have to do is go ahead and install Vault
so just down below I have a link here
that I found and we'll go down below and
it's not shouldn't be too hard to
install so
uh we are on Linux today I mean I'm on a
Windows machine but I'm using Linux
um as the windows subsystem there and so
this is where we're going to start and
grab our stuff so making my way over to
vs code whoops
um and
I'm just trying to think should we use
this for a new project probably so I'm
going to just CD out here
and I'm going to make my way into
uh vault which apparently I don't have a
folder for so I'm going to just go here
and we're going to
uh if I reveal and explore
and we'll make a new one
200 volts
okay and so
we'll start first install something then
we'll set up a project all right so
um
let's go through the installation
process here okay so we'll go do a curl
which is our first step
and that's just going to grab the gpg I
think we already have it because we did
it for probably the the CLI 4
terraform there but we'll just do it
again there it doesn't hurt I'll add the
repository again I think we already did
this when we installed the CLI in the
beginning of this course
but we'll let it go again there I
remember this takes a little bit of time
so we'll just wait here for a bit
all right so now we need to run the last
command which is actually going to go
ahead and install Vault here for us
we'll just go ahead and grab that line
and I'm going to go ahead and paste that
on in
I'm not sure if I grabbed that properly
we'll try that one more time
it uh I got my consoles on response so
there we go okay
just happens when I um I stop and start
recording it just for some reason times
out like that so I'll go ahead and hit
enter there and that will go ahead and
install our vaults and then after that
we're going to have to start getting it
running
um there is again a tutorial to inject
secrets I'm not going to stick one to
one with it because it does come with a
repository but I find that it is a
little bit more work than we want to do
here we just want to kind of get a basic
example working and I just want to make
our lives a little bit easier so I'm
just going to modify it as we go here
but uh yeah we'll just wait for that to
install I'll see you back here in a
moment okay all right so after a short
little weight here I believe that vault
is installed let's find out if it works
so we'll type in Vault
once I get the responsiveness back from
my console here just giving it a moment
great nope nope there we go Vault and so
vault is there and so what we can do is
start it up in a developer mode and I
remember from here they actually had
some pretty good instructions on the
starting of that so
um like the way they do this project and
I have the repo here is that they
um they provision Vault with a bunch of
different things so I think they're
using like S3 here and that would
probably be a really common use case for
this but I really want to simplify and I
don't want to have to provision that
terraform and cross-reference the stuff
so we're just going to simplify that so
I'm just looking for the command to
start fault because I saw a good one
here that was like vaults
um ah here it is right there so Vault
server hyphen dab that starts in the
developer mode Dev root token ID there's
something about like ceiling or
unsealing stuff I don't know what that
means but I assume that's a way of
securing the Vault but we're going to go
ahead ahead and just type that in so
we're going to go Vault server hyphen
Dev hyphen Dev root token ID and
obviously you wouldn't want to do this
for your production they call there's
education I'm just going to stick with
that to make our lives a bit easier and
so what that's going to do is start up a
vault server it is running on this port
here so I suppose we should export that
or or keep this because we'll probably
have to reference it somehow notice we
have this like unsealed key so the
unsealed key and root token are
displayed Below in case you want to seal
or re-authenticate
um developments should not be used in
production so what I'm going to do
is I'm just going to create a
uh uh a readme file in our vault here so
we'll just say new file read me because
I just want to dump this stuff of course
you know you should not share these with
anybody but I just don't want to forget
these while we're working through this
so I'm going to go ahead and copy that
and we will go ahead and save that
and
so
what I want to do now oops
did we lose our terminal
did I close it
okay I must have closed it so which one
were we working in second third one
which is it
fourth okay it's the third one so
don't be like me close out your old one
so I'm just gonna close out these old
ones so I'm less confused
there we go and so it says that it
started on this address here so I'm
gonna go copy that address
and we're going to open this up you can
do everything via the CLI
uh I just want to
copy that there
but they have a nice UI which is nice
and so this is where we're going to put
that token education and drop that down
so there are some other options where
there's a lot of options for
authenticating but token is obviously
the easiest probably not the most secure
because the way we wrote it and notice
that we have a couple things
pre-installed so we have cubbyhole which
is a per token private secret storage
and then we have key value secret
storage again I don't know much about
these because this isn't a um
this isn't a course on vault it's just
kind of us showing a basic integration
and more focus on the terraform side but
here is where we can create our secrets
we can of course use the CLI to do that
and I think they showed in the getting
started here
and we don't have to do it this way I'd
rather do it through your eye but you do
like vault key key V put and then you
put the name of your secret so here's
secret forward slash hello and then the
key and the value that's where the store
I assume that this would go to the well
this would specify we're using here so
what we'll do is we'll go over here
and we'll create ourselves a new secret
because we're going to want to store
something here so we want the path for
the secret
this is pretty common with um if you've
ever used parameter store you have a
path
I don't know if it starts with a forward
slash
may not end in a forward slash probably
can begin with it so I'm going to say
AWS key because we'll do the key in the
secret right so here
oh okay cool cool so we can do forward
slash AWS and then down below I would
just add another one
maybe I got to add each one at a time so
we'll say key
and I'll actually go grab our proper
ones
um oh I should have stopped that I'm
going to
start that up again
okay and we'll add a plus there because
everything lives in memory when you're
in the dev one so you really don't want
to shut that down or you'll have to redo
all this from scratch so what I'm going
to do is just go back
here and drag this down a little bit
more
okay and I'm just gonna go see if I have
to re-log in because I might have messed
this all up
yes I do so we'll type in education so
we really don't want to stop running
that server during the duration of this
follow along okay and so we'll go back
into secret here create a secret
forward slash AWS
uh what do you want is it Json no I
don't think it matters
if we can add two keys that's all that
matters to me and so what I'm going to
do
is cat out
credentials of course this is not the
secure way of doing it so you know again
don't show people these things and so I
want this and I probably should match
the name
I'm gonna like type in the whole darn
thing
and we'll grab this
oops
I want to see that value is correct good
we're going to add another one here this
is going to be our axis Secrets or axis
secret access key I really don't like
how those have been named and we'll go
ahead and grab on this
and
um I mean we don't really need to really
store the region here but why not
because we're doing all the rest to here
we might as well just throw them all in
here
for fun
and uh here it says maximum number of
versions I don't need anything beyond
one because we're not going to be
updating these
um require check and set so rights will
only be allowed if the keys current
version matches the version specified in
the cas parameter not sure what that
means maybe just like you're passing
something along when you are doing
something but uh I think this is all
good
you know what I'm just going to leave
that back to 10 just in case I've made a
mistake and we have to go debug that I'm
going to go hit save and so there are
secrets
um and so what we want to do is be able
to access them and so maybe this is our
opportunity to learn the CLI here a bit
so I have it pulled up on the left hand
side and so what I'm going to do is type
in vault key V get and we'll do AWS I
don't know if we can start with the
forward slash there I'm going to hit
enter
and
um the server gave an HTTP response to
an https client
so I'm not sure
why that's a problem because
like I mean I understand that it started
up in HT http
but I mean I'm in development so you
know what else am I going to really do
here
let's see if I can just scroll up here
and if there's anything else
um
hmm
and I could have swore that it installed
a private key as we were doing this
because I remember seeing that there
was like a private key
I could have swore there was one
something but private key
so I'm not sure what the problem is here
I'll be back in a moment and I will
resolve it okay
so the suggestion I'm getting is that we
need to
um export a couple of environment
variables
so see here where it writes this so we
say you need to set the following so
maybe we will go through and set those
so I'll go grab that there but here's
the thing is like how do I run that
because these are I think these are like
not the same so I mean I can't run it
over here can I
I don't think so
uh well I guess if we're doing key Vault
value there maybe we can
um still no good what if we export The
Vault token
I think we said it was education here
um
let's do Vault status
so yeah I'm not sure how we're going to
do it that way I mean it's not a really
big deal because I don't think that we
have to access it that way but notice
here like as I was reading here you know
they're just saying down below oh we had
to set this and that so I'm not really
sure
what I would do here so the output is
like this
run these commands and it should do it
again the error message can be similar
to different problems so that or maybe
I'm just specifying the key incorrectly
and that's why it doesn't like it so
[Music]
um
let's just type in Vault and see what we
have here so Vault QV
maybe if we do like a list can we get a
list
list the secrets
um AWS
AWS
clear
I'm not sure what parameter it wants
there
uh let's go look it up so let's say like
tariff or was it vault key V list option
seems to want another parameter here
I'm going to scroll on down so Secret
forward slash my app
um folders are suffixed with the forward
slash the input must be a folder list of
a file will not return
um do I have to put Secret in front of
it
Secret
AWS
no so I don't know what the issue is
there I just would have been nice to use
it via the CLI but the thing is is that
again we don't need to use it that way
we just need to
um you know set it and and get it but I
thought it would be fun to kind of see a
lie there so now that we have those set
the way we're going to extract out these
values is by using a data source and so
what I want to do is just create a new
local project and I think we'd like to
always pull from our account repo here
so I'm going to go all the way up to
here and I'm going to go grab the main
and I'm just going to copy the contents
there we're going to go all the way down
to the ground and we're going to make a
new
main TF file here
we're gonna go paste that on in
and uh we just want my server
we don't need an output it's fine
this is all fine this is all fine but uh
the one thing is we don't want to use
our particular provider there so what
I'm going to do
um is I'm going to just open up our
credentials file there
and I'm just going to change this to
something else like other so that it
doesn't load that profile there
okay I just
take these out of here
um I think we can leave that alone
and I think that's everything so what I
want to do now we don't need that count
we'll get rid of that count
we'll go check out the documentation or
the code base here
because it gives us a bit of an idea how
we need to implement this
we'll go over the operator
we'll go over to the main
and so they're setting some variables
here like name region path things like
that but again we want to grab it from
The Source there actually
cross-referencing it like this other
they provision the admin and grabbing it
that way I don't want to do it that way
I wanted to use just the data source
like this
so
I'm not sure how that's going to work so
let's go look that up
okay so here it says read it was
credentials from an AWS secret back end
and I'm not trying to do that I'm just
trying to read them from the key vaults
okay so we probably want faults
generic secret would this be from Key
vault
this resource is primarily intended to
be used with the generic secret back end
but it is also compatible with any Vault
endpoint that is provided
but is that the key value one that's not
clear to me
um so I think it is
so let's see if we can figure that out
here so I'm just going to move that off
screen here
and we're going to add ourselves the
data source so I guess we're really not
following the other tutorial at all
because it we literally have to use a
different
um
key value there a
so we'll say secrets and this is going
to be like AWS
credentials Maybe
there's creds they don't have to worry
about spelling mistakes and we need to
specify a path notice it always starts
with like secret I don't know if we
always have to start it with secret so I
will just say AWS here
and there might be some additional
options I'm just scrolling through to
hear that so you have paths so this is
the fully the full logical path from
which to request the data to read data
from generic secret back in Mountain
Vault by default this should be prefix
with secret forward slash so we do have
to do that reading from other back ends
as data sources possible consult each
back-end documentation to see which
endpoint supports the get version
version of the secret to read we only
have a single version so we don't have
to specify that so technically that
should be correct
so what we will want to do now in our
provider is specify all those options
so again I'm just going back to the
source code this is off screen but we
need to set the region the access key
and the secret key here
and so this is going to be data and it's
going to be
Vault generic Secret
and I guess it would be AWS
and then we're accessing those things
like region
and so I'm going to go ahead and just
copy that really quickly
and we will go over back to our vault
here because the names are over here
so go grab that paste that in there
we'll go grab that paste that in there
and I'm just going to double check to
make sure if I've made any mistakes
this one it's showing it from the admin
so it goes admin outputs but we're not
outputting from anything we're just
grabbing it from uh the Vault there so
maybe what we need to do is just kind of
review
how this generic fault works
so this does Data Vault generic and then
it does data and then Square braces
so I wonder if we always have to do data
so for example The Vault there is a a
key named auth token the value is a
token that we need to keep Secret
but yeah I don't understand is this a
Json object or just a way of referencing
it because it doesn't specify that so
we'll just give it a try
nothing hurts with trying right so we'll
say data
and this might again might not be the
right way I don't know if it's single or
doubles there it's doubles
so I just wonder if that was like the
one case where it's doubles
okay and we will do this
and so I think that that should
maybe work
don't know
what I'm wondering is if I if I live
with a forward slash would it have
considered that and or is it now double
but I don't think so because look here
it looks like it's stripped it out
because it just says AWS here so we got
a secret since just AWS
almost looks like there's a space in the
front of it eh
but it's not there so maybe there's not
this is kind of like a little glitch so
um
we need to go and CD into this directory
here
and we just need to do a terraforming
knit
that's kind of interesting because like
we haven't set up the provider
I guess it's not going to happen until
we actually use the provider so maybe
it's not an issue just yet
I'm curious to see if it pulls any kind
of modules in for the vault generic
Secret
so we'll just give it a moment there to
initialize
okay so after there we can see that it
did actually add vault in so it must be
ready to take it from there
um I'm going to do a terraform plan here
and you know I'm going to just change
this to like my server with vaults
now remember it's not going to be able
to pull from the um
from our local credentials because we're
not setting a profile and we overroad
the default just in case
so here it's saying a resource a data
resource Vault generic secret AWS has
not been declared in the root module
um it hasn't I mean it looks like I did
no maybe I typed it wrong so we'll go
here I don't think it matters but I'll
just put it above
okay and I'm just going to double check
to make sure nope it matches oh because
it's eight of his creds that's fair
um you didn't use the option o that's
fine so my question will be will this
correctly provision because we will not
know until we uh use this right here I
suppose if we try to use a data source
for AWS that would probably also
indicate whether it's working or not so
maybe we should try doing that
we do like data AWS VPC
and then we just do like ID equals here
because that would have to use the
credentials right
and so we'll just go well that's
actually it's not specifying any of the
the VPC here so maybe maybe we won't do
that because it's just too much work
um so what I'll do here
is I'm going to do a terraform apply
Auto approve
and Let's cross our fingers and hope
this works
and while that is running what I'm going
to do is just pull up my AWS environment
here
and apparently I'm not logged in so
that'll give me a bit of time here to
kind of catch up here while this is
provisioning there
and so it looks like it actually
provisioned the server and if that's the
case that means that our secrets are
being pulled correctly right so if we go
over to ec2 here
and we go and check out this instance it
is running so it worked
um if we just want to do a sanity check
to make sure it absolutely is working we
can just introduce a bug into this
so maybe we go here and we just say
uh um I guess we'd have to make a new
version create a new version and what
I'm going to do is purposely introduce
some mistakes so we're just going to put
like an at sign here on the end we're
going to save that and I'm going to make
a minor change like Nano
and so what I'm expecting is for this to
fail let's see if it fails on the plan I
don't think it will
give it a fail in the apply and it does
okay so the plan would tell us whether
it didn't work or not so that clearly uh
clearly means it absolutely is pulling
from it especially when we're doing the
plan
so
um I want to go back to
our file there I just kind of lost the
folder I'm just looking for it the I got
too many um too many Chrome windows open
here
there it is okay so we'll go back here
and we'll
I wonder if we can just revert back to
the previous version
um see I don't know if I would delete
there I don't want to I don't want to
jinx it so I'm just going to go here
and take out that at sign we're going to
go ahead and save that and so that
should be updated we're going to do
terraform plan
great and so what I want to do is just
tear this down so we'll say terraform
apply Auto approve and Destroy okay and
while that is destroying I'm pretty
pretty confident that's going to work
I'm going to stop my Vault server oh
wait
is that going to still work did I get
the credentials in time
oh no I I made a big boo-boo okay so
um
I I Killed My Vault server before I was
supposed to
that's really embarrassing
um anyway that's not a big deal because
I kind of wanted to stop the server
anyway
but I want to go back into our it was
credentials there and turn that back to
defaults
and I wanted to go back up here and just
flip that back so that we can get rid of
the server right so I don't want to kind
of lose these for the tutorial so I'm
just going to go here and just comment
those out for a second
profile defaults
oops
region
Us East one
and
um we'll do that again that's
embarrassing
okay and I'm just going to preemptively
I'm not going to save this file but I'm
just going to do this for now
um it's still trying to connect
oh boy
so
just put these back in here
because it's set to the Vault can I do a
terraform refresh probably not
no probably not what if I do a
terraforming net because I did change
like I was using Vault so maybe I just
have to do that to fix that problem
and let's try destroy again
that was a big boo-boo on my part eh
nope okay so let's go back over here
and start it up again and I'm pretty
sure there's like a way to back up your
vaults like there's probably some kind
of like snapshot or something
um again I'm not that uh deep into it so
I cannot tell you if that's the case
um so I guess we'll just go back here
and remake our secrets
because it shouldn't have persisted
right
if it did I'd be so happy
nope okay
AWS we'll leave 10 in there and then
we'll just have to copy all this stuff
over again because of my
bonehead mistake there so we have region
which is Us East one
U.S east one here
and uh
go over here
well at least you know what to do if
that happens to you okay
I don't need the uh equal sign there
go ahead and add this one
okay and what we're going to do is go
ahead and save that
and we'll just quit out of that we'll do
a terraform plan
since we know that that will pick it up
right
and uh we'll do terraform apply Auto
approve destroy
Okay so
again this only applies to development
but uh yeah don't kill your Vault server
before you're done destroying okay
so I'll see you back here in a moment
all right so that infrastructure is
destroyed we can go back to here and
then we can stop our server and for your
benefit I'm just going to bring back
these in here
so you don't have to worry about that
and uh yeah we uh we accomplished Vault
for injections now you might say well
how would you do this with terraform
Cloud well the thing is is that
terraform Cloud already uses
uh Vault Under the Hood when you store
your environment variables there and the
idea is that uh I suppose you don't need
to pull them in from all those sources
but I think that was one of my my
questions I had when I was talking to
one of the DA's which was like okay it's
great that terraform cloud has
um uh you know uses behind the scenes
but what if I want that to live
somewhere else but maybe that's not
really necessary
um because I don't know but yeah that's
it so we're all done with vaults
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at Atlantis
which is an open source developer tool
to automate terraform pull requests
which you can find at run atlantis.io so
the idea is once this is installed on
your GitHub and you merge a pull request
then it's going to go ahead and do a
terraform apply so this would be a way
for you to do
um get Ops or to automate your uh your
infrastructure as code and the
interesting thing is that hashicorp
actually maintains this project they
didn't originally build it was built by
two people from another company and it
wasn't that they did not want to use
terraform Cloud which can do this but at
the time I think they had a hard time at
the company getting procurement because
it was a very large company and so they
had to build something so they built out
this thing
and anyway these two people end up
getting hired by hashicorp and hashicorp
maintains this project which is really
nice because it is an alternative for
terraform Cloud
um but uh yeah that's all
foreign
[Music]
let's take a look at cdk for terraform
and so to understand this we need to
First understand what is cdk so AWS
Cloud development kit is an imperative
infrastructure as code tool with sdks
for your favorite language so the idea
is that you can use something like
typescript python Java c-sharp go and
Ruby Ruby's definitely there that's the
language I like to use AWS cdk is
intended only for AWS Cloud resources
because cdk generates a cloud formation
so CFN templates this is known as
synthesizing and uses that for IAC but
cdk for terraform is a standalone
project by hashicorp that allows you to
use cdk but instead of CFN templates it
generates out it's going to generate
terraform templates and so basically
anything terraform can do you can do it
through cdk and that allows you to do
interesting things like use cdk to
provision Azure resources so that is
very interesting uh and a great
development that I think that they're
doing
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at grunt work
which is a software company that builds
devops tools that extends or leverages
terraform the reason we're talking about
them is that they produce a couple of
very popular open source tools that work
with terraform and you're going to see
their name because
um uh you know the co-founders there are
very active in the community uh Jim has
wrote in a really good book on terraform
so you know it's no surprise that uh
they are present but it's worth giving
them a mention so you know who they are
uh the first thing I want to mention is
the infrastructure is the code Library
so these are a bunch of reusable battle
tested production ready infrastructure
code for AWS gcp Azure
um and so they have some free ones there
and some paid ones there then there's
teragram so a thin wrapper that provides
extra tools for keeping your
configurations dry we have terror tests
a testing framework for infrastructure
provisioned with terraform we have grunt
work Landing zones for AWS this is a
multi-count security on AWS we have
grunt work pipelines and then there's
the grunt work reference architecture
and so where we're going to focus our
attention in here is just on Terra Grunt
and Terra tasks because those are things
I think are essential to know if you are
using terraform because you know you'll
run into those use cases where you might
want to use them okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
teragram so this is a thin wrapper for
terraform that provides extra tools for
keeping your configuration dry working
with multiple terraform modules managing
remote State and this is accessible to
tariff Terra
grunt.gruntwork.io so the idea here is
the concept of don't repeat yourself so
it's a programming methodology to
abstract repeated code into functions
and modules or libraries and often in
isolate files to reduce code complexity
efforts and errors so the way that works
is that you'll see these HCL files which
are the Terra grunt code and they're
actually named Terra grant.hcl and
that's what's going to be used to
abstract away or dry up your terraform
files so here is an example of Terror
run now Terra Grant does a lot of
different things and you're going to
find its use when you actually use
terraform and practice and you run into
these limitations in terraform and you
go and I wish there was a way around it
integrine like almost always solves that
and so one example is being able to
generate rate Dynamic providers and I
don't mean like Dynamic values here in
the sense that there's that Dynamic
value feature of terraform but I just
mean the fact that at the time of this
it's very hard to inject or to write out
providers so they have this generate
function that allows you to get around
that
another really interesting thing is that
Terra grunt supports better granular
literary for modules by reducing lots of
boilerplate uh the way they do this is
is that you are referencing your
terraform files uh via the source here
okay so you're not including your
modules within your code you're just
referencing them and then you pass along
their inputs and this is going to be
very important when we look at wanting
to write unit tests for your
infrastructure because when you learn
about how you test IAC you have to
really break things down into smaller
parts and if you have a lot of friction
there it's going to make your team not
want to adopt that or it's going to make
that process really slow but again this
is more like at scale or when you hit
these kind of requirements okay
oh
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
testing and terraform and so what we
have here on the left hand side is our
usual
um pyramid that tells us the layers of
testing and so I kind of want to walk
through the layers there and talk about
a bit of the tools that are available to
the terraform community and you know the
reason why we want to move up the
pyramid here to get uh better tests and
then we'll take a look at Terra test so
at the bottom we have static analysis
and this is where you test your code
without deploying and you've been doing
it all along when you do terraform
validate terraform plan or you're using
Sentinel you're doing static analysis
and that just means that we're testing
you know like the composition or the the
shape of our code or like its outputs to
what it says it should be doing okay but
you can't catch all your problems there
and that's where you move on to unit
testing and unit testing uh you know
traditionally means like in programming
to test like a particular function its
inputs and its outputs it's a little bit
harder for infrastructure because
um you know you have to have it
connected to other things so it the
definite sessions a little bit warped
but the idea here and specifically with
terraform is you're just testing a
single module and that really says like
okay well you need to really Pare down
that module to be of the small scope and
that's where you end up dividing your
modules into very small units of work
and so for tooling here we got Terra
Test Kitchen uh terraform and inspec
um and so uh yeah that's where that
motivation came with um you know Terra
Grande the last thing saying okay let's
split them up into smaller stuff uh we
have integration testing this is pretty
much just using multiple
um uh modules together you know so you
say okay well I know that this Lambda
function is working but do I know it
works in conjunction with this sqsq or
something like that then you have
end-to-end testing and this is where
you're testing basically like business
use cases so it's not just saying okay
from a technical perspective but from a
business use case do or the customer use
case do we meet the requirements here uh
and this uh is very hard because what
you have to actually do is set up a
persistent test Network environment but
once you have one you're going to be
really good shape one example of a test
environment and it is paid but
groundwork has their own called the
grunt work reference architecture uh but
you know if you had to do it without
that you'd have to just roll your own
kind of environment
so you know if you do want a good
breakdown of all these different kinds
uh you know Jim from grunt work has a
complete talk on automated testing for
infrastructure as a code I strongly
recommend it because it really gives you
a better scope than what I can cover
here
um but let's just go take a quick look
at Terra test so Terra test allows you
to perform unit tests and integration
tests on your infrastructure it tests
your infrastructure by temporarily
deploying it validating the results then
tearing down the test environment and so
here's an example of what a a test
function would look like in Terror test
it is written in golang I know golang
can be very hard to use but you don't
need to know much about it if you you
pretty much copy and paste it and just
kind of tweak the values to get the
result you want so you know hopefully
that helps to tell you how you would
test in terraform and you know that
about Terra test okay